h
just I
love love
come
show
this
is this is
not
think it's
generation
we
for
by that the one that says speak okay and
everyone should know that if you have
the red button pushed the speakers are
on all over the room so everyone can
hear what you say so if you're like
having a side conversation call
correct okay Iran okay all right even
though it might be true uh all right uh
I'd ask uh let we start with a pledge
I'd ask
representative bton if you would lead us
in the
fledge right behind
it to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for
all all right welcome to the
first uh resources Recreation and
Development Committee hearing of it is
2022 Now isn't it
uh this is our first time we're in a
rather
is all of this covid seating and things
like that uh we when I before I open up
uh
the the hearing uh for those who are
this might be their first time you're
going to appear or wish to speak on a
bill
uh you're gonna going to speak on a bill
uh you have to have a pink card and uh
you know put on whether you support
support the bill or oppose the
bill uh you should also have your name
address who you rep who you
represent uh
and uh the time needed to
speak
so you when you so when you fill out the
card you just pass it up and it'll get
passed up uh to the to the clerk uh I
have uh two cards for the next bill let
me open the hearing
on how House Bill 1339 relative to
winnipauk River Basin
control replacement fund representative
Johnson uh I don't think we don't need a
we don't need a roll
call this is uh this for I usually don't
call a roll call for the hearing uh
because a hearing
is well the you you can the actual
Quorum can be as little as uh as one
representative there been times when
there been close to one Representatives
when the snow when the snow is a half a
foot
outside uh representative uh okay
representative Johnson you wish to speak
on your
bill yeah press the button there we go
yes thank you all for taking the time to
talk to me today be patient with me this
is my first
bill um so I'm gonna introduce um Wes
Anderson he is the chair of the um wiip
basaki uh River Basin he has all the
information on this bill um it is
actually more of a housekeeping Bill
than anything and um he has all the
information that you know can explain it
all better and more in depth for you
all first of all just for formality are
there any questions of Representative
Johnson I don't believe there will
be thank you very
much all right could you could you
identify yourself I'm Wes Anderson the
director of public works for the city of
Bonia and I'm also the chair of the
winaki river Bas and Advisory Board
program okay can anyone everyone hear
him well
enough yeah if you if you could yeah
okay talk right inway that
better all right so the board consists
of 10 municipalities and organizations
that send their sewage to the program's
Regional treatment plant in Franklin the
regional collection system in the
treatment plant is operated in Hampshire
Department environmental services and
the advisory board's main function is to
review the capital Improvement program
review the contracts to plan design and
constructive Capital Improvements that
require approval by the governor and
executive councel and to review the
program's budget 10 member communities
pay all costs associated with the
operations and maintenance of the system
the only state funds the program
receives are from Grants and loans that
any sewage treatment plant can receive
in the state there have been no major
changes to the systems cost distribution
plan since the 1980s when the uh system
began operations the board its member
communities and the program
administrator have been working for
several years on changes to the funding
model to reflect more
closely the the current usage of the
system of by the member communities and
organizations the reason why this is
necessary is Municipal growth rates do
not reflect what they were predicting
back into the 1980s we have found that
water consumption changes
water consumption itself is dropping due
to changes in the more efficient systems
that you find in homes and the
maintenance and repair of the municipal
old own system varies between
communities the members are build to
support costs of four functions the
methods for updating the distribution of
costs or three of the four functions can
be updated without any change to the
existing laws the fourth the replacement
fund can only be updated through
legislation the replacement fund is the
account the Department of Environmental
Services uses to fund the cost of
unanticipated repairs that cost between
that cost more than they can be funded
through the operation maintenance
account and they're really less than you
you do with a bond so it's in that
spot presently the cost or repairs
funded through the replacement fund are
distributed to member communities based
on their use of that portion of the
system that failed the impacted
municipalities are required to pay back
that fund the cost of those repairs over
10 years the proposed change approved by
the member communities will have the
impacted communities pay 50% of the cost
of repairs and the other 50% will be
distributed based on the respective use
of the
infrastructure all other aspects of the
existing law on changed except for some
clarifying language regarding the
proportional assessment of the fund as
established by the Attorney General's
office during the review of the draft
legislation the member communities asked
for your support to change the laws on
the wi of basaki river place and
programs replacement fund and we thank
you for considering our
request subject to your
questions first of all you do have say
you have written testimony I do I have
copies uh we have 21 members I didn't
know that at the
time
def definitely make certain the clerk
receives
the I don't need
one uh Al also representative Johnson if
you could fill out a pink card
and pass it up
uh any questions uh
for Mr
Anderson Mr
chair yeah first I wanted to comment
that I can hear this are you hearing me
through a speaker okay the gentleman who
just testified I did not hear him
through my speaker and it didn't sound
like the mic was working all that well
so I don't know if it's just you have to
get closer or is the red and everyone
should know the red light has to be on
for you to be able to hear people
through the speaker um but the question
I have for you um Mr Anderson is the um
I might have missed this but the the uh
in quite a few places like on line 13 of
the bill it changed total fund to Total
fund
capital and I wondered uh the reason for
that change
part of that was part of that was the
clarifying language from the Attorney
General's office our change really
focused on how we just distributed the
cost portion okay thank
you any other questions representative
gron the you want the red light
on uh the one with the
the one on your
right yeah
he's our are
only oh yours are
okay not through not through the
mic green doesn't
work oh you
don't okay time to call
it
okay all right now I'm on I think you
can only have one red on at a
time okay now just to just to clarify
thank you Mr chairman just to
clarify uh that the 10 Towns uh
represented in this bill have all agreed
uh to this plan and they're all they're
all good with it correct we made sure
that the Advisory Board didn't take a
vote to all four communities governing
councils whether it's a Selectmen or in
one case it's a district uh made their
determination before we took the vote
and all 100% agreed okay thank you
sir
anyone
else for anyone else for a
question uh representative uh Johnson
did you have a a list of uh
informational questions that you wanted
to uh uh you said they were available
here there are
not so um I some of the questions that I
had talked with uh West about was was
the like he said The Advisory Board was
completely unanimous about making these
changes um in the last three years the
fund um was used to pay for $900,000
project to repair a uh forc main break
on pedon beach in lonia 90% of the flow
in this line was from Guilford 10% of
the flow was for lonia
um these are just some of the recent
Replacements that had to be done it was
also been used to repair two Force main
Brakes in Belmont and the force uh main
only supported the town of
Belmont all right
uh that being the case
uh is in there there no other questions
uh for
[Music]
the Mr Anderson or uh repres
representative Johnson uh that thank you
very much um I'll come in
to come to call the next witnesses there
is
uh Sharon
McMillan please introduce yourself and
uh move your refence
good morning my name is Sharon McMillan
I'm the environmental program administer
for the winaki River Basin program um
managed by Department of Environmental
Services and I'm here simply to answer
any further questions that uh the
members may
have thank you are there any uh
questions for uh Miss
Anderson or excuse me uh MC V I'm sorry
beg your pardon uh they
uh seeing none is oh I'm sorry
I is is the department in approval of
this project or the
change um the department is taking no
position on
this is there any other other
questions is there anyone who wishes to
to testify well excuse me uh thank you
very
much is there anyone in the audience who
wishes to
testify if not anyone know nothing else
on the
committee which case I'll declare the
hearing closed on
1339 and
uh and we're on a break
until where is my chart okay
9:45 I I apologize to the committee I
thought we'd take an easy one to start
with I didn't think it would be quite
that
easy
Mr chair I just wanted to say uh good
morning my name is Timothy Egan I'm from
Crafton 2 and Sugar Hill Franconia
Lisbon Lyman Monroe and I'm excited to
be serving on this committee thank you
for uh having me all I look forward to
meeting most of you uh only a few of you
I know um but if I can be of any insight
to the North Country I know there's a
fellow North Country representative on
your committee as well but I'm excited I
serve on Fish and Game and Marine
Resources as my other committee so I try
to think big picture about uh the
natural resources that our constituents
uh value here in the state and hope to
bring that to bear in my committee work
thank
you and I apologize for uh being remiss
and not introducing folks it's what
happens when you stay out when you're
when you're talking outside then all of
a sudden you look at your watch and it's
oh my God it's 9:00 uh and and I walked
in the door at like 9:01 so that's okay
that's representative Huff you like to
and is it is is it Huff it is it is
thank you after a lifetime of having my
name uh hatcheted up I appreciate it uh
I just wanted to say uh I'm happy to be
here um my other committee is labor so
I'm looking for a a a Kinder gentler
committee
here and I look forward to what we're
doing so well you have a kind general or
chairman don't believe anything anybody
tells you thank
you has everyone signed us yep I I
haven't even signed it uh well we could
just pass it
around
uh well just what do you have oh you
going to sign go go guess go right ahead
if anybody has the you have to sign in
on bills and stuff go right ahead
uh just let just a little do a little
business uh
just and we have there are AA there are
available uh in the in the uh Resources
office which is right on that side 305
uh 305 there are these drawer there draw
list of drawers they have names
on that's for your storage of anything
that you want
uh that that hadn't been announced I
surprised that but uh it it is Avail
they are available now
so so you'll find find your name in all
probability you know his is on the top
the vice chair mine is the
desk everybody else I think it's yeah
pretty don't don't come to me if yours
is the bottom one it isn't my fault I
didn't pick it
out oh and also if you see we're this is
the the seating arrangement that we're
required to be in
uh kind of did the best we could to get
everybody into into a s into a you we
have masks we masks we have non masks
tried to keep a a set that table masks
this table non-m
there's try try to we try to make it as
uh comfortable as possible
we the uh ranking member and the vice
chair uh and I spent some time looking
at it uh working on it and think it's
the best we
can
e
all right folks we're going to get
started all right before I start if you
are where the next bill will be
1452 uh if you have are going to
testify on the bill are going to speak
on the bill please fill out a pin
card
and otherwise you won't be recognized
and as I asked for please put on the
bill whether you support the bill uh or
do not support the bill
and I'm starting starting to eat my mask
so
i' pulling it down uh so uh and uh also
put on the amount of time uh you you
intend to
speak let me get my copy of the
bill Mr Mr chair yes um I just wanted to
make sure that um all the new people
knew what the protocol is for
co-sponsors or sponsors of bills that
we're hearing that are people who are on
the
committee all right uh thank you thank
you representative Smith I'll uh right
now on
14 well this is
uh
uh the only co-sponsors are is
representative is representative
Mooney uh and she's in the
audience uh the but yeah the uh the
protocol if you're a member of this
committee and you are a
co-sponsor you
cannot you can speak on the bill you
have to speak on it from the
floor if you're not speaking on the
bill it's my it's my call as to whether
you stay in your seat or not I think of
the covid issue I think I would just
assume you stayed in your seats but you
cannot question
anyone uh you you just sit
there uh and I think any uh any other
comments representative Smith as you
might want nope that was it
okay that being said let don't why don't
I open the hearing open the hearing on
House Bill
1452 FN renaming the Department of
Environmental Services the Department of
Environmental Pro uh protection and
assigning the department oversight of
private drinking water
wells
uh representative Boyd you you have yeah
I think I do
have I do have a card for you and uh you
need you need s
minutes five minutes of
pres thank you very much and through you
to my esteemed colleagues of the house
my name is Bill Boyd I am the newly
elected representative from Hillsboro 21
in
meramac I also serve as a member on the
New Hampshire drinking water and
groundwater advisory commission um I
come to today uh to speak in favor of
House Bill
1452 as the chairman alluded to seeks to
change the name from Dees to D and to
test them with monitoring private Wells
on private
property over the last couple of
years when we talk
about environmental issues in state
there are there are two names that come
to mind and its peas and its meramac and
the elements of posos that have that
have permeated um those
two can't really call peas and
neighborhood but you know we'll call it
a community Community like like meramac
um that has had you know tremendous
impact on on water quality in those
particular in those particular
areas one of the companies that has
impacted meramac Sango Bane twice had an
injunction slapped on them and also had
a letter of deficiency as it related to
the treatment of their air quality at at
their
facility we're at a we're at a point I
feel as as a growing state of roughly
1.4 million people that we can no longer
be tasked with
servicing environmental issues God bless
you the contrast between
servicing Environmental Services versus
Environmental Protection I would suggest
to you is similar to the the difference
between the words may and shall May
grants you a little bit of latitude to
do something shall means you're going to
do something and that's the distinction
I think from looking at Environmental
Services to Environmental Protection I
think historically when Dees was first
approved back in the 80s it was a brand
new agency just for the lack of a better
term getting getting their feet wet and
here we are in
2022 you know the state of New Hampshire
is probably faced with the most
compelling challenge that we're we're
going to we're going to face over not
just my generation or your grandkids
generation but I would suggest maybe
your great great grandkids generation
and that's going to be making sure that
the air especially our water and the
soil remains as pristine as possible
that will allow New Hampshire to
continue to provide the quality of life
and grow and flourish
now Dees I can say with a fair degree of
certainty having served on The Drinking
Water
Commission the individuals along with
the commissioner from top to bottom they
are committed they're qualified they're
competent and they're absolutely F
mission focused on trying to deliver the
best possible that Dees can provide as
it relates to Environmental Quality in
our St state but changing the name from
services to protection means pivoting
the mission it doesn't necessarily mean
that we're going to be confusing people
with what de Dees is already doing I
would suggest to you that changing the
name to protection only amplifies
amplifies our mission and highlights the
fact that this is a state that remains a
tourist state that provides people 4,000
foot mountains to hike trails to paramet
beaches to visit Forest to to to go play
in I mean I don't mean to sound polanish
to my colleagues but New Hampshire has
worked very hard to provide outdoor
amenities to the people that come to New
Hampshire and believe in what New
Hampshire is offering them not if you're
visiting as a tourist but also for those
that reside here in terms of quality
life issues so I would to contend to you
that the name change is is Phil I will
suggest it is philosophical and I think
we're at this particular point that a
name change from a philosophical
perspective is going to be necessary
considering the issues that this state
has begun to deal with most specifically
as it relates to propo and other
contaminants that are permeating the air
the water and the
soil as it relates to the the PIV the
private drinking
Wells the reason why that was added to
the bill is I have my my father-in-law
my father Law's neighbor um received a
letter from Dees was well put together
regarding the groundwater contamination
notification program and they reached
out to
roughly 103 private well owners um
amorist Hollis Bedford Londoner meramac
pelum Windam all with issues relating to
P in in their private
Wells all of these homeowners are
outside the decree that Dees negotiated
with sang go Bain as it relates to the
to the to the pollution problem that
they did as it relates to marac Villa
District Wells four and
five these private these these private
Wells the notification program Dees has
kindly sent these individuals a letter
basically explain we've tested you Wells
and it's Ted with
pooa goes on in the letter that says New
Hampshire has limited resources
available to sample private
Wells you can submit a d you can submit
a request to have you all sampled by you
know by DS or you can have have it done
privately I think there should be an
expectation the dees should just not be
in the position of saying you your well
has a problem you need to do something
about it I think there needs to be more
of an enforcement capability where
they're using the analytes and they're
going after fingerprints and we know
that they can do it based on what Dees
has done as it relates to Wells 4 and
five and meramac they're able to
identify specific poas based on the
makeup the makeup is what they call the
is what I would call a fingerprint and
they can identify what company
manufactured that particular chemical in
in in a given given
period
so the second Point regarding
Wells is a community in Auburn New
Hampshire new subdivision saddle SLE
Hill Estates had a level of iron in
their wellwater which is not
treatable the standard for subdivisions
in New Hampshire is that you have access
have access to water does not get into
the planning boards local local land use
boards they don't get into portability
they don't get into quality that just
you have to be able to provide a
standard that you're able to provide
water to that particular
neighborhood so Dees had did a report
that that identified the level of iron
and it was rising to the level that it
wasn't going to be treated by any type
of point of service system that a
homeowner could could put in so I raised
these issues
because circling back to my initial
comment about water being probably the
most important commodity that this state
will be facing for for Gen
Generations it's really
important as I feel and even if you
don't change the name from Dees to D I
do think it's important for Dees to to
step up and take the lead to provide and
and amplify the things that they've
already done but take it a step further
as it relates to sampling training and
doing next steps uh in going after what
may be responsible for contamin
private wells in in New in New Hampshire
as as all of you are well aware you know
P it's it's man-made it's not it's not
something that's organic that grows from
the ground I mean there's a reason why
that these Wells you know are developing
a level of taint of contamination that
deserves further examination it
shouldn't be you you Well's contaminated
you need to do something about it I
honestly think and I'm hoping that with
the with my bill that were taking the
necessary next steps for either Dees or
D whatever the recommendation is of this
committee
to have a further I don't like to use
the word oversight because you're
treading into private property and I
respect that and I understand that there
are people that may have objections to
that and I certainly respect that but
there needs to be a level of enforcement
that de should have to be able that once
they've analyzed private weals that
they're able to do what they need to do
to pursue it and to answer the first
question that's probably on your mind
yes it's going to cost money it
absolutely has got going to cost money
if not changing the name on the letter
ahead from DS to D but you know tasking
with the people that work at at the
agency to do the necessary research and
Analysis to be able to identify the
source of the pollutants in those
private Wells so I said five minutes I
think I I think I spoke for eight I
certainly
want to thank my esteemed colleagues for
indulging me I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you representative for
taking my question um I'm sure you read
the letter that we all received from
Robert R Scott Commissioner of
Dees um in his letter he states that
he's opposed to the change of the name
and says in one of the sections he
doesn't think that the requirement to go
on to private Wells is needed can you
have a response to his letter please
well if if if I have my neighbor who's
getting a letter from Dees that's
telling them that they have a level of
they have a level of poas that are
exceeding the the limits as prescribed
by law and we're not following
through on on it's one thing to
remediate the well whether that's done
with public funds or private funds
that's one thing but to not begin an
investigation to begin tracing
how those chemicals got into that
particular private well then to me the
need is there to elevate going from
services to protection because we're
asking them to protect the very
investment that these folks have by by
by when they buy their house and they on
a private wealth they're investing you
know they're they're investing money
into into that because you know I'm old
school you know my my dad's my dad's 79
he bought his my house his house back in
1971 that's his investment people look
at housing as as an investment these
days and when there's a taint on the
investment potentially you could have a
taint on their ability to make it
marketable for resale assuming you know
that they they do the point of point of
service Tre whether it be a Gak filter
or reverse osmosis um that I mean that
certainly is out there but circling back
you know outside of hooking up to to
public water you know I I truly I truly
believe that if if Dees is outreaching
to people with private Wells and they're
saying that there's an issue then we
need to be taking a step further I'm not
sure if that answers your question but I
don't think it does but I your response
I I I apologize representative that's
okay thank you
Mr chair I got this uh via email from uh
the commissioner so I'm assuming it went
to everybody on the committee I received
it on Monday Mr chairman I believe it
was Monday Mr
chairman I'd be happy to give you my
hard
copy
forgot to forgot to turn my mic on
sorry it'll it's a bad habit uh
representative G for a
question okay I'm still a little conf
confused about the well issue sure um it
says oversight of wells in the title of
the bill here correct and uh I don't
know the sequence of things that will
happen what you're talking about I can't
had quite determined that and uh could
someone just come onto my property and
measure my well water or did so I mean
why would they come onto my property to
test it you
know Outreach was done as it relates to
my neighbor that they thought that there
might be an issue regarding private
Wells that were outside the decree
Circle so they did an examination of
those particular houses that were just
outside the decree Circle okay and
actually that happened to me they came
to my house and I'm quote unquote
outside of the circle correct and and
that's and that's how this this um this
contamination program came into
existence and
they they started creeping outside the
that decree Circle and started examining
so it it it begs it begs the question
um it's it's it's getting it just it
begs the question as
to I feel that there should be a level
of oversight what you feel that level of
oversight should be I you know to be
perfectly CED with you if if you know
people are not going to want people on
people are not going to want Dees on
their property just randomly so I would
I would presume that protocols or some
type of a plan would want to be put in
put into place but I would think that
there should be some level of
jurisdiction that de has as it relates
to what marac is going through like
coming outside of that Circle you know
there needs to begin you know as it
relates to marac you know more more of a
discussion of getting on to identifying
other private Wells making the
appropriate Outreach and
ascertaining whether or not a pollutant
exists in that private well or
not for a followup yeah I think I think
my followup would be um
with the people outside of the area sure
uh would have to be an area that's
already um being investigated like the
one in marac for examp cor correct so I
I would suggest to you that there needs
whatever Dees determines to
be appropriate radius original radius
for identifying and then working working
outwards I would think that would be
their I would assume that would I don't
like to assume but I would assume that
would be their how they would approach
it with within their jurisdiction
okay for third followup okay I think
just then so the people would have to be
either sent a letter perhaps so that
would be part of this bill so exactly
that's that's how that's how my
neighbors were were notified my my
father-in-law's neighbors were
notified who
else okay represent reprentative post
then representative
Cohen yes okay
um why wouldn't you let um homeowners
call in to say I think I have a problem
with my well or them have an inspection
done just to be careful like you would
do when
you
um begin
on all this and then
create more funding necessary to I
wouldn't stop them that's certainly what
their prerogative to do representative
so so why would we need this if
homeowners know in their area there has
been or even if they're on the fridge
um why would we need this
bill because I feel that there should be
more oversight by Dees as it relates
to not just and I'm not getting into the
management of the well but if somebody
is managing their well and you take a
contaminant like posos that's that's a
man that that's man-made it has to be
coming from has to be coming from
somewhere so that's why
Dees or Dees would be equipped to have
the necessary tools to be able to do
that level of
Investigation in in in collecting the
sample testing the analytes revie the
data and being able to make a decision
to conduct an
investigation
followup um oh that's no that's true
it's a
never
in it seems like too wide of a net there
okay that's fair and and is there any
solution to
that that you could make an amendment on
so I would I would I would want to sew
up the net to make it narrow so that
it's narrowly focused for a specific
contaminant as opposed
to every known
chemical or organism that that permeates
water today so that's a that's a great
point Thank you thank
you can you hear me representative Boyd
thank you for taking my question um I
understand the urgency and critical
nature of the past problem in this state
and I like what you're trying to do
which you're proposing that we do to
meet that in this bill particular I also
know the bill is going going to go
through possibly through through some
changes after the public hearing of
everyone's testimony and I'm wondering
in my mind what happens to this bill if
we do not change the name of the
department but we would add something
like a line to the bill that changes the
charter of the dees to include
protection and then another line in the
bill that expands the responsibility to
private Wells especially around PS I
just want your opinion if that's going
to water down too much what you're
trying to
accomplish so I I read commissioner
Scott's letter and and I have a very
strong working relationship with
commissioner Scott along with
commissioner assistant commissioner
sandborn and I certainly would be
amendable to anything I'm I'm being I'm
being honest with you I just that I feel
like we're at a point where there's an
expectation at least in my community
that
that that the general court needs to be
providing some direction as to how we
handle not just you know not just public
water but how we handle private water so
I certainly would be receptive to to
what you're proposing expanding the
mission and and including including the
wells not necessarily changing the name
so I you know I I'm it's a friendly
Amendment and I certainly would be
gracious thank you for your response
thank you I
somewhat
um agree with the issue of for you
especi but also it is one that is not
simply tested for in home testing kits I
know when I was having trouble with
discoloration
in my uh sink and toilet and shower um
Dees advised me to get a water test done
which cost $80 but it tested for arsenic
iron manganese copper and lead a host of
other things but not past and then I was
able to do some remediation work on my
own so
um the the bill seems
very Lim vague to me almost because it's
you say it's to have them do compliance
but what I read here is it's just for
carrying out inspection and take water
samples so is there any way you can like
clarify it a little bit better maybe you
know the bill entirely because it's I
mean it does say or rules adopted under
it uh Provisions with this title and I
looked at the title and it pretty much
is Just duties of Dees
so I'd be happy to okay I'd be happy
to representative
Graton or
question uh thank you representative I I
have a a question on again changing the
name from services to protection your
your testimony uh indicated that you you
wanted to change the mission so that
they were more proactive in
enforcement
uh having received many changes in
Mission In My Life a one word change in
Mission seems like uh it could be taken
in a lot of different ways the cost of
that could be quite
substantial uh and I'm not sure the
mission analysis that was
done to achieve whatever wanted it to go
is there been what's the
mission analysis it says here's the
effect that we want and changing this
one word is going to achieve that
effect simply put and I appreciate the
question thank you when I think Services
I just think I just think it's generic
and when I think protection it's like
it's good teeth it's and I don't again
like I I don't mean to be myopic about
it but that's you know that that's how I
really look at it I mean that sincerely
you know it just when when when you use
the word protection it's it's saying you
have an agency that has some
teeth thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative void uh my question I I I
kind of want to go back um a little bit
um I mirror the concerns of some of my
colleagues on the idea of um just
entering privately owned I I agree with
you I'm not gonna I can see the point so
my question is because from what you
were saying it appears to me that you
are more focused on the idea of say like
a corporate contaminant or something and
trying to trace that back couldn't if
that was a investigation wouldn't a like
a search warrant or or something to that
effect to you know uh probable cause uh
to collect evidence wouldn't that do
what you're
suggesting I'm not a
lawyer I did stay at a holiday and
exence once um sorry just trying to be
funny folks I apologize
um I don't think it should rise to a
level of a search warrant to when I
think search warrant I
think criminal I think you you're going
in there to to look for
um looking for you're looking for
information you have you have probable
cause um as a you know anecdotally
looking at at meramac and as I explain
how we have that consent decree and we
have this race radius and now the the
radius the mission creep is is going
outside that radius because there is you
know to use the word there is some
probable cause to suggest that you know
the the P the p is the posos you know
the C8 you know FL chemicals you know
it's it's expanding into into into
private Wells
so knowing in my experience with how
Dees has worked in in marac and and as I
said all little to the're they're very
thorough and they they know exactly what
they're doing um I don't think it should
get to a level of the certain laws that
are on
the
provide them the enough level of of
discretion
[Music]
to casually Outreach to people and say
hey you're just outside the circle we'd
like to come in and look at your wells I
think right now is is has been has been
working thank you you're
welcome any other
questions
members of the
committee representative for a question
Mr thank you Mr chair um so I'm going to
piggyback a little bit on the whole
government entity taking the water
sample on private property um I take a
lot of water samples with my business
and I do happen to know that Pasa
testing is available at a lot of the
local Labs um Nelson Analytical in
Manchester is one of them you do have to
request the test but they can't handle
it um would you be open to possibly
having those tests made available and
homeowners being able to test their own
Wells perhaps if they were
notified short answer is yes but I
didn't know I actually and I'm
embarrassed to say this I did not know
that that
existed so that may be something in my
role with the drinking water and
groundwater advisory
commission would consider because we do
we've done pilot programs over the last
couple of years for for a variety of
different things perking new wells for
people up in the North Country uh we've
done some Source water development um
we've done done a lot of small pilot
projects in that particular that
actually is is a great idea um and I
certainly would be receptive to that
whether it is incorporated directly
through Dees or uh through the role of
the uh the drink and water trust
fund um
you shouldn't um it it is a special
request there
any any more questions from the
uh or comments or questions from the
committee okay
uh
I'll I'll pass uh with that uh thank you
very thank you very much Mr chairman to
you and the committee thank you very
much for your time okay the next uh
person looking to testify is Brandon and
it's K RN and the rest of the number
rest of the letters all run
together and so how do you how do you
spell the how do you spell the last part
of your name I'm sorry a e r n as a
Nancy e n is a Nancy
okay so I'm well good morning Mr
chairman and members of the committee
I'm Brandon kernin I'm the administrator
of the drinking water and groundwater
Bureau here to testify on House Bill uh
1452 um there's two aspects to the bill
that are not directly related so I
didn't indicate if we opposed or had or
or supported the bill just because we
have quite slightly different takes on
the two aspects of the bill as far as
reaming could you speak uh into the
microphone bring it bring it a little
closer to
you all right is that better right thank
you so there's two aspects to the bill
one renaming department environmental
services the Department of Environmental
Protection um the department is opposed
to that change and we believe Services
is a good way to describe how we achieve
Environmental Protection we not only
rely on our statutory Authority and the
rules we make but we largely uh rely on
providing technical assistance financial
assistance education Outreach
collaboration with stakeholders and
communities and then ultimately um
regulation and to the degree that we are
proactive in our administration of our
programs it's really dictated by the
statutes and what's required of us so to
the extent someone feels that we're
being passive on something we probably
should look at more the statute opposed
to the name in my opinion but I feel
like the current approach under Services
is very effective it's always most
effective to work with people first and
you get 98% of the problems addressed
before you get to the more difficult
regulatory enforcement aspects so that's
why we oppose that it also would be very
costly at a time that the agency is very
busy um we're addressing past
contamination Statewide arsic magines
and a number of other issues so divert
resources time and probably cause
confusion all the while the other aspect
of the bill about giving the department
explicit authority to enter private
property to collect water
samples and also administer the
provisions of the Safe Drinking Water
Act we have no position on we do work
with the water well board um who
oversees private well construction
maintenance and pump installation and we
do address groundwater contamination and
we have found we've had great success
working with property owners to
voluntarily gain access to their
properties to sample Wells when we have
concerns and we do have a process when
there's contamination and sending out
letters there actually a law that
requires we notify people within 500
feet of a known exceedence of a state
regul state drinking water standard and
then for the case of past we're actually
offering to sample the well at no cost
to the homeowner it's it's off up to the
property owner though to respond to that
request and and have us come on the
property where we have instances that
where we're really concerned about
public health and safety and an acute
sense that something really bad could
happen immediately if actions not taken
we have worked with local Health
officers who have extensive authorities
to enter properties to address public
health and we have a recent example of
that of a site in Lancaster where a
landlord put a well in a wetland in a
contaminated Wetland and was serving the
tenants at water supply and we worked
with the local Health officer and the
local police to gain access to the
property to to stop that situation
and so for those reasons we we don't
take a position but I can't show a lot
of examples in my 20 years at the
department where we have not been able
to access a property I will just point
out if we have reasonable um information
to suggest someone's polluting the
environment on a property there was a
whole another process to compel somebody
to do investigations um using licensed
professionals if they're not going to
let us on site and so that's how we
address those situations and I'd be
happy to answer any
questions
any questions by members of the
committee representative Smith thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr kerin for
taking my question in the letter that
commissioner Scott wrote he said that
even with the language in this bill that
enables the department to enter
privately owned lands a land owner May
refuse entry um and they must obtain an
administrative warrant so is that so is
that different I mean right now anyone
can refuse entry onto their property so
even with this bill they could do that
so it's not really going to fix
everything that's correct um I could
provide you the legal analysis for that
our enforcement document for the agency
talks about inspections of properties
and even where we have clear statutory
Authority Under other unrelated statutes
ultimately anybody can refuse our
immediate entry and require we get an
administrative search warrant and that's
actually the case for many non-law
enforcement statutes out there where
that you know private property owners
are afforded that one opportunity where
we have to go through that procedure my
20 years I've never had to go there yet
I know it's been done before but yes for
Dees any inspection could be put off
until we have that administrative search
warrant if the property owner wants to
take advantage of
that thank
you representative
Cohen thank for taking my question I
just need some clarification on entering
private property for well you gave a
great example I think of Lancaster what
happens if a tenant on a property or
apartment complex has the water tested
whether it's through the state or wants
the water tested through private person
or state and it's polluted somehow but
the property owner refuses to allow the
state or private um testing company on
the property to conduct the test what
would the tenant's rights be in that
case so there's a a specific statute and
I can get the number for you I don't
have it memorized that actually states
that land owners that have tenants must
provide an adequate water supply and
that's about the that's the essence of
the wording I might be off a little bit
and so that protection's there and it
would be up to the health officer to
enforce it I will say I'm aware of many
less than satisfying instances
where the very situation you present
someone who's renting something is not
happy about the water quality either
aesthetically or from a health
standpoint and they sort of get stuck in
limbo because we don't have authority to
jump in on that but we don't compel the
property owner to fix the problem and so
it's really up to the health
officer and they interpret an adequate
supply of water many different ways
that's not defined mind and so it is an
issue that's come up from time to time
that hasn't always been perfectly
resolved there was a bill a couple years
ago I think it may have stalled due to
covid you know many of the bills sort of
lost progress when Co set in that was
going to have more testing requirements
for landlords I think it was potentially
going to a study committee because it
was complicated and also when you get in
these situations sometimes when you
start we try to help in those situations
we say it's not our problem but often we
start learning there's other issues
between the renters and the and the
owner and about who's paying or not
paying what and so it gets complicated
you really have to think out how you
would do that if you're going
to add more to that process okay thank
you for the
answer thank you Mr chair thank you sir
for taking my question um given this
bill has a fiscal note but there's a
zero number in there and and you alluded
to the phrase costly um as well as it's
reference in the letter do you have an
estimate of the cost and if since the
agency was contacted why there's no
fiscal
note so the the primary cost isn't so
much with the inspecting the wells
because we are already sampling Wells
I'm sorry let me clarify the name I
think starting with the name change so
that's really indeterminable we have
probably over 20,000 documents on our
website our rules
um our
stationary it we staff would have to go
in and reproduce every document you see
on our website to change that that name
possibly a logo and so that that's just
really difficult to estimate the cost
followup I'm aware that the department
of resources and economic development
changed their name to the Bea um so
that's been done there's probably a cost
analysis that has been done by state
Administration is that something that
the AG he can look into so that we can
understand what the true fiscal note
would be we can certainly ask admin
Services if they have an estimate of
what that cost was thank you
sir representative post for a
question thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you today for testifying um I do have
two questions so if I could do a
followup um after this um currently you
said if a homeowner calls do you can go
out and do a posos test is that
correct not not exactly what we're doing
right now is we have targeted areas
where we found contamination and by
state law we have to notify all Property
Owners within 500 feet where we have an
exceedence and for past because the
legislature has provided some funding
for it within that 500 feet notification
letter we are offering to sample the
well at no cost to the homeowner where
staff will come out and collect the
sample that has not always been the case
but for past we've been funded to do
that but just anyone can't call it has
to be in a in a focused area we do have
um a web survey for where people could
put in requests to be sampled and as we
um discover new areas of contamination
we often go there first to see where we
can get other sampling sites quickly
before our notifications go out but
right now just anybody can't um request
it or anyone can request it but not
everyone will get sampled unless you're
in a target targeted area
follow
up so in that when you find that there
is contamination outside of the area and
someone has responded to a letter you've
sent do you then start
tracing yes that process of going out
500 feet notifying sampling then as more
exceedances another 500 foot circle and
that's why we have such a backlog now
the representative boy is right there's
a serious problem New Hampshire with
past contamination and the more harder
we work the more work we have it just
keeps going out and out because of the
extent of contamination the population
center of the state so it just continues
on to St we have a backlog of hundreds
of Wells but they are going to be
sampled another followup please
um the funding that you're receiving is
there is this covid funds is it um arpa
funds is it
how at what point are those funds going
to be expended with the knowledge that
this is
growing so I would have to get back to
you on that assessment um you know
there's the funds $6 million believe
from The Advisory commission is to
investigate past where there's no
responsible party and do another number
of other things such as figure out
destruction Technologies for getting rid
of P out of the environment
you know ultimately what the state needs
and there's litigation with the
Department of Justice on this at this
point is every well needs to be sampled
in the state and pest is pervasive it's
just not in southern Hampshire it's in
downtown Center Harbor it's in stratom
it's in Windam and the the only way to
know if it's succeeding due to the
extent of so many sources is to actually
sample the wells and so hopefully
someday we will get the resources from
responsible parties to address the
situation fully
one more
followup um and as you've been involved
with the posos is there have you found
cancer clusters um in the areas that you
have been um sampling and is that one of
the problems that um has arisen so in
our state that's a complicated question
um is it's a lot of science behind that
and the epidemiology is little be on my
expertise but I am aware of one Cor
correlation but causation might not
exactly be established and that is in
aramac there's been found to be a higher
incidence of kidney cancer and based on
some recent data from EPA on pfoa that
is one of the large health concerns of
PF is kidney cancer two haven't been
connected so I don't want to misstate
that and maramax had other contaminants
back in the 80s in their water supply
Wells too that that they've since
addressed so it's a complicated issue
but there is that one correlation I'm
aware of
thank you thank you very
much thank you uh Al I actually have a
question
uh
knowing the uh level of supervision or
uh Authority you have over the
other uh sources of
water uh if you have authority over
Lakes you have authority over uh ground
you have authority over groundwater you
have authority over
commercial
uh uh activities with water uh would
would this bill uh allow you to have
that level of control over the
residential Wells that are in homes
now uh that you have over commercial
Wells and all of the other sources of
water
it would give us the same level of
access potentially but as far as
authority to propel a homeowner to take
action if they had natural or man-made
contaminants no right now there's no
State regulation of private wellwater
quality or even a testing requirement
for private wellwater quality right for
for now but could this then apply all of
a sudden to all if you get if this bill
were passed could all of the uh uh
levels of various contaminants that are
that are in that may be appear in uh
commercial water or in other or lake
water things of that nature will be now
appli to
homeowners so if a homeowner has a
contaminated water supply and we're
aware of responsible party we can compel
the responsible party to mitigate that
homeowner's water supply right now
homeowner wants that they but they have
a right to say I want nothing to do with
responsible party or Dees this bill
wouldn't change that it would just give
us access to actually collect a water
sample uh the way I read the bill it
says you have you know
you
uh the purpose of carrying out
inspection and for the purpose of taking
water samples and to determine comp
compliance with provisions of this title
or rules adopted under it so you can
adopt rules once you have jurisdiction
you can adopt rules in pretty much uh
any way you would you would wish to
expand the authority of the uh Dees over
local over
residential uh Wells so the Safe
Drinking Water Act which is what this
references RSA
485 98% of it pertains to Public Water
Systems which
is larger water system a larger entity
serving a lot of people water more than
15 connections or 25
people um under the state Drinking Water
Act there's only one provision for
private Wells and that has to do with
the es and a health officer being able
to order a well not to be used if we
believe it poses a health risk and then
there's a a fencing requirement for
certain types of Wells the statute that
pertains to private Wells say 483 I
believe B the water well board and
that's where well construction standards
are established for all wells in the
state including private Wells so we have
no rule making authority to make water
quality standards for private Wells we
have guidance and we provide that
guidance to towns and some towns have
adopted local regulations that require
new wells when they're drilled be tested
there was legislation again I think
pending During the period right
preceding Co that was and pursued by the
legislature but it stalled out when Co
took us off
track and and a final final
question you you stated that if someone
is at the present time if someone
has uh received a a letter from you
that that uh there's been water F water
well contamination within
500 is it 500 feet that you will test
their well for past only at this time
fore gee I got a letter like that a
month or so ago and nobody said that
nobody said you would do that it didn't
offer to sample your well of course
not why would I be asking yeah I see
that please and I could get back to you
on why that okay uh well I think I know
why it's in the town of Hudson not in
any of the other towns that
uh uh rep the representative voyd
mentioned there is one exception I I
should correct that we offered a sample
when there's no viable responsible party
so like inside this centree area St Goan
we are telling them to go sample the
private Wells um but when you're outside
the area or like in downtown Center
Harbor where there's no obvious
contamination Source that's where DS
we're not spending State resources when
there's a viable responsible party that
has to use their own funds for that okay
yeah I okay we'll talk later thank
you anyone else for a
question representative Healey
representative Healey for a question
thank you Mr Speaker okay I sit on the
737 commission and um there was a couple
of over sites and I just want to know if
this would even help um what we found is
on a couple of the occasions you were
only going 7 F feet out from the wells
and now you're going out to 500 feet I'm
not going to get into the why that
happened it just it did happen so we
added like 130 or 40 more users that you
had to go out and
test the big thing that I have an issue
with now there are people out there now
that have been for three years have been
on bottled water delivered to the
house I'm talking about pallets of
water bottles of
water and I think at this point that
there should be some remediation for
them whether it be I know you keep
talking about we may tie them when we
may tie them in some people of these
people are way away from any water
supply that you ever going to tie them
into why aren't we looking at um trying
to get point of entry systems in these
houses at this time it this is something
that we should be looking at and I I I
know you can't say you can't do this but
this is something that should be done
right
now yes it
Wy so we understand there's a large
number of Wells that are impacted with P
fasts that don't have a viable
responsible party and that a long-term
solution to extending water supply could
be hundred million dollar in certain
areas of the state very costly with
again no viable responsible party and
bottle water achieved one thing that's
really important it stopped the exposure
of past and drinking water but it's
really unsatisfactory it doesn't make
people whole and for that reason reason
just last Monday the drinking water
advisory commission which represent Boyd
is on and very much supported this
concept approved $5 million to provide a
rebate program for people that have
contaminated Wells it' be $1,500 so
that's approved it probably take a month
or two for staff to stand up the program
because it's a whole new program that we
we have but it's really the first time
the state has put a lot of funding out
there to help private well owners who
don't receive the tax the grants that
Public Water Systems get from the
federal government to address an issue
like this it's not perfect but it's at
least a big incremental improvement from
where we have
been and there there is a lot of work
going on with London da and all Southern
New Hampshire there multiple studies uh
conceptualizing how to extend water how
to get the right who has enough water to
extend there what would be the cost be
what would be the legal mechanisms of
Water Systems it's incredibly
complicated um but I I understand your
frustration
completely than thank
you seeing no other questions from the
committee thank you very
much oh we have
a uh Mark sandor assistant commissioner
you wish
to speak on the bill
thank you Mr
chairman for the record Mark Sor
assistant commissioner New Hampshire
Dees um I just wanted to offer a couple
clarifying points to some of the
questions Brandon got just to make sure
they were on the record uh correctly um
first and foremost and this is really
important to commissioner Scott um often
a bill like this um and I'm referring to
the second part of the bill access um
increasing access um um sometimes it can
come across as if an agency has asked a
legislator um we have an issue could you
help us with this we want to make sure
on the record um uh Dees did not ask for
this U motion to be brought forward um
quite frankly and I have a ton of
respect for the sponsor of this bill
I've known him 20 years and I know he's
looking out for his community and his
constituents um but we really think that
this is a solution looking for a problem
uh the challenges particularly with
pfest don't relate to access for testing
there's a lot of issues and there's a
lot of reasons and you've talked about
them but we have not had a challenge
sampling through the current process so
this would not help address the P issues
that we have in Southern New Hampshire
or anywhere else we
mentioned
and um but I will reiterate we feel the
current name regardless of the cost is
much more in the spirit of the New
Hampshire approach to state regulatory
um in terms of serving our constituents
versus oversight and the last thing just
because it's such a sensitive issue um
to the question about cancer clusters uh
we really DS should really be referring
you to um Health and Human Services they
have done a test there's a report that
came out recently um that is not our
area of expertise and um while Brendan
mentioned it's correct and you know
we've learned it from our colleagues
there I I really would refer you to
those questions um to HHS is that's
their area of expertise and and and um
you know their responsibility to to look
at on behalf of the uh citizens of the
state
representative post for a question yes
thank you chair for um allowing me to
ask this question um could the change of
name be chain be be done in a different
way and put in like a mission statement
or something um rather than changing
your name and having to go through all
of that so protecting the natural
resources and environment of uh of New
Hampshire is already in our mission
statement um and again I I very much
appreciate the motivation of the
sponsors um and the feeling out there in
some communities that um um are they
being protected by the state I you know
with some of the issues that have been
brought to light I I I totally
appreciate that sentiment I just don't
think this is the way to uh solve it the
way we'll solve it is to continue
sampling find out where the past
clusters exist coming up with solutions
for either well or public um sources of
drinking water um and continuing to make
the progress we've made in working with
the folks that we can identify as
responsible to pay for their cost and
where we can't find out with Public
Funding Solutions um to the folks are
there outside those areas that
That's How we'll make progress on these
issues um but it is already in our
mission to protect the natural resources
the environment um and the the waters um
drinking water um and and recreational
Waters of the state and we take that
charge um very wholeheartedly and do our
best to to live up to that
mission I have a question oh I'll get
I'll give I'll return to you is it the
is would you feel that it is within the
purview of the legislative branch to
determine the name of what the executive
branch calls
itself uh sure I mean you you think it
is within our purview okay I mean I I I
mean I think you know I mean that that
we have a you know classic system of of
checks and balances and if uh the folks
that determine our funding feel they
they want to call our agency something
else well you know we'd respect that I
just I I you know just speaking as a
lifelong granted stator I think I think
the name reflects the culture and
approach of New Hampshire and and and
state agent and and state
regulatory um more so than protection
and um I I I I I I we have a very often
not always but we have have good working
relationships with communities and
residents and and I think part of it
comes from we view them as our customers
and our constituents not as folks we're
there to bring oversight towards and I
I'd just be nervous that a change of
name would would would give it a
different feel but we certainly respect
the con state constitution and the
authorities uh of of the fine
legislative branch of the State of New
Hampshire
representative post for a follow on
question thank you very much um just um
they talked the last speaker talked
about responsible party um they would go
to them for the funds is there any have
you kept a an account where there isn't
responsible parties that um now the
state is paying for and is that part of
the litigation that's going forward yeah
so we got have to be a little careful
given there is pending legislation but
broadly
speaking um with some parties we've been
able to come to agreement on
responsibility um and as a result you
know there there and I understand why
especially in the world we live in and
you know as we start
2022 we haven't talked a ton about what
has been done the over 400 Wells that
have been addressed the new public water
sources that have been um put in place a
lot has been done um to this point and a
lot more needs to be done um there are
still people using bottled water so it
it's you know I totally understand both
sides of that coin um but um
I um sorry I lost my train thought uh uh
there so number so where there has been
agreement among parties on where there
is responsibility we've been able to
move forward where there hasn't been
agreement on responsible parties one of
two things is happening either we are
looking uh we are reviewing if we can
identify who we could show data that we
believe um a responsible party has been
identified um and there is pend pending
leg legislation in other areas where we
believe our responsible party has been
identified and they haven't agreed to
that on their end so you know it's kind
of three-prong we're in the process of
having the court system agree with us
we've been able to come to a mutual
agreement with some parties and we're
still doing research in other
areas the last one um yeah so um do you
have an amount of um
expenditures that haven't been covered
by the responsible parties
um um a little bit of that is I
identified in some of the pending
lawsuits so I um need to be careful but
um I I I in conjunction with the
Attorney General's office we are
ensuring that any amount we bring
forward we can justify in terms of we
feel it is um the appropriate cost for
uh mitigation for uh an
appropriately um identified respons
party thank you very
much
okay for a second for a second time
representative
Healey um I I will remind the with the
uh committee that we are a half an hour
over talking about uh what Bill said
about a little bit more teeth uh
recently you sent a letter to uh s
gobain about
bypassing the RL do you think just
sending a letter was going to be good
enough where he was saying whether would
be more teeth in it would you think more
teeth would have been better about
that yeah so the letter is the form part
of the formal process to get on the
record what we have um uh identified and
information that has uh come our way I
promise you we are uh working with st
Goan right now um about what happened in
the permitting process um uh why um the
stack that is in question um was built
um what we believe outside of the
permitting process I do want to get on
the record In fairness um what they
built is can get a receive a permit they
didn't do something that um is against
Statute in and of itself it just um they
hadn't been permitted for it so we will
work with them as we do with any um
entity um commercial or private where
there um uh what we believe was a
mistake uh or
improper uh development in the
permitting process and um uh part of
that will be um action on their part and
which also could
include uh mitigation for what has
happened um I will say this um and from
a public safety perspective all of the
tests and our folks are on there when
they are testing them and ensured that
the U bypass stack was not in use uh the
stacks they use in their everyday um did
meet all of our air requirements so from
a public health standpoint um we don't
believe there's any uh public health
risk um with what happened um they they
they didn't didn't follow the permitting
process correctly um we will work with
them on that we will get it correctly
permitted um and we will work with the
Attorney General's office and their
lawyers um to work on mitigation just as
we would in any other time when a permit
wasn't properly
followed thank you very
much I know you're behind so I don't
want to yeah seeing no other uh
questions thank you very much thank you
very much appreciate your time okay
seeing no other having no other pink
sheets excuse
me I don't see
it oh
okay anybody any other ones all right
Chris Norwood
three
minutes Mr chair members of the
committee I will keep my uh comments
brief to respect the time uh New
Hampshire Association of Realtors is
opposed to this bill I apologize for the
record my name is Chris Norwood I am the
2022 public policy chair for the New
Hampshire Association uh we are opposed
to this bill as written uh not so much
in the name change portion but relative
to uh the uh the entering of private
property which is where our concern
mainly lies uh let me just skip ahead to
what has not already been covered I
think that one of the things that
concerns us is not only entering into
the premise but most of the uh the Water
Testing that I have seen is is done at
the faucet and the tap so not only are
you entering upon uh private property
owners land but also into their their
domicile which is of
concern uh it also doesn't uh clarify
under which Circ circumstances uh one
neighbor would have their well well
water tested and the abutter may not uh
and I think that that's a concern so who
gets the to choose which private
properties get entered into uh is is
another uh
concern uh I'll skim ahead here has been
covered been
covered I I think that the the comment
came up relative to uh Community well
sources um and I think that that's
another important piece um so the dees
does have standards for Community well
water and commercial property um and
while those are not imposed on a private
property owner those in fact have become
the deao standard for a private uh
property test so at the point of sale
when uh somebody is getting a water
inspection if they elect to do so
there's a check box on the realtor
purchase and sale agreement and if a
priv
has their their go-to again it's not a
mandate but that is de facto standard
that they turn to so uh that was a
clarifying question from um one of the
representatives earlier
um and yeah and then at that point it's
really up to the home buyer Andor seller
to contribute uh whether or not what
remediation system is appropriate for
them uh verse osmosis I've seen I've
seen uh uh uh water softeners um in
various other tools um typically within
the private domicile again this is for
private properties not so for you know
Community Wells those are under a
different uh statute so I thank you Mr
chair and representatives and uh that's
my
testimony thank you very
much representative Smith for a question
all right thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Norwood for taking my question um
you state that a point of sale is when
um the homeowner will choose to have
their water tested and um my question
is do realtors because they are the key
person that the homeowner home buyer is
usually working with do they um do you
give information packets to potential
home owners uh talking about why it's
good to have your water tested you know
Dees has a lot of these things having
your septic system checked before you
buy the property having your water well
water checked before you buy the
property do realtors do this
customarily not so much a like there's a
lead paint pamplet which I think that
that's coming to my mind with your
question representative um but not so
much that but there is a statutory
disclosure requirement so for any of you
who have bought and sold a home you
might be aware of there's a five page
six-page disclosure and I believe it's
oh geez I'm going to go on the record
with 477 or maybe it's 483 that
references uh statuto uh disclosure
requirements and wellwater uh any known
contaminants uh the last time it was
tested um who the vendor was that was
that performed the testing those are
requirements that a home seller is
obligated to disclose to the home buyer
so there is an obligatory right for uh
the realtor in this case the leny and as
as well as the property seller to
disclose um those items to a potential
buyer thank you very
welcome seeing
no no further questions seeing no
further questions thank you very much
thank you and I apologize for missing
your card no
worries any
other anyone else wish wishing to
testify seeing no one I'll call the
hearing on 1452 closed and open the
hearing on house house bill
1618 representative
Boyd
again through you to my esteemed
colleagues of the house um
1618 is a build that would add two
specific substances to the um perer
Chemin prorated chemical list that
standard specifically
pbfa and pbfs and then a total
contaminant level as relates to
paragraphs a through up to 20 parts per
trillion um is and I'll and I will be
brief because I think I know most of if
not all of you are well aware of the
public health
impacts the environmental impact
that perforated chemicals have on on a
variety of different things both you
know fetal development you know cancer
uh
crops that and that kind of thing
the
two chemicals that I'm seeking to add to
the list is p pfba and PFS and for all
intents and purposes um it's just it's
just another
it's just another type of pfoa that has
been created used being used on specific
consumer products food packaging and
other types of industrial
processes
so the guide the guidance that I'm
proposing as I said is seven parts per
trillion for P for pfba and a th000
parts per Tron for pfbs and this would
be added to
the existing uh peroral alkal substances
that exist in in our
rsas as providing
a limit as to how those chemicals can be
used and I'm happy to answer any
questions any questions by members of
the
committee
uh thank you for taking my question uh
the uh seven in a thousand figures that
you presented do those come from a
certain source so the the seven Parts
patrolling is based off of analysis that
was done by the Department of Health for
the state of Minnesota based on specific
research and criteria that they had used
they had arrived at at a at an mdh
guidance value of seven parts
seven Parts
portray thank you representative and
thank you Mr chair for allowing me to
ask the question um are you aware that
in 2018 legislation that we passed I
believe enabled Dees to develop uh
standards for new p poas p pfcs if
evidence was found uh to require that
yes thank
you representative kraton for a
question yeah thank you representative
for your your uh input I'm I'm reading
the the letter that we got from De s uh
from commissioner Scott who's uh
recommending that we not support this
bill uh and then I'm looking at the
financial um statement in the back which
as I read it uh it's a 12 12 million
cost
um 12 or 12.4 million uh up to uh and so
I I'm just trying to understand what
does $122 million buy me and why would I
do it if my Dees is saying we don't need
it because it it creates a a class of
chemicals that confuses the issue it
it's another it's it's it's another type
of chemical that potentially is going
into in the water or the air that
potentially could have an impact on
public health so the cost that you
potentially would be paying for would be
to to Reg to to regulate
in
part okay no and and but DS says they're
already doing it yes I read I read the
letter that is correct okay so you're
saying they're wrong I'm not saying
they're wrong at
all okay
got any other
questions representative gotl thank you
Mr chairman I see that you uh said you
got the statistics from the state of
Minnesota that's correct uh have are
there any other sets of Statistics that
are comparable or similar and why did
you choose Minnesota quite honestly was
the only one that popped out in my
research it it seems that that the state
of Minnesota is really the only one that
I could find and want to research the
matter further but state of Minnesota
was the only one that I found that had
done a significant level of research to
to justify The Advisory that they put
out thank
you thank you anyone else or a
question seeing none thank you thank you
very much Mr chairman again thank you to
my colleagues through you to my
colleagues thank
you Mr uh Mr
Kieran
you have the floor thank you chairman
and members of committee again I'm
Brandon kernin administrator of the
drinking water and groundwater Bureau
for the Department of Environmental
Services testifying on House Bill
1618 the department is opposed to this
bill um I want to point out that you
back when the statute was changed to
enable or require Dees to adopt
standards for for pfoa pfna pfhxs and uh
pfos it not only required that we do it
but it also enabled Us by establishing
two positions a toxicologist and health
risk assessor who are now tasked with
not only adopting the standards that we
have done but to continue to review the
science and propose new drinking water
standards as warranted opposed to
looking to the legisl to proposed value
so we figure the process that's been
established and the capacity that's been
given to Dees is really how we should
assess and adopt standards going forward
you know based on science I want to
comment on a few of the provisions that
are proposed in this bill and it's
outlined in more detail in her letter um
first of all for
pfba the Senate Minnesota does have a
guidance value but I believe it's part
per billion not trillion so it's a
factor of a thousand different and
that's kind of consistent with our
analysis at this point EPA has some
draft toxicity data that they' published
for pfba for public comment and my
Bureau is a member of association with
similar agencies in other states
drinking water programs in other states
and our assessment is based on this
draft toxicity data which again isn't
ready to be finalized a standard would
be well over a th parts per trillion um
possibly over 3,000 parts per trillion
and it's good to know that um but the
implication of of that value doesn't
have a lot of meaning in New Hampshire
because we're not finding pfba at those
levels in the state we definitely detect
pfba but it's usually at very low levels
below 20 parts per trillion so even if
we charged ahead and made a 7,000 or a
th000 or 3700 part per trillion standard
which is kind of where the science is
driving us it wouldn't have any
practical effect it wouldn't impact
anybody's water
supply for pfbs um we would are in a
good position to make a standard um EPA
has created what we call reference dose
which you use to calculate what a
drinking water standard would be and
we've had internal meetings about it
talking about adopting a standard and we
bear well may when we reopt a rulle
someday but again there's no urgency
because the value for pfbs would be
around a th parts of trillion as
proposed in this bill but again wouldn't
have any practical effect on drinking
water we're not based on seven 8,000
private public water supply drinking
water test we haven't seen anything come
close to a th000 parts per trillion for
pfbs the only place we really seen pfbs
at that high levels where we have a
source of contamination the spot where
things were actually released in those
cases the things we regulate already
pfna PFA pfos and
pfhxs are also exceeded and so
remediations already occurring there so
changing that value wouldn't have any
practical effect the third thing that's
proposed is adding the six compounds to
four we regulate plus pfba and pfbs and
having a cumulative standard a pfas 6
standard of 20 parts per trillion
there's a couple problems with that one
it pulls pfbs in and so you know the
defacto value for pfbs would become 20
parts per trillion because you're adding
that towards 20 so no matter if we had
the Thousand parts per trillion standard
as proposed would actually be 20 because
it's part of that
equation and then the other concern we
have with it is that each of these
compounds have a different Health
outcome it's not a one: one ratio and so
although it's highly desirable to
regulate them as a class because there's
ultimately thousands of these compounds
and going at them one at a time is not
ideal we just don't have the scientific
basis to group them yet EPA and part of
Asar nudging our commissioner centil
letter EPA asking him to start working
on regulating these as a class because
we're never going to get at it doing
them boy one but EPA is now working
really hard at assessing the toxicity of
cocktails of these pest values and and
hopefully in the future there'll be a
sound scientific basis for having
standards based on the class we just
don't have that at this time to justify
that and I'd be happy to answer any
questions representative kraton for a
question yeah Mr K I thank you for your
testimony so my my understanding from
your testimony is that this
bill would cost $12 million to do
something that you guys have already
looked at and it determined is not an
issue at this
point it would cause local entities to
spend money to either do investigations
or remediation or put in treatment
systems for something at this time that
we don't have a basis for but we keep
looking at the data and at some point in
the future we may have different
standards that more align with this but
at the time no we don't have a
scientific basis okay thank you
sir representative Kelly for a for a
question thank you Mr chairman uh so I
guess my question we you talked about
our standards are being uh you know
let's say a thousand parts per trillion
would be we wouldn't see those levels in
testing the question would be what would
be the harm of of having a standard that
high if the the you know let's say you
know somebody did start using more pfba
in our in our production process and
then water did Spike to that that level
wouldn't wouldn't having a a safety
level you know 2,000 parts per trillion
or something that that high what would
be the harm in in having that on the
books or having
that I don't think there would be a harm
I we actually have the data we need to
make a standard for pfbs at this time
there's a final reference dose by
EPA and we very well could make a
standard likely would when we reopt
those rules but it doesn't make sense to
go through the rule making process
prematurely you have to renew the rules
every 8 10 years so you where there's no
practical implication we're not going to
divert resources to make the rule you
know sort of out of sequence had we had
a issue and we know that value would
reduce exposure we'd probably expedite
the rule making like we did for the
other four compounds so your Point's
well taken and the value of having a
standard ultimately is that it's
instructive to people they have a result
you have something to compare it to so I
think your spot on it's just um it
doesn't make sense to put it in law
outside the process that we're already
using and it doesn't make sense to rush
to do it when there's no advantage to
having that
value follow follow up Mr chairman uh so
follow up just be so the the pfbs is has
a standard EPA has a standard released
the final standard
pfba is in a draft standard released in
November is that
so PFS they have a final reference dose
which is just a a value but we use that
value to calculate a standard so it's
it's kind of plug and chug once I is you
that it's not really standard at EPA but
it's a value we can use to make it
standard and then your correct pfba
they're they have draft data um at this
point that's out for public
comment and just one more call so if
it's an 8 to 10 year process to renew
those standards it it would pfba when
that final report where it's obviously
on coming soon would that make that 8 to
10 year
cycle yeah and I don't mean to say we're
going to wait 8 to 10 years we may have
other rule changes that we need to
maintain the rules sooner but yeah if
there's final toxicity data from EPA
they would be they would incorporate
that into the rules but again it would
have no it wouldn't change anything so
it doesn't matter if we do it tomorrow
or five years from now at this point for
those two compounds based on what we
know about the science
today thank
you thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
kerum for taking my
question
um it is heartening that we do have a
toxicologist now at Dees now I just want
to make sure I have my uh what I heard
you say correct and my understanding is
on the
pfbs you said we are not finding Parts
above the a thousand parts per trillion
not in drinking water
there may be certain localized areas of
groundwater at the source of
contamination but then the P Rec current
re regulate are also exceeded there and
so efforts are underway to remediate it
and remediating PFA pfna pfhxs and pfos
would remediate the pfbs as well
followup Mr
chair so you're saying you're already
REM remediating the contaminated spots
because they have the for uh per po
polyfloral chemicals
that are do have mcls and so this one is
getting taken care of at the same time
right and it's rare that we even have
this one at that level but at those hot
spots yes and again not in drinking
water supplies at those levels just the
actual contamination Source thank
you representative Cen for a question
am I on yeah could you please could you
please tell me based on your 10 years
experience looking at
perlin chemicals within our state and
perhaps using um peas Andor meramac as
an example in in my in the answer to
this question are we finding that known
polluters uh are changing which perlu
per fluin chemical they're using once we
clamp down on them do they substitute
another variation that's now not covered
by our standard are we is it like we're
kind of an ER rase against the polluters
and those two
examples so what's really driven
industry to change the type of pfas
they've used is the termination usually
at the federal level of known toxicity
of the original
compounds and it is true new compounds
are being used often before we have a
full understanding of their toxicity
profile um again that's driven by EPA we
don't approve chemicals in New Hampshire
that's a EPA process the EPA is taking
big steps to get around that by uh by
changing how they approve um new
chemicals and also requiring more
toxicity assessments upfront and even
recently in recent legislation requiring
that manufacturers these products
provide standards to EPA so that we can
assess if they're occurring in large
quantities in the environment before we
didn't even know what to look for and we
didn't have standards for it so yeah
it's at the federal level it's not a
perfect process but they're trying to
get their arms around past is a whole
class and it made big progress in doing
it but yeah we are um we are creating
new compounds that may have more
information on later than we have now on
yes follow on
please you followup on the issue us so I
appreciate that answer but specifically
with your experience in PE and or Mar
have we found that one has been
substituted for another and it's causing
problems
again I'm not aware of a substitute
chemical causing a problem based on our
regulatory standards at this time okay
thank you for the
information any other questions by any
other members of the committee seeing
none right thank you very much thank
you
okay uh is it Grace not
Grace n n not thank you Mr chair n Grace
for the New Hampshire Municipal
Association we are opposed to this bill
uh I just want to be clear that we don't
we're not scientists so we would defer
to Dees about the science entirely uh
the reason we're opposed to the bill is
the costs uh as you may recall
uh a few years ago when the initial four
compounds were put into statute uh the
legislature authorized the treasury
Department to borrow $1 155 million uh
15 million dollar via bonding uh in
order to help pay for this uh as we've
heard throughout testimony this morning
mitigating P past compounds is very
expensive and we want to make sure that
costs are covered with without causing
um municipalities to have to pay for
those that's really the substance of my
testimony I did provide that uh via
email but there are hard copies
available uh that your researcher has if
you would like
those I'm happy to answer
questions any questions from members of
the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
uh Boyd Smith um
NH well
whatever about there we go uh I'm the
president CEO of New Hampshire Water
Works
Association and we represent uh public
drinking water uh providers in in the
state of New Hampshire we do oppose this
bill uh and I submitted electronic
testimony uh yesterday I'm going to
leave hard copies with the with over on
the table there and I learned that
bundling multiple bills of our interest
into your letters is not helpful so I
apologize for that and uh as I continue
coming to testify uh about legislation
we're concerned with I'll create
separate documents so you guys can
organize them it'll work better for you
so apologize for that
um uh you've really heard the technical
information that we would uh support uh
from from NHD uh from from Brandon
kernin so I don't want to uh reiterate
that but we fully you know we fully uh
support their DS's arguments there
um fundamentally I want folks to
understand that the group that we that
we represent and these are the people
that provide public drinking water to
the State of New Hampshire many are
municipalities some are precincts and
districts and some are private entities
such as pachuk uh this group of people
is incredibly Health focused in their
mission so when they're told you know
we've got pasos or the Arsenic level is
changing or manganese now has a new
notification standard uh they do it
these are very you know operational
outcome focused people and and as I've
gotten to know them over the last couple
years I've had this job um as they say
their product goes into people's mouths
so I just want you to understand because
most people don't think about where the
water comes from that the people that
provide this water uh to over half of
our residents uh are consumate
professionals that are highly driven for
public
service um that being said when a new
standard is proposed uh it has
implications it has treatment
implications for example as we know in
marac and Portsmouth area with posos uh
it has Health implications if you you
know don't use the right
standard and then it has all the time to
roll that out and fund it so there's
cost and health implication so what the
other thing other than sharing about the
you know the people that provide our
water is how important it is to follow
these established uh risk-based
health-based financial analysis when we
set a new standard and uh I know that
the uh the methodology was referenced
the position of a toxicologist is new
and most necessary and welcome and uh
this this point I'm making applies to
this rule here that we should not we
should not offer new standards lightly
we should test them out uh following
wellestablished
processes and that'll be a theme that
you'll probably hear from me again on a
couple of other pieces of peos related
uh legislation but that's really all I
wanted to share a little understanding
ing of of uh how seriously uh drinking
water providers take their job and uh
and they the seriousness with which they
follow science-based risk-based you know
wellth thought out procedures and
policies to establish new methods uh and
with that I thank you very much for the
time to speak to you and for the work of
the committee and if you have any
questions I'll try and answer
them any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you I have I have no other pink cards
for House Bill
1618 is anyone else wish to speak if not
I will close the hearing on House Bill
FN I will open the hearing
on House Bill
1292 permitting the use of
drones for unmanned aerial vehicles on
the Statewide trail
system
okay representative uh Aman for to speak
to his
bill
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the committee for hearing my uh
introduction of this bill my name is
Keith adman I represent Hillsboro
District 40 in the towns of New Boston
and Mount Vernon Milford and
Hollis uh this bill is at the request of
a
constituent and I think our job as state
legislators is to Advocate on behalf of
our constituents when it comes to their
relationship with the state government
so uh in that Spirit uh we introduced
this
bill if you uh if you look at I don't
know if you can see my phone here but I
believe this bill was was sparked by a
notice that's on the state parks website
and I'll read it to you here it says
drone use is restricted at all New
Hampshire state parks drone operators
are not permitted take off or to take
off or land within New Hampshire Park
boundaries so there's an outright
prohibition it's it's you know publicly
noticed on the
website um I am not a drone operator
owner um I understand that the
technology is pretty interesting and
it's it's um you know advancing pretty
steadily um but this is a hobby for
some uh and this is you know a uh an
occupation for others so um so you know
in uh deference to that Hobby
uh we would like to find a way to allow
permitted use of drones in state parks
and uh while respecting privacy issues
and while respecting safety
issues there will be people testifying I
believe behind me or after me that are
more uh expert in this area um but
understand that uh for certain uses the
FAA requires a test uh a certification
for uh drone operators to operate within
certain uh airspace
limitations uh and so some of this uh
Bill deals with people who have that
certification or they're you know
they've proven to the federal government
that they're competent drone
operators so with that I'll take any
questions if you have
them thank you uh uh M uh representative
uh
do you say that there there's someone
behind you who would be uh willing to
step forward I believe that's the case
technical there is a Drew mamt is that
the person he's he's my constituent and
it was his request that this the bill
okay so
probably
the will uh with the unanimous consent
of the of the uh the committee will just
get right to the person who knows the
information rep representative
Egan thank you Mr chair thank you sir
representative for taking my question
yes should
um um why is the designation of 55
pounds in the legislation that's awfully
large for a
drone it may correspond with some
Federal Regulation I don't have the
answer for you right now but it that
would be my best guess that it it
corresponds with some uh
designation within the federal
guidelines thank
you uh seeing no other
questions representative you have
something yeah I think there's ideas for
improving this bill and I'm certainly
open to improving it um so thank you all
right thank you um chair calls Drew
memt hi there can you hear
me so my name is Drew Melman I'm from
Hollis New Hampshire I'm a data
scientist for IBM and I've been involved
with Aviation my entire life my my
father's a pilot my grandfather was a
pilot um my younger brothers are both
Pilots my uncle's a pilot I'm a pilot
I've been flying with my father since I
was about two weeks old um I soloed in
gliders when I was 16 years old and I
got my license for uh real planes when I
was 22 in
college um more relevant to this bill
I've been flying model airplanes since I
was about 8 years old um I've seen this
hobby change considerably in the last 15
years both from a technology standpoint
and from a regulatory standpoint in 2016
the federal government put in a program
um for certification of commercial drone
licenses and I was one of the first
people in the United States to get this
type of license so it's called part 107
license and allows me to be uh flying
drones for hire so I could be hired by a
real estate company or um I could sell
my work um to movie studios or whatnot
you can take photos and um do this for
higher um I got my first salary job um
as a direct result of having this part
107 license I did a lot of testing work
for a company down in New Jersey um that
does analytics with satellite data um we
use drones as a platform for testing out
some of these capabilities and testing
out different
algorithms um but I became aware of of
this uh rule for state parks in about
2020 prior to this this was an
unregulated activity and people could
fly drones on state land without really
much issue um I think the problem kind
of started coming around when a lot of
people had more access to these drones
and I guess somebody decided that they
wanted to um bar everyone from using
drones without having prior permission
there is apparently a process in place
for getting that per Mission um but it
it I believe it is on duerden on both
commercial and recreational drone Pilots
um it takes very long to get this permit
um uh one of my friends Marie sapena
cannot be here today she's a former
State Rep and she submitted you guys um
a very long written testimony that's
very thorough and goes into long detail
about um this whole process so she was
able to get a permit at one point she's
been featured in the new Wildlife
Journal um with some of her drone
photography so that's the official
journal for um the fishing F or the uh
fishing game Bureau
um so yeah she has a lot of detail I
have that testimony in front of me um so
I can go into detail with some of the
some of the facts that she had um just
trying to go through so what the two
main desires with this bills um just
much easier ability to um have
recreational and Commercial Dr Pilots be
able to fly in State Park land um again
this was previously an unregulated and
allowable activity um and then the
second desire is to promote tourism the
Strone Hobby and stem Fields throughout
New Hampshire um through this
photography uh which has significant
viewership on social media so um the New
Hampshire tourism page has a lot of
these photos being featured on on their
Instagram account and various other
social media sites um so these pictures
do get used quite a bit so it's photos
and
videos
um another interesting point so this is
a precedent already most towns and uh
Town parks and trails do allow drone
flight already this is unregulated and
I've not been able to find any
municipality in New Hampshire that does
currently ban drones on
townland
um and then another precedent as well is
that drones are already allowed um in
the White Mountain National Forest in
designated areas um you do have to go
through a per permitting process through
them uh to be allowed to do this um and
in Marie's testimony she went into
detail about how it's much easier to get
a hunting permit to hunt in state parks
than it is to uh be able to fly drones
and be permitted to to do this activity
in state parks
um so the state government has no j
ition over drone and airspace rules once
the Drone is in Flight you have the
ability to regulate uh where drones can
take off and land and this bill goes
into explicit detail about um some of
the limitations on um when recreational
Pilots would be able to uh be allowed to
um do uh the takeoff and
landings
um some of the sticking
points uh with some of the opposition
would be about the burden on Wildlife um
again hunting and Motor Vehicles
represent in my mind a bigger burden on
um nature there in both terms of noise
and in terms of lethality on um yeah
just wildlife and other um natural
resources uh the reporting requirement
for the non-licensed pilots and spill is
consistent with existing federal
reporting requirements um when you're
flying drones within the proximity of
airports you do have to let the airport
know that you're you're flying and you
can either do this through an app or in
other cases you have to give them a
phone call um so this reporting
requirement to try to mimic um some of
those existing regulations in
place um another member of the
opposition mentioned um these causing
forest fires the only case that I could
find was a case out west in I believe
Arizona where it a drone crashed and
caused small brush fire they were able
to extinguish the fire very quickly um
but this does not represent a
significant
risk um trying to see what else I
wrote um yeah again this is just I think
a great way to promote stem careers in
New Hampshire and uh get younger people
outside and using drones um in a safe
way
um so in my testimony I went through and
I put a nice table together on just
comparing commercial drone users versus
recreational drone users both of which
um are permitted Under The Spill um as
Keith was mentioning there is a
certification program for commercial
drone users this is called the part 107
certification it takes many days to
study for this exam if you're already a
part 61 pilot so Private Pilot like
myself you can get this as an add-on a
little bit more
easily um but for general public uh it
is a difficult exam you do have to learn
a lot about the airspace requirements
and safe flying and um again yeah this
is an area that's become more and more
regulated and I do think these
regulations um help make it a safer
hobby
um so you can take a look at that table
Marie put together another table that
was kind of interesting trying to find
it yeah yeah
comparing um the two activities hunting
versus drone operations in state parks
and yes you need education for both
um just trying to see if there's
anything else interesting so um last
year in New Hampshire there were 49,000
hunting permits per state there's about
8,600 uh part 107 drone users so that's
that's a portioned um evenly among
states so it might be a little bit less
because New Hampshire small in the
average State um in terms of noise
gunshots about 140 to 175 DB uh a drone
like this and actually let me unfold
this for you so you can see it so this
fits in a backpack I can actually go
hiking with this it's quite small um I
can answer the question about the weight
requirement I think there was something
about that before I mean most drones are
about the size um this is a couple
pounds um yeah the FAA regulation does
allow this to be up to 55 PBS that's a
federal um thing
but most drones are about the size um I
don't think there's a lot of I don't
think the state has a lot of control
over um size limitations once the the
Drone is in
Flight
um again yeah that's out of your your
jurisdiction um so again um in terms of
noise this is about 70 DB traffic
outside is about 80 DB uh decb is a
logarithmic scale so roughly every 10 DB
is doubling in the intensity that you
perceive the noise so this is about half
as loud as um autom Opals outside we in
that scale considerably less um loud
than
gunshots um in terms of safety there
were two deaths in New Hampshire in 2021
due to hunting which is permitted in
state
parks and we could only find one case
back in 2016 where a drone caused um
somebody to get bruised and cut but it
was not a death Marie put in a nice map
of the White Mountain National Forest
showing where drones are permitted and
most of it you can fly drones um there
are some regulated Wildlife areas where
you can't launch drones and that's also
um a regulation for uh regular planes as
well there are certain altitude
restrictions about flying too low over
some of these um this areas so that that
is an important Federal
rule um just trying to see what else she
put together she is a lawyer she put a
lot of good information together um term
in terms of like fact sheets let's see
what
else I think that's about it as far as
information I have to to say do you have
any questions
any questions by members of the
committee representative Smith for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um the you
have focused on the state park rule but
the State trail system is a lot more
expansive than state
parks so I wondered you know what you're
what the why are you focusing on state
parks when the state trails
are all you know a lot more expansive
than the parks themselves I'm going to
have to defer to Keith a little bit on
the terminology but yeah I personally
believe that drones should be permitted
on all public land like that land
belongs to all of us like this was an
activity that was permissible in all
these public spaces previously um and I
think this is a great way to um begin
implementing this and I think I don't
know the exact terminology between state
parks versus a Statewide trail system um
but my intent is to be able to fly
drones in state
parks thank you not sure if that answer
the question
but any any other question by
anyone um thank you I uh I was just
wondering I am a drone certified drone
pilot as well um how could you clarify a
little bit about uh how for instance
people would their privacy would be
protected when they're using a state
park or a trail say they were riding
their uh bike and I know for instance
with a lot of the drones you can you can
follow someone and be followed and
tracked that way I think I believe that
is why for instance it in ski areas they
don't allow drones you could track
people and have a a drone flying
overhead so there's a is a privacy issue
that needs to be addressed I think the
bill seems has Merit I mean it'd be nice
to be able to allow this but at the same
time we need to protect people's privacy
when they're using parks and trails as
well thanks thank you that's a very good
question um this bill does directly um
address that if you look at the bottom
of the bill there is a clause in there
um addressing the Privacy issue you
cannot um spy on somebody essentially
without their written consent um and
that parallels an existing law in Sp in
um New Hampshire there's only one law in
the books regarding drones currently and
you cannot spy on somebody hunting
without their written consent um so we
took that language directly out of that
existing law
um I guess also in regards to that like
there was a big discussion when um
cameras came about over 150 years ago
and there were a lot of concerns um with
privacy way back
then um and a lot of people didn't want
to have cameras on the street they felt
it was a big breach in the
Privacy um but we've as a society have
um kind of come to accept that when you
step outside you are in the public
domain and you do give up some sense of
privacy so I do under concern about
being spied on um but this doesn't
represent any different of a privacy
breach um
than somebody like with a camera or a
phone or whatever recording you on the
trail but yeah I do understand that
concern and the whole
loitering um concern is addressed with
with that Clause that um prohibits
spying on
people thank you chair um well I see
here it says no person shall use the uh
uas with the intent to conduct video
surveillance um but is not
defined uh obviously you'll be filming
people in the park possibly but it would
be no different than somebody filming
with her iPhone or whatever with you
know igers walking down the trail in
fact um I think with footage on the
ground people's faces and all that would
be more visible that's perfectly
permissible thing I can walk down the
street here in conquer and I can record
people's faces without any any ruling
against that um in fact people's faces
from above are not visible at all um so
I think it's actually less of a risk
than somebody walking around with an
iPhone the only issue I would have with
that is well you you can confront
someone with a camera who's who's in
your face but you can't confront a
person with a drone the drone's up in
the air you what would you do if a drone
was following you you'd have no recourse
of you can't see where they are perhaps
but you'd also be a lot further away and
you wouldn't be as visible in in the
photos representative Huff for
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for coming and testifying today um you
said that it used to it used to be
allowed and now it's disallowed um do
you know how that is disallowed is it an
RSA is it a an agency uh uh rule or or
what I don't have the specific details
maybe Keith can um further elaborate on
some of that but I believe there was
some decision made by a regulator within
the State Parks Commission that decided
one day that they needed a post
everywhere that you can't fly drones I
don't know if um it went through the
exact formal rul making process or if
there is such a thing um but they put up
the signs and that's kind of the extent
that I know follow up Mr chair for a
followup um so if that's the case um I'm
assuming that there were reasons why
they wanted to put that up instead of
just
maybe repealing that law and just
letting it go I'm assuming that this is
an an attempt to kind of play into not
play in that's not a great uh uh word um
to acknowledge the possibilities of of
their concerns and regulate it in more
of a safe way or a more uh uh
eco-friendly and and and and public
friendly so that the issues that may
have been arised previously to make them
ban it might not be quite as prevalent I
think that's a correct assessment of
what we're trying to achieve here trying
to weigh the concerns of um safety and
management on on their end but then also
allow people like like myself and other
commercial and recreational drone users
to be able to have access that we
previously had thank you very
much thank you by the way the
commissioner Parks will be the next one
up to speak to adjust your concerns uh
any other questions from this this uh
representative harb for
question thank you and thank you for
taking my question I you may not have
this but I wonder do you have any
statistics on drone failures my concern
is it's flying around and it crashes
even though it may not be negligent on
the part of the Drone flyer or the pilot
but like cars and things like that do
you have any statistics I don't have any
hard numbers with me um I do have the
number that Marie uh gave me and there
was only one case that she could find in
New Hampshire of somebody getting um
basically cut and bruised because of the
Drone I think they were trying to like
maybe catch it or something and it maybe
hurt their hand or maybe they were near
bystander I'm not in entirely sure the
exact case um again but this doesn't
present any more of a risk than any
other falling object out of the sky like
somebody could throw a rock off a cliff
and it could hit somebody in the head
and they could die that way I mean
there's a lot of other risks out there
like that I think this is actually
probably safer than um plenty of other
activities that go on um already in in
state parks thank
you any other
questions repr mville answer this but
I'm wondering about the enforcement
of folks that aren't licensed because
you're mentioning the bill mentions that
they have to notify the commissioner so
is the commissioner going to be
available day night evening and and how
do you see that as a as a pro who
capably launches and lands your aircraft
how do you see that as someone who's not
a pro managing that and going through
this enforcement process so I believe
the way the bill is written is the
commissioner or somebody delegated by
the commissioner can take the um the
permit or whatever the request so here's
how I Envision it like a non-licensed
person or they've gone through the trust
certification I guess if they don't have
this part 107 license so currently as it
stands like even if you don't have the
license that I have you're still
supposed to take this online tutorial
and it's like an hourong test so
everyone that's flying drones now has to
take some form of Education whether it's
the license that I have it's more
difficult or um this trust certification
online it's like tutorial like YouTube
video type thing there's a quiz at the
end it's just basically um instilling
safe safety practices so everyone has
that from the get-go but somebody with
that trust certification how I Envision
is they email or they call somebody
within the state park commission um with
a request so this is either a day or or
30 minutes before when they go
flying um so they're going to email with
that request and they'll say um the
location they plan on
flying and um yeah what they're going to
do um that's their notification they can
go out and fly um if somebody within the
state park commission doesn't want them
to fly because of the different reasons
spelled out in the bill um they can uh
notify the person with a request that
they do not have permission to fly and
that's how I intend it to work um so
it's a notification requirement um and
there's a little bit of a Time threshold
for somebody within State Park
commission to give feedback and say no
if they need to but otherwise it's an
immediate
yes representative Smith for a
question yeah thank you Mr chair um
thank you for taking my question um you
just said that that if you are not
licensed you're required to take a uh
test or tutorial or something like that
who is that required by it's required by
the Federal Aviation Administration so
if you buy one of those those little
Cheapo drones that are like a $100 or
something I don't know how much they
cost you have you're someone gives you a
test or gives you a course it's
actually I don't know how well it's
enforced but it's highly encouraged for
you to take it and it is a requirement
um again yeah I don't really know what
the enforcement is like on their end but
it says all over the FAA website that
recreational users have to take one of
these these courses and there's about 10
of them that they they've certified so
you can either do it through the Boy
Scouts or the Academy of model
Aeronautics um so you have a bunch of
different options um as far
as so I it looks like in oh sorry
followup um it looks like in the bill on
line 21 it says prior to launch they
have to notify the commissioner so
there's no permission given you were
talking about denying permission but
this doesn't say anything about
permitting or permission it's just
notifying the commissioner within either
30 minutes and no more than 24 hours
before they're going to correct a lot of
areas with an aviation you just
basically have to notify and that kind
of parallels a lot of things within
Aviation um B basically a no answer
means you have permission to to do what
you you intend to do um and that
parallels existing regulations in place
like previously you had to notify an
airport they didn't have to call you
back but you just had to let them know
what you intended to do and this bill
intends to parallel that so that should
not be um too
concerning okay and final
followup yeah um the the last thing is
um since the there is nothing in the
bill about being uh the uh taking the
course or the tutorial or whatever it is
would you object to that going into the
bill that um if they don't have a
license they should show provide proof
that they've taken a class or done
something I have no objection for you
mentioning the the trust certification
in the bill if you need to amend it that
way that's pretty reasonable
um
but um yeah again it's a federal
requirement so I don't know if it needs
to be spelled out again in state law but
again I think that would be reasonable
if you need to spell out that that trust
thank you
cerification anyone
else seeing no one thank you very much
for your testimony thank
you uh call the next uh person to
testify uh Philip Bryce director
division of
Parks still morning good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Philip Bryce I director of the
division of Parks and Recreation
Department of natural and cultural
resources
um I have copies of my testimony and I
might add a couple of additional
comments uh Beyond what's written um so
the division is very concerned with the
impact that this bill would have on
recreational experience of our visitors
and continued access to the trails in
the Statewide trail system that cross
private land protecting the quality of
that experience is one of the purposes
of our administrative rules and I would
point out that under under our current
administrative rules drones are not
permitted on um our state parks our
state forest our state
reservations
um impact of drones on other
recreationists we are concerned that
drone use on hiking trails on lands
owned by the state will negatively
impact other recreational users of the
trail system who are otherwise expecting
to be able to enjoy a quiet experience
on the trail our current administrative
rules governing the use of Department
land state the following the properties
uh or portions of a property shall be
closed or restricted for Public Access
by posting or public notification if the
quiet enjoyment of the recreational use
of the property by other users or
budding land owners is being disturbed
our rules go on to say under the
reserved and privileged use of public
lands and facilities and resources which
is where we issue special use permits
for drones States degradation of visitor
experience means the event activity or
use disrupts traditional
traditional very important word uh
public park use or unduly inconveniences
AB budding land owners of the general
public and causes or might cause any of
the following conditions including
conflict with the use of dread lands
facilities and Resources by the public
at large note those resources would
include
wildlife and increasingly there is uh
research being done on the impact of
trails in general uh without adding uh
whether they're motorized or you add
other activities on those Trails
excessive noise so as to deny others
their right to quiet enjoyment of
recreational use of dread lands
facilities and resources and of course
the complaints by visitors although the
bill uh prohibits video Sur uh
surveillance of private City citizens we
wonder how the operate of the Drone can
be sure that no one else is in the area
and this provision as far as work
concerned is
unenforceable uh so anytime there's this
assumption that because you put
something in statute or make a law or
rule that that everybody's going to
comply and those of you who are familiar
and use our Parks extensively no we have
a lot of difficulty in enforcing
something as simple as a dog leash uh
rule loss of recreational access we are
dependent upon the willingness of
private land owners to allow trails in
the Statewide trail system to cross
their lands for public use we are very
concerned that those land owners would
no longer permit the public use of their
property
if drones were required to be permitted
and I would point out um some of you are
familiar that state lands state park
lands are part of dread dread that's
what they originally called uh dncr
reservations State reservations include
state parks State Forest Wayside areas
natural areas all of the all of the um
properties that are under the ownership
of the state or under the control of the
state state so even if we change the
word the word and keep in mind the word
Park is
um uh Park is just a a term so you have
pisca state park for example which is
Zone mostly 99% for forestry and for uh
wildlife and natural
areas uh you have be Brook State Park
which is 60% zoned the same way Parks
only managing is a small portion of the
hundreds of thousands of Acres that the
agency has and those are the developed
Park sites however those that term
reservations also includes properties
over which we have control and
recreational uh recreational control so
it would include those Trails where we
have rules controlling use of those
Trails across private land so even if
you don't say Statewide trail system and
you go to Parks keep in mind that when
you say Parks you're only you're not
talking about all the state lands that
are used for recreation which includes
you know state forests like Gile and
others uh but you also then in addition
bring in the um still bring in the
private land
issue commercial use under
administrative rule a special use is
required a special use permit is
required for commercial use special
means any event activity or use that is
beyond the normal routine recreation use
of a spe specific property
um so we do issue commercial permits uh
uh if you're conducting a commercial
activity on state land you need a permit
because that that land is owned by the
um the people of the citizens of the
State of New Hampshire and actually the
citizens of the nation because of
federal funding and long ago it was
determined that if you're receiving a a
a commercial benefit from the use of
that that property picture for some uses
you know having to go out and buy that
property can take that activity the
expectation is that the the the um the
state the state and the park system
would receive a compensation for that
use that is especially important given
as as you all know that we're an
operationally self-funded Park system um
and that that commercial use permit also
helps ensure that the commercial use
isn't interfering with the recreational
use we do work very closely with the
division tourism uh um to uh to Grant
permits so people can do uh promotional
work for the state of New Hampshire
obviously at uh permit based on the
impact on the park um the issue is is we
have we issue literally hundreds of
permits and we're trying to continue to
develop
we're trying to continue to make things
simpler if you go to our website things
that before you had to call the office
you can start to like you can start to
reserve Pavilions uh
online um uh and so we're we're
continuing to move with our enterprise
system in that direction to be able to
Grant permits more simply um but
nonetheless uh uh at some point at some
levels of activity there needs to be
more dialogue between this the uh the
agency and the person who wants to uh um
uh conduct that activity and I I would
us just add that leg you know the
legislation should be cons considered to
be uh to be compared with what the FAA
rules we did not do that we did not
filter that uh do that filter to check
to make sure that the legislation is
consistent with those rules we we can't
Pro prohibit uh drones from flying over
State lands um but we can prohibit them
from uh Landing and taking off on on the
the lands under our our jurisdiction and
when we think of drone use you know we
think of places like Hampton beach with
100,000 people and um you know would it
every if if a lot of people have drones
is that really something you want to
want to see and I would agree that there
are certainly cases where drone use is
not going to impact anybody it's going
to be fine but our problem is is sort of
sifting that out uh as to as to uh where
it's appropriate ensuring that it
doesn't impact with with um uh have a
negative impact on what the primary
purposes and the traditional uses of our
properties are be glad to answer any
questions or help the committee any
further address
this I think I have one one question at
least the to be uh need more more
specific on uh
you you have the the
prohibition or is now on all state
property or well on the on the when I
say State lands that are under the
jurisdiction of our agency of of the
Parks and Recreation of of dncr dncr
yeah our rules if I may respond y our
rules apply to State reservations that's
how the lands are are designated in New
Hampshire and it works right really
really well it's not so we can optimize
the use of those properties so you
conduct harvest in a a a state park
because it's very um it's very uh
appropriate to do so based on the
conditions of the forest and the the
need to improve wildli habitat Etc and
then you had cases like state forests
that have pretty intense recreational
use of course one of the best examples
of that that is Livermore Falls that is
actually in estate Forest uh and that's
a wonderful recreational site um uh
along the river there and on a beautiful
historic site as
well any questions representative Kon
yes sir thank thank you for your
testimony um and I I understand that the
challenge with bothering people who want
to walk quietly uh how do you do how do
you balance motorcy
uh
ATVs snowmobiles other recreational
vehicles that are quite honestly a
little bit louder than a drone might be
um and yet and yet thousands of those
people use the the resources every day
yeah how how does that compare to a 70 D
drone that weighs less than five pounds
yeah um very good question so you cannot
opiz a motorized vehicle Le on aate
property unless it's designated for that
use so you just can't go anywhere with a
with a um a trail bike or a uh or an ATV
so those trails are designated so the
user knows generally knows when they go
onto that trail that they're likely to
come across uh somebody else whether
you're an equestrian or whether or not
you're a mountain biker or a hiker
whatever um whatever it is and that and
that trail system is there there's a lot
of trails that are not accessible for a
motorized um uh use you know manad the
entire trail system on an Agnon
including uh the the lands that the
state leases from the forest Society you
know um uh you know there's no motorized
access uh uh permitted on on on um that
site so it it's you know you're starting
to um address sort of the challenge of
balancing all of the different users and
their impact on the environment and each
other and we're trying to minimize the
impacts on each other as much as we
possibly can which is of course why we
don't just allow um motorized vehicles
to go wherever they want on on uh dncr
reservations for a
followup for a follow
up so so s
okay is there then uh
a modification this bill considering
that the people using those drones are
constituents they are citizens with
rights to access to the land what what
kind of modification could be made
to uh allow that as you've done for the
other the other vehicles well as I said
I I mean the thought the the the IDE
comes up will designate certain places
where drones can be
used uh but I I
would in many respects
um in many
respects there's a there PE part of it
is people getting used to certain
things um and so and there's and that's
why we talk about the traditional uses
so so you know the issue was brought up
about hunting hunting you know is much
louder of course it's a shorter period
of time
um and um but it is it's much it's much
louder than a drone but that is that is
a traditional use and and you know and
part of the culture of the State of New
Hampshire what we we are particularly
challenged and this is also even
includes with ATVs is when new
technology comes along that creates an
additional uh um uh you know desire to
use public lands to to carry out that
activity
and so I cannot tell you really what
would be appropriate for for drone use
my first concern is the impact on our
access on trail systems that are on
other people's property that that so
that would have to be clearly addressed
that this only includes lands that are
owned by the state and secondly I would
want to really fully understand the use
the the issue of the issue of um
uh uh privacy and enforcing that privacy
is is is everywhere I think there is a
difference between a drone taking a
picture I recognize it's taking a
picture and taking you know taking a
picture I recognize that there's there
you know that there is the issue of a
camera but people understand what that
is today and we're all used to that
happening and there's you know the point
of proximity was was made up so
um I I think this is really something if
you want to try to do something one of
the one of the ways to approach it is to
provide for this to occur in rul making
so it's put in the context of all of the
other dread dread dncr and they say
dread now because they haven't been
updated um recently uh the dncr rul
making process so that that is that is
one approach and it's put in the context
of all the other uses we have an when we
when we redo the rules we go through an
extensive public engagement process that
I think some of you might be familiar
with so we get a lot of feedback from
users in the in the last set of rules it
was the
equestrians um so that's one that is
that is the vehicle by which we would
try to come to grips with with the use
of drones on state lands but in the
short term we're just very you know we
don't we we just don't think that drones
up at Canon are going to be good um you
know we prohibit them there um even
though somebody wanted might want to you
know it's a cool place beautiful
location we we don't think that's
appropriate and so we need to have
something in place under our existing
rules and and made the decision not to
permit
them I have representative Egan followed
by representative harb is anyone else
who wants to get in
line no if not representative Egan thank
you Mr chair thank you director Bryce
for taking my question uh in previous
testimony there was a concern about
being drone use being able to be used by
professionals that might need to do it
for their work is there now a system of
Permitting for professionals whether
land surveyors commercial photographers
to process a permit to use a drone on
state lands and if there is a process
can you explain how that gets executed
yes there is a process it's a special
use permit for for non sort of
non-traditional uses um we're trying to
streamline that process it's sometimes
it's hard for us to keep up with the
changes and expectations of our users on
public lands we're very cognizant of
that um like we're working on permits
for uh working with our permit person
when can you get the permit out for the
ATV Festival in Berlin when can you get
the permit out for the seafood festival
out in in Hampton so that's kind of the
scale of what we're ISS we're dealing
with with the special use permit process
but yes anyone can ask for a permit to
to use a drone on on um on state land
for commercial use or or or
not and is there a fee for that and is
it the special use permit fee is
$10000 for example guides that are
guiding uh that want permission to guide
in developed recreational areas we issue
a a permit for them for $100 to to be
able to do that um so and that's set in
the fee package that's approved by the
fiscal committee last followup so there
is a system in place for anyone that a
professional use that wanted to utilize
a drone in their professional capacity
to work with the park system and get it
executed quickly and cost- effectively
yes but I'd be remiss if I didn't say
it's not the smoothest most friendliest
system but there is a system thank you
very
much representative harp thank you and
thank you director Bryce for taking my
question um I just wanted to clarify
without this bill your department still
has the ability to review your rules and
regs and then to if you decide
appropriate what place what location
what regulations you could set uh
regulations allowing drones when deemed
appropriate under a revised rules is
that correct that is correct thank
you any question representative
post yes thank you for um allowing me to
speak um and thank you for being here
today
um would you say on average um how many
requests you would get in a
year for using it on the park system
having drones used on a park
system I could not I don't know how many
drones are are sold I think what and you
hit a really really key issue in trying
to manage public Recreation um which is
uh the the the difference between when
it's like one or two people and it's
like thousands of people and so um and
that changes the overall impact of the
activity for you know we hear that with
the uh ATVs which this committee has
worked with for years that you know one
ATV going by your house or two you're
not going to bother with but we get
complaints that you know there's like
200 apbs going by our house and so how
do how do we address that so I think
it's a matter of scale you know if it's
if it's if you're going up to hike up
karge and um uh you know and and there's
the whole issue of campgrounds do you
allow them in campgrounds so if you're
in a campground and one person has a a
small drone like he has and is just
flying it around their campsite for fun
that's one thing but if every Camp
camper has one in a confined area and is
is using them or on a trail everybody
has a drone you know that just changes
the whole the whole um you know the
whole uh issue of of impact so very good
question follow up have you had
conversations within the agency of
making any kind of
approvals um for use in different
areas we we we currently have a drone
policy in play right now that we're
working on uh
finalizing um temporarily till we go to
to till we go to ruem and we're working
with um Patrick Hackley the director of
forest lands on that because most of the
acreage that would be affected would be
that uh Acres so we're currently working
on finalizing that and
um uh and then we'll it'll need to be
taken up and
Ru but right now as I said before
anybody can request a permit to fly a
drone let's say if you're we have them
for re we you know do them for research
do them for mostly it's either research
or it's mostly for commercial uh
photography or to support um support the
uh the tourism division of
Tourism one more
follow um so as
recreationally do you get many
calls well as as the gentleman
uh who Who provided great testimony
earlier said um there's currently no
restrictions on trones of State lands so
I I I'm sure there's a lot of people
that are using them and don't think that
it's a permit's required so that's the
case where you know we don't have any
enforcement capacity in
Parks uh so until we get a complaint
about something we're not going to
follow up so I don't have I don't have a
sense for how many people would ask or
how many many people are out there using
drones unless it's in one of those
places that is heavily used heavily
managed like it they're they're they
have a lot of issues with people trying
to use drones at Cannon both in the
summer and the winter and in frankon and
not State Park you know just picture
walking on your Flume uh on the walkway
and going up there and having a bunch of
Zone drones zipping by you taking
photographs which would be great it's a
beautiful place to do that so there
there are some places where it really
has a significant impact on your
experience and we run in usually those
places the ones that we run into the
most likelihood that somebody's going to
be trying to use a drone and in that
case we're going to deny it you know
during the you know we're not going to
let you fly drones during you know
during the season uh up The Flume you
know so for personal
use thank you Mr than very much
[Music]
uh tiricia Lambert and Jason levit New
Hampshire do Bureau of
Aeronautics good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee U my name
is uh Trisha Lambert and I'm the
administrator for the Bureau of
Aeronautics um with the Department of
trans ation and with me I have Jason
levit who is our uas or drone planner
within the
department um for those who aren't
really familiar with who we are and what
we do we are a small Bureau um however
we um oversee all the
regulatory um actions for all aircraft
which now include um uas or
drones um we're also um a Construction
Group so we build infrastructure for
Aviation
um and
um I guess one of the big things that we
do and I want to be really clear for us
is that one of our biggest jobs is to
promote Aviation and that includes
everything from whether it's your um a
glider man aircraft commercial aircraft
that everybody uses down to the uas uh
drone um
we um we're opposing this bill as
written um only because I think there's
issues within the bill as written um and
some of them are technical some of them
I I think are um agency jur state agency
jurisdictional I believe that there are
some issues with
um um trying the compliance aspect of it
and the enforcement um we are the
enforcement agency for Aviation um so we
we respond to aircraft accidents we
respond to drone
accidents um and so we think there's
some cross agency issues with the bill
as it says um and then um finally I
think there's some land jurisdiction
which I is not my hat but I will share
it that's part of the Department of
Transportation so uh as part of the bill
one of the things that we had put into
last legislative session was that
actually to define a uas this bill tries
to yet Define it again and that creates
a bad Patchwork of things of which makes
it difficult for us to to regulate um it
is in fact a federal registered
vehicle um which makes it very different
than anything else in the state um which
is why it comes under specifically under
under the Department of Transportation
Bureau of Aeronautics who is the liaison
to the
FAA the second issue
um is
uh it mentions that the that dncr
commissioner will have the approval
there are other um trails that are owned
by the Department of
Transportation uh that we would need to
have that uh AB the commissioner of the
Department of Transportation would need
to have that right to to make those
decisions um specifically relating to
the to the rail trails that are still
under the ownership and mainten uh
management of the
department and
finally the federal preemption piece is
is I'll give you an example of the one
is the Federal Aviation administ ation
they mentioned that they have to add
they want more information put on the
Drone the federal the FAA uh registers
about 800 has about 800,000 drones
registered it requires it has a federal
number um Federal registration number on
aircraft we call it an nend number um
some drones can have an end number or
they'll just have a regular number ass
assigned to that um I believe the
individual is that correct to the
individual who owns them that is on the
aircraft when you start trying to put
other information in there so that they
can track it to try to figure out who
owns the
Drone um that would be Federal
preemption because now the Drone
operator does not have to do that um the
second part is is I'm not quite sure how
they're going to enforce it because
young children as young as 13 own these
drones and so you're not going to be
able to track back to the FAA to get
that information because they're minor
so you can see it creates this
Enforcement issue um which even we as a
we can probably get it as Lea is on the
FAA but the minor become an issue I'm
not sure they would give that to us so I
see an Enforcement issue as it relates
to it
um and and I'm G to keep it really
simple with that we're happy to take
questions we're happy to work with
anybody it is clear that anybody who
owns property has the right to um make
the decision whether you can launch or
land a drone at that property whether
it's your private property or whether
it's State Property um but overflights
and I know that was mentioned I don't
like to repeat but overflights you
cannot restrict it's under the
jurisdiction of the of the federal
government under the FAA so with that
I'd be happy to answer questions um
either Jason or I depending on what it
is any questions from members of the
committee
seeing none thank you thank you very
much Robert Johnson for one
minute thank thank you Mr chair members
of the committee for the record Rob
Johnson representing the New Hamshire
Farm Bureau as the federation's policy
director and newshire farm consists of
just under 2,000 Family Farm memberships
and then another 1,000 supporting
members we are opposed to the bill as
drafted representativ uh Smith touched
on it with an earlier question as and
the director did mention it and he did
not say the the amount bit I've heard in
the past my understanding is that the
Statewide trail system it's something
like 75 to 80% of that trail system is
on private property much of it running
through our members property and much of
it is snow wheel trails and as a as a
private land owner my family has has uh
land uh uh Trails on our our property uh
that that we are uh we want to support
we want to support the Public's use um I
don't think it's the intent of this bill
but if it were to pass as is to allow
for drones over the Statewide trail
system you would not have a Statewide
trail
system and I I'll leave it at that Mr
chair thank
you thank you very much any questions by
members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very
much and Jason
stock from the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners
Association good afternoon uh for the
record Jason stock executive director of
the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association and I will be very brief
basically what Rob said we are in the
same place these Trails the Statewide
trail system crosses our our members
property and when those Trails when that
land owner agreed to allow the trail
across their property I am quite certain
drones were never
contemplated and for that reason you
know our our members it was a specific
use that was granted um there's always a
privacy concern someone launches a drone
near my buildings or near my my resid
pres you know I'm not not going to be
real I may not be real comfortable about
that so for that reason I'm coming today
to oppose the bill as drafted would be
happy to continue to participate in any
further discussions thank
you any questions representative post uh
representative
kraton thank you very much for taking my
question and um uh your members or the
people that you're representing um
assuming with the property they have
they they have current use right correct
um so in and and I don't know any of
this but um in most occasions there are
different levels of
use um for current uses for
recreationally hunting things like that
you can prohibit or you can allow uh has
there been any discussion about allowing
is this been a
conversation um
about allowing
drones as part of a current
use system because if you have current
use and you deny deny a recreation or
something like that that can be removed
as current
use so I just wondered if that was you
know something people had discussed
because this is part of the future and
there are so many people that do have
this sure sure so first off in in
current use is a another ball of wax but
it's a tax it's a a means of assessing
taxes um on property based on the use in
New Hampshire our current use program
you have current use that assesses taxes
based on whether you're growing trees or
growing an agricultural crop and that
assessment is based on that land's
productive capability to produce cords
of wood bushels of corn Etc in New
Hampshire as a way to kind of create an
incentive to for land owners to keep
their land open for outdoor recreation
there is an incentive in built into the
program it's called the recreational
discount that your assessment you can
say agree that yes I will allow
pedestrian access and it's pedestrian
access um I will allow that and I can
and by making that notice and filing
with the town that you're allowing this
you can receive an additional I believe
it's 10% of a reduction on your assessed
assessment not tax bill but the assessed
value of it um so land um if you have
land and you do not want people on it
you can still enroll it in current use
and post it current use is not a public
access um program it's just simply a tax
assessment program and it's really to
promote maintaining working Farms
working
Forest so drone use with even within the
context of current use has I am not
aware of any discussions about drone use
current use or any connection
there thank you you're welcome
representative kraton for a question
yeah thank you sir can you explain the
the testimony that that I understand so
far has said that the the issue is take
off and Landing the flying of the
Drone can be over anything private
property or anything um to similar to an
airplane airplane I'm a I'm a Private
Pilot I can fly as long as I'm over 500
feet so how does that impact on your on
your discussion if it's currently
allowed to fly over land anyway I
believe that's what the testimony said
so we're not talking about taking off
from those lands what we're what we're
what you've said is you can't take off
okay but you can fly over under current
law as I understand it yeah and great
question and so if I
have 50,000 acres and I have a trail
that cuts across it um what I heard I
heard exactly what you heard is I can
fly a drone the same as I could fly an
airplane or a helicopter over that
property um our issue though and we all
get that our issue is if I have that
trail across that property and now folks
are which is on my property and they're
using that as a a launching and landing
pad to go and fly over and and look at
my property maybe scope out a Timber
sale or whatever that's going on in my
property that's where we we start to get
a little longer uncomfortable I people
do video or aerial surveillance all the
time of the state we get that and that's
the world we live in but drones when I
talk to my my policy committee drones
there's a feeling that it's a little
more invasive it's a little more intense
um the type of scrutiny that can be done
with a drone versus a plane that's
flying over a mile above taking aerial
photographs
any other
questions see none thank you very
much there's no other I have no other
cards in front of
me uh so I think we'll call these this
uh call an adjournment for uh adjourn
the hearing on uh House Bill
and we will meet back
here at one o'clock the next
hearing no I
can't because you saw because I don't
want to have then we're going to be
huh
oh well you they'll be there'll be
more got to got to keep got to keep to
to
schedule
thing
green those all your lights go off so
that that
way
okay just call uh meeting to order for
house bill
51 call
Representative
Edon you have the
floor thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the resources and Rec
committee I'm excited to be here today
to introduce HB 1451 FN relative to the
recovery of submerged
logs uh this bill originated in October
of 2020 as a constituent request um and
thankfully the constituent is here um
because they know more a lot they know a
lot more about the issue than I do
um everybody on the committee should
have received the letter from the
Department of Environmental Services
last night um that outlined some pretty
critical structural issues in the bill
um I am happy to acknowledge that um as
this is not especially my area of
expertise um I made some drafting
mistakes uh in conflicting
rsas um
and uh I I acknowledge that what I think
my hope here today is um not to have the
committee OTP the bill or not to have
the committee it El the bill um as
written uh the constituent today um is
here to provide very what I thought uh
were substantive uh examples of what
we're trying to accomplished with this
bill uh create uh sort of a
demonstration of why something in this
realm is needed um and what I would hope
for is that we can either in from study
the bill move it to a study committee or
um make a very simple Amendment because
what I think I did in drafting this was
significantly over complicate the issue
uh and there will be a couple folks that
follow me that explain that um and I'm
happy to work with anybody on the
committee um to fix that um because I
think uh as you'll see there is some
substantive need um in my opinion for
something to come out of this so that's
all I have um I can take any questions
to the best of my ability um but I would
definitely refer any questions on
substance to the following presenter um
because like I said they know
considerably more about this issue than
I
do thank you the presenter would be uh
Jamie Irving correct okay
members of the committee you've uh heard
the testimony of Representative he uh
can we if well do you have any
questions seeing no questions thank you
very much and I would just say Mr
chairman uh the Mr Irving does have some
packets to pass around to folks um so I
would ask that we could distribute those
really quick just so everybody has
information in front of them for context
yep you can thank you bring them up and
I don't know how many packets do you
have oh go glad you said
okay see see what happens when you get
that
chair okay um Mr Irving uh tell is your
name uh and
full name your your uh town that from uh
who you
represent you ask to speak for a little
less than 10 minutes I guess uh
there's it's looking there most there
mostly El opposition so I'll allow
that wonderful um yes my name is Jamie
Irving I'm from Meredith New Hampshire
um thank you all for taking the time to
actually hear me
out the actual legislation of having to
do with submerge logs is way out of my
pay grade so what I was really just
focusing on is pointing out that there
is a valuable resource on the bottom of
the lakes ponds and rivers in New
Hampshire uh the packet that I have uh
for you just is a brief introductory
letter on the front the second
page and the third page are actual log
reserves one in Lake wyan and
and the other up on the anders scogin in
Berlin these are pretty um different
examples uh so I've been I've been a
scuba diver for 25 years U most of my
life and had an awful of opportunities
to see examples like this where there
are deposited logs in rivers and lakes
the walki WAN example um sorry for the
terrible pictures but they are probably
about 30 to 40 white oak logs just
sitting on the bottom of the lake they
were put there intentionally I believe
they were all actually saw logs and
they're all in fabulous condition I
don't know when they were put there I
don't know
why um but to harvest those would be as
simple as just getting a float bag and
actually floating them over to the
launch ramp which is about 100 yards
away so no actual machine would be
required for that the next picture up on
the anders scoggan you have a bunch of
logs that are actually embedded into the
into the river bank quite a different
situation and it would be a lot more
disruptive to the structure of the River
Bank than say the example of the logs on
the bottom of Lake Walk wyan could just
be
plucked so back in 1938 I'm sure you
guys are all aware of the hurricane that
came through was really quite
destructive New Hampshire didn't receive
as much of the um of the destructive
force of that hurricane as Vermont for
example but we did receive some uh to
the point where the department of
agriculture I think it
was actually created the northeastern
Timber Salvage Administration for the
sole purpose of getting the logs off of
the forest floor for two reasons one to
prevent all that fuel build up in case
of forest fire and second to actually
get a valuable res resource off off the
ground um they weren't able to do it
fast enough so what they ended up doing
was actually ditching a lot of those
logs into rivers and lakes well mostly
ponds and lakes so at some point we
could go back and actually get that
resource so it's obviously something
that's worthwhile and I I just think
that it's it would be a shame for there
not to be an Avenue for the general
public to be part of that
recovery um as it as it is right now all
those logs are sitting there and they're
the property of the state with no
realistic um way for the general public
to access those there is a law that or
an exemption rather the next page I
believe
the exemption for the grant and right of
submerged logs for municipalities and
that is basically allowed in cases where
there's a navigational Hazard or there's
some other problem that these logs are
creating there is one part in there that
says a municipality that receives a
permit under this section may enter into
a commercially reasonable private
contract to undertake log removal after
publicly requesting bids for such work
for your average citizen that that seems
like an awfully tedious process and my
day-to-day job is actually permitting
with the Department of Environmental
Services so I I understand first
firsthand how difficult sometimes it can
be so I guess my only my only request is
that you consider the fact that this is
a valuable resource and it's a historic
resource that um that should not go to
waste so thank you if you guys have any
questions anyone on the committee have a
question representative
post thank you Mr chair for taking my
question and thank you for being here
today um so one of my questions is um by
removing them they've been there so long
they're now part of the Lakes I'm
talking I guess about the um Lake wacaan
in Meredith they've been there so long
I'm sure there's uh habitats going on
and fishes and all sorts of things so
you would think except those part
particular logs um there isn't actually
a lot of structure the logs are piled on
one another so there are some areas that
you would be able to hide if you were a
fish but they're all really really
exposed so if you were to imagine a pine
tree falling upside down into the into
the water you're going to have more of
like a curtain and it's going to be a
lot better habitat so that's why a lot
of folks when they're going fishing
they're looking for those Fallen trees
these are these are just logs there are
no branches there's really nothing there
that provides any kind of signific ific
an habitat but that's not to say that
some of those reserves aren't providing
habitat so that's why the perverting
process I think would be would be
important I'm not saying that we should
just be you know everything should be
fair game to whomever that's why I
included the the picture of the Andre
scogan Reserve because that would be a
lot more impacting for Habitat whereas
the logs on walki Wan are just sitting
there like a pile of of Pickup Sticks
really follow and so can you tell me how
deep these are those are in about 25 to
30 feet of water you can almost on a
clear day with a sun right overhead you
can almost just see
them any other questions members of the
committee I have a few don't go away
um these these logs right now are the
property of the state of New hampire as
far as I understand yeah what
uh are if you're if if they're if you
how how are you looking
to uh you looking to have them wave the
right of ownership or uh because I
presume you're you're not collecting
these logs so that uh you can move them
to somewhere else you're collecting them
to sell
them uh so what would be what would what
are you view what are you looking at as
a a
process that that might be above my
level of expertise but what I would
Envision is is actually modeling after
the state of Michigan they have a
similar program so it's it's based on a
fee structure I think wouldn't differ
much than you know the mineral rights
for for for Excavating in you know in
rivers for gold um it's I don't and
actually Dees may may be able to speak
to that a little bit better than I can
but I I imagine a permitting process
that would there would be a flat
rate um fee if say for example I wanted
to Harbor those logs for myself not for
sale but then there would be an
additional rate based on any kind of
commercial gain if they were
sold um but as far as the transfer and
ownership that's I can't really speak to
that I don't know
enough well what I what I meant was
since they
they are owned by the state you would be
you would be would be they are state
property now and then but you would be
getting possession of them and
converting that so
just that's that's what I was what I was
so certainly something to consider yeah
uh I have
seen uh
on I'm so I don't know if was Discovery
or one of the other channels they did
something something I think it was on
Michigan and some of the logs that they
were taking out were you couldn't get
them now I mean I'm talking about Bird's
Eye Maple and stuff like that uh so
there's significant value to these so
would uh would would you look to have
create to have a uh some kind
of uh fee fee schedule on the on the
quality or this the value of the log
specifically I think that's a
that's difficult only because every time
you were to harvest anything then you
would have to bring in an
appraiser and who I don't really know
what the scale is for assessing the
value of submerged logs um I mean I
think in the legislation as was
introduced uh there were supposed to be
an an appraiser at the Mill when there
when the Timbers are actually being
milled I just don't see that being
very um for lack of better words it
seems kind of complicated to me um so
that's why I thought a flat rate for any
any removal and then in addition if
there were commercial sales then it
would be a percentage of that I think
the state of Michigan has a
5% uh sales tax for if you
will um something within reason so it's
not going to be prohibitive to actually
taking the logs out of the water in the
first place
any questions by any members of the
committee if
not thank you very much thank you folks
I appreciate
it chair
calls Diane Timmons New Hampshire
fishing game
department hi good
afternoon so I put a letter on
everyone's area hopefully I printed out
20 and I have an extra one so I must
have missed someone so I'll just set
that aside and I
apologize so good good afternoon
chairman Renzo and members of the House
resources Recreation and development
committee I want to start by thanking
you for the opportunity to speak and
testify regarding House Bill 1451 FN
regarding the some the sorry acquisition
of submerged logs my name is Diane
Timmons I'm recently in a new position
at New Hampshire fishing game um I'm the
Inland Fisheries division Chief as of
June so this is a new process for me so
bear with
me the New Hampshire fishing Game
Commission voted yesterday unanimously
to oppose this bill and we are in
opposition of the bill for the
environmental and resources uh detriment
that we think in expanding this
opportunity would
entail so first of all it's a little bit
redundant as the other gentlemen had
mentioned there is some um existing
statutes in place by the Department of
Environmental Services that allows the
acquisition of submerged logs um under
various um conditions the one I'm in
referencing is 482 A3 and also
482 a22
a so we take the Critter Approach at New
Hampshire fishing game and there's a lot
of um un unintended con consequences
that result from this the biggest thing
being in Fisheries that any detriment to
Habitat and wood is a huge component of
habitat for warm water cold water fish
as well as other aquatic
organisms and also water quality is
impacted when you start digging around
in these rivers and streams the other
thing is wood although it may look like
a simple pile it is
absolutely driving what that system
looks like in a in a river as flow comes
down if there's a bunch of logs that
water is forced around it causing an
Eddy approach so you get pools created
you get spawning gravel that gets
cleaned out through that type of event
so it's not just a pile of logs it's
Habitat creating
material what is vitalizing I mentioned
it also supports spawning um we have
been documenting a lot of wild
reproduction of brook trout and I can
tell you being originally from the
northern region region one in Lancaster
I've done a lot of work with wild brook
trout and river in rivers and streams
and all of my natural spawning sites not
one of them exists without some sort of
wood structure it's really really
important to helping clean that gravel
that those fish need for spawning and
it's not just wild brook trout it's
small minnos algae all sorts of bacteria
different things that are growing in
that water that you just don't
see so it also provides shelter as the
gentleman had mentioned there's all
sorts of little fishes hiding in that
area and they're doing that so the big
guys don't eat them so really really
important for different production of um
alternate
species it of course provides food bugs
love wood algae loves wood all of those
are basis of sorry the basis of the food
chain so without that structure you
wouldn't have that bottom layer of
forage so manipulating the sediment can
also release bacteria including
cyanobacteria causing algae and
bacterial blooms so
cyanobacteria provide poses as a health
risk for humans and pets as I'm sure
everybody is fully aware of and it also
causes various um issues with organisms
for example fish
kills so we would like to keep the
habitat as the habitat the way it stays
and the way it's been existing for
years and again I know it exists on um
various levels at this point but
expanding it to the general public I
think would be really
dangerous so reductions in gamefish also
impact the economy so in the 2021
American sport fish Association economic
impact study it revealed that $ 209
million was spent by New Hampshire
anglers in 2019 yielding
$338 million to New Hampshire's economy
so really really important you got to
start at the bottom with the habitat to
be able to produce the big fish that
amount to money on the other
end so New Hampshire has also spent
fishing game as also spent sorry new
hire fishing game has also spent 20
years restoring wood to streams and
lakes in the past for decades they
removed wood we had all sorts of
problems with flooding uh instability of
stream Banks issues with um Banks
laughing off and causing problems and
reducing spawning and all sorts of um
geomorphology so the structure of the
river so re making all the habitat
homogeneous meaning you took away pools
everything filled in with the dirt that
that's sloft off from the banks huge
problem so for years we have been
spending money on research and um
garnering partners with various State
and non-governmental organizations as
well as the federal government and have
proven and realized that um wood is
really really critical to multiple
organis multiple organisms at various
life
stages so the Fisheries habitat account
fund Within New Hampshire fishing game
we've spent over
$73,000 just with instream wood
projects so in closing I would like to
thank chairman ranula as well as the
members of the committee for giving me
this opportunity to speak on behalf of
the department fish and game department
and allowing me to testify today in
opposition of House Bill 1451 FN and we
hope that you do not allow the increased
removal of submerged locks and with that
if anybody has any
questions any members of the committee
have any
questions representative ghoul for
questions uh the logs that seem to be uh
alluded to in this bill are cut
logs and um so what is the difference
between cut logs in a in water versus uh
trees that fall in and I presume are the
ones that the Fisheries put in or
whoever does that are they just falling
into the water like naturally so to
speak or do they cut logs and put them
in so we do both we have some sorry if
this is echoing we have some that we do
cut and we have some that we actually
cut and let fall in so you get the whole
canopy cover the cut logs there's a um
so just to give an example it's it's a
little bit of
um it's a little bit of a perspective
thing so cut logs even though it looks
like just a simple cut log um for
example the North country is full of cut
logs in the dead Diamond River the
Connecticut River the anders Skagen
River all of those areas that were very
heavily logged in the forestry industry
and still today there's all sorts of old
cut logs in there from jams that
happened in the past that were dynamited
or broken apart and those logs that even
though they're just cut logs they
provide structure they provide cover
they increase um they all build up and
build what we wood GMS which is a huge
huge habitat thing all sorts of
creatures live in those including otter
and mink and all sorts of other bigger
larger um terrestrial as well as aquatic
animals um so it's different so fish
juveniles you know utilize both canopy
and the the cut logs log jams are
obviously a buildup of both and then the
cut logs can just create jams on the
side or again the structure of the
riverbed itself with the geomorphology
happening under various flow conditions
so both are very important we do both
we've CA we've cabled logs cut logs to
stones and boulders to be able to create
certain types of habitat that we trying
to you know aose or create a waterfall
or something like that so we've done
both both are very beneficial W period
no matter what no matter what form it's
in is really really important to
Habitat thank you for your testimony
ma'am so and according to the letter
that you sent out you said and you just
mentioned that there's uh two rsas that
would allow harvesting of
cut logs what is that process is that a
reasonable process that someone would go
through if they wanted to harvest these
logs um I will tell you that like him
I'm going to I'm going to pull the dees
non I should say the non Dees card and
the only reason I know about those is
because I did call the and speak with
them specifically about this and it's an
R I don't know exactly I believe it's
under their Dr dredge and fill permit
requirement and it allows municipalities
to be able to withdraw wood from um from
aquatic areas so but not businessman or
something of that nature not that I've
seen so we do have someone from Dees who
will be coming right after I'm like that
would be really good thank
you any other questions
by for the uh for the person
testifying seeing none thank you very
much thank
you
I'll okay we if we need
it uh chair calls Darlene Force New
Hampshire
Dees Department of Environmental
services at least so
far
she
yeah you were you Wen you were you were
not here for the
morning we had where we talked about
changing the de's
name there are so many
options the floor is
yours thank you um chairman Mulo my name
is Darlene Forest I'm the administrator
of the wetlands Bureau at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services we did email testimony to the
chair and to the committee
members in advance so you should have a
copy we are routing hard copies I
apologize I showed up with 20 but I gave
a couple to some folks in the audience
that that were curious what our position
would be so there's only 18 coming
around but I only counted 17 persons so
we should still have you
covered as a rather lengthy letter of
testimony I'm not going to regurgitate
the whole thing uh some flaws in the
legislation have already been mentioned
by the previous individuals
testifying there are processes to cover
this in Wetland statute now through the
standard Wetlands dredge and fill which
states anyone who needs to remove or
wishes to dredge materials from public
Waters needs a wetland permit that is
also qualifying those folks under the
Army cores programmatic General permit
for removal of things from public Waters
in addition to that it is mentioned as a
as a Project Specific criteria to go
through through the GNC process for logs
that are in lakes and ponds over 10
acres in size under RSA
42 a
22-a
so that process if this legislation were
to pass would still exist so in fact if
an individual wanted to go through this
new process which is in Mr deer who is
the Mr deer is the administrator of
watershed this legislation would create
a new permitting process in Watershed
which would need staff which which we do
not believe the funding is adequate
enough to pay
for so if you were to create that new
Under This legislation permitting
position and permiting process it would
not get that individual out of the need
to get the permit onto 42a so it's a
redundant process you're just actually
adding a layer of Regulation not
creating an Avenue per
se the it is true the process in RSA
42a 42 a
22-a is limited to use by
municipalities that is a fairly new
provision of law I believe it is less
than 10 10 years old originally you
would have still been required to get a
wetland permit under 42 A3 as excavation
removal and we would have simply put
this under the normal Grant and right
position Provisions for excavation of
materials which is RSA 482 a21 and
22 um and the reason for for this there
is a couple of things here that why that
fits into that provision under A3 in the
permit process Dees is going to look at
the environmental impacts and decide if
the environmental impacts are such that
it should or should not be allowed if
Dees determines that the impacts are not
significant so significant as there is
some reason this should not be allowed
then it's a transfer of property and I
believe there are several members here
who have brought that up there are two
different resource types that have been
discussed today
if something is on the bed of a stream
or a river that is not the public trust
stream or river bed unless it is title
is owned by the ab budding land
owners the landowners of the adjacent
Properties or whoever owns that riverbed
that's theirs we could not give it away
to someone else you would need to have
the land owner's
permission also when you're looking at
streams and rivers it's been mentioned
that this is habitat I'm going to take a
slightly different approach on this if
pile of logs has been in that River
since 1930s or 40s or even earlier in
the early 1800s if the log jams go back
that far they're embedded and that River
has reached a static equilibrium and
stable um level of stability with that
material anchoring in its sides and its
bed if you're going to go in and remove
that material you run the risk of
destabilizing channels so I can assure
you that part of the review process for
removal of that material under wetland
is going to be Channel stability the
Army Core will require a hydraulic study
to determine how many logs how deep they
go what's the flow characteristics
because with the way the weather
patterns have been going these days and
what we've been paying for in our
Calbert and Bridge Replacements and
other Associated roadway damage one of
the things we are definitely going to
key on is anything that destabilizes a
river channel is not likely to get
approval so you've got a private
ownership issue and a public safety
issue associated with strip rivers and
streams that we would look at under rsa4
2A for this
process if it's a Laker Pond greater
than 10 acres in size now you're part of
the public trust anything on the bed of
that Laker Pond is generally considered
to be property of the people of the
State of New Hampshire which is why it
must go through governor and executive
counsel for the transfer of that
property it is a type of Grant of right
or Grant in right never know if I'm
supposed to say of in we have attorneys
for that but it is a transfer of
property current currently Dees does not
set price for these things that is not
our position um it is not within our
purview to determine what the transfer
value the value of the transfer of goods
would be we would leave that to the
executive counsil and the governor's
office the other uh one other thing I
want to add to this though is I said
normally this would be property of the
State of New Hampshire in Mr Irving's
package he had some information that I
had not seen before out of the national
Arch
um I would suggest reading through his
package it states that these logs were
purchased by the federal government in
19 uh in a program that ran through
1943 one of the biggest issue is who
owns these if in fact they belong to us
as people of the State of New Hampshire
and we chose to allow them to be
recovered and Governor executive Council
chose what an appropriate recovery cost
for those of what the state's um
monetary price on that would be
that would be fine I don't know how the
federal government would feel about it
if in fact they purchased those logs and
we chose to give them to someone else
and take a cut so those are the
ownership issues there are ownership and
stability issues that are actually the
chief determinants of why this is
currently in Wetland St statute and it's
in two different places one
environmental one ownership and property
rights um again if you chose to the
legislature based on my background and
what I've had to research late on other
aspects of transfer of property and
public Waters and public trust the
legislature could Empower and could set
a price scale if it chose to way as
everybody else has said today way above
my pay grade but it is a transfer of
property is it a transfer of New
Hampshire's property Federal property or
in a river private
property and then stability issues and I
I won't reiterate all the other habitat
issues that folks have have mentioned so
that's it in a nutshell it's a redundant
process and there are some legal
ramifications uh could you Empower an
individual to do it yes it was given to
municipalities because at the time 10 12
years ago people figured well towns do
intent to cut maybe we'll kind of
consider this as part of the intent to
cut push it off that way beyond that I
can take any questions and hopefully
provide meaningful answers or at least
write them down and get back to you at
another
time
any questions from uh representative
post and anyone
else get in line so thank you Mr post um
excuse me um I just forgot my question
sorry all right I'll come back to get in
get in line oh now you're me all right
did you say whether you opposed it or
not the state is in opposition to this
bu okay thank you that was
my any other questions by members of the
committee I have H one or two uh thank
you for taking my question uh are you at
all familiar with uh what Michigan is
doing or some of the other states and
why there why they
are allowing this in a
fairly larger I have I have done some
research on what the state of Michigan
is doing I've done some research on
other types of projects or other types
of activities in in Oregon and there's a
couple of different reasons one is when
our logging may have started versus when
their logging Industries may have
started another is the the way the state
is formed New Hampshire as one of the
oldest first King's Grand States you
know the transfer of property we have
because of what king common law was
after in the way sovereignty was taken
After the revolution Our Lake beds are
public trust other states so for
instance if you came as part of the
Louisiana Purchase it depends on the
original when that land was purchased
what were the water rights granted as
part of that in Oregon by the time
you're getting all the way to the West
Coast what were the federal laws that
were in place when you know with the
Homestead Act or whatever act covered
The Taking of the land of Oregon and
turning it into a state and partitioning
it out how you run your state program
and the transfer of property on the beds
of lakes ponds or Rivers is completely
dependent upon how your state was formed
as it was added to the union or as it
was purchased and and became part of
what is now the union so Oregon was flat
out P purchased in Oregon they hold
ownership of the bed of rivers and
streams where we do not unless their
title so you've got that underlying
formation what your formation statutes
are and then the other thing is water is
by biologies are different from from
place to place in New England we are
blessed with having cold water which is
mostly
oligotrophic um and you can see a great
distance of depth may it stay cold for a
long long time because that's what gives
us our Clarity our lack of nutrients our
concerns for what we do in cold water in
New Hampshire are going to be different
and the reactivity of the way the
environment responds to activities is
going to be different than what happens
in Virginia or
Florida so you've got different
environmental concern concerns because
of a different environmental temperature
nutrients underlying soils
characteristics as well as the legal
basis for how things got to where they
are and how many years of industrialized
history may have been contributing
materials any any other
questions there being none thank you
very much my number is on the letter if
anybody has anything in followup please
let us know
Mr Irving you wish to speak a second
time uh I'll allow it make it quick um I
just wanted to follow up real quick on
two things um first I couldn't agree
more with de's perspective that this
would be a redundant process and I don't
want that I know how hard they work and
I don't want to make any more work for
them it's not my intention it would be
nice to find a way to make this happen
um that wouldn't necessarily create a
whole another branch of Permitting and
all that I also wanted to agree with
what the representative from fishing
game said uh I actually sit on the B up
County of conservation districts I'm
also on the board of the walki WAN
Watershed advisory committe so water
quality is absolutely important and I'm
not advocating that Joe public has cart
blanch on taking any type of wood out of
any type of water body the bccd actually
works with trout unlimited to do in
stream restoration work where we are
paying through grants and matching funds
to drop trees into the lake into the
rivers rather so if you read that
introductory letter that I submitted and
look at the picture from the anders
scogan I totally appreciate that there
are certain types of wood that ought to
remain and trying to remove would be
detrimental not only to the habitat not
only to the bank stabilization but
everything however there are some types
of wood like the ones on the bottom of
walki Wan which I think the benefits
outweigh the costs um just because it's
a really great resource and I do not
think and that obviously would depend on
some studies I suppose but I don't think
the value is is should be should rule
out recovery of those logs whereas
instream restoration or instream Timbers
do provide a really really important
resource so I couldn't agree with with
them more um on those points but I think
there is still room to make something
happen in certain cases so that's
it thank you thank you very
much any questions uh oh F before you go
any questions by any member of the
committee seeing none and having no
additional
cards in front of me I
[Music]
will I will adjourn the hearing
on what is this one 14
51 thank you and I will open the hearing
now on House Bill
1066 1066 what happened in
1066 Battle of
Hastings there you go
that's right all
right
okay what uh what are you
submitting is
just was that Amendment okay it's the
amendment I spoke to you about last we
all right representative uh Rose Mary
rung Okay
so
let him finish passing it out
and I get one get any up
here you know you're gonna lose your
job I'll also make sure you get it
electronically
thank thank you thank you thank you
representative representative rung the
floor is yours thank you um good
afternoon uh resources Recreation and
development committee and thank you for
this opportunity to bring forth House
Bill 1066 for your
consideration uh this bill is to
establish a commission to investigate
and analyze the environmental human and
animal health impacts related to
cyanobacteria blooms in New Hampshire
water bodies it would be the first time
experts representing
nhdes HHS Environmental Conservation
groups veterinarians universities and
policy makers come together to address
cyano bacteria in New Hampshire and
recommend ways to mitigate its threat as
background cyanobacteria which uh were
Formerly Known as Blu green algae in
some ways they they are in some in some
groups are microscopic organisms found
naturally in all types of water in warm
nutrient Rich environments cyanobacteria
can multiply quickly creating blooms
that spread across the water's surface a
bloom of harmful cyanobacteria has
several negative effects it can block
sunlight oxygen and or nutrients that
other organisms
need to live and by releasing toxins
known as
cyanotoxins cyanotoxins are among the
most powerful natural poisons known to
man and have caused neurological liver
and skin damage and even death as we
have seen firsthand in New Hampshire
exposure to cyanotoxins have sickened
people and pets and other
animals the occurrence of tox xic blooms
is increasing every year both in New
Hampshire and around the world presently
New Hampshire does not have an effective
way to identify and confirm all blooms
in our lakes and rivers and there is no
efficient way of communicating risk to
the public although an understanding of
conditions which contribute to blooms
namely runoff erosion malfunctioning
septic systems and warming water
temperatures are well known we as a
state do not have a strategy to develop
and
Implement management plans for
mitigation this is why convening a study
commission to comprehensively examine
this issue is needed not just to protect
public health and our natural resources
but to protect our economy over 17
billion of value is brought to New
Hampshire from Lake wabaki alone we have
leared learned that allowing cyano
bacteria blooms to become a chronic
occurrence makes them more difficult to
overcome and raises the risk of serious
disease for people living near impacted
Lakes I am also submitting which was
distributed Amendment 2022
29h which adds a representative to the
commission from the New Hampshire Rivers
Council as New Hampshire rivers are also
suffering from cyanobacteria blooms so I
want to thank you for your attention and
I um would would be happy to answer any
questions you may
have I should also say one other thing I
did get a request today from The Nature
Conservancy to have them added on to
this bill um I I really haven't uh
thought about that too much I may just
leave it up to the committee to uh to
explore and and make a decision
upon
Sor me any
questions representative Smith thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
rung for introducing this bill and for
being here today um you know I am the
chair of the Exotic Aquatic weeds and
species committee and and the question
has been asked of me and I believe I
asked you also months ago could this
could this commission be made rolled
into the uh weeds and species committee
The Aquatic weeds and species
committee um I I don't really believe so
um and for several reasons um aquatic
weeds can be transferred from Lake to
Lake they can be carried through boats
or other vehicles that can contaminate a
lake cyano bacteria are actually
inherent to a lake they're found
naturally um and many of the uh uh
considerations or the elements that
contribute to blooms don't have any
commonality with exotic blooms I mean
with exotic species of plants and
animals um I also think too that the the
health implications of cyano bacteria
make it something that we should examine
specifically
um you probably got a letter from Dr
Elijah STL he's a neurologist and a
professor at the geil school of medicine
at Dartmouth his he's one of the leading
researchers on the link between
cyanobacteria and
ALS and um there some of the research
even suggests that residents that live
even greater than 8 kilometers away from
an impacted Lake could be at a higher
risk of ALS so I think because of the
very serious health impacts of
cyanobacteria the fact that they aren't
um inherently they don't inherently
infect go infect from one body of water
to another means that we should really
focus uh specifically just on cyano
bacteria thank you thank
you any other questions from
Members representative
mville thank you Mr Sharon thank you
representative
I understand the mitigation efforts that
can be used to combat sayano bacteria so
and I'm wondering maybe someone else
will speak to this are there
remediation um solutions to combat this
yes for very chronic lakes that have
suffered years and years um there are a
couple two primary ways of remediating
it and one is to add copper sulfate to
the lake and the other is um um um it's
a it's an Alum type thing they're both
extremely expensive they're not
permanent and then you're also adding a
chemical to a lake um the best and the
reason for this commission is because I
don't have the answers but um in in in
my experience in working on this issue
it's much more successful to um instead
of remediation is to Med mitigate so
ident identify what are the uh inputs
into the lake that are causing these
blooms now granted we can't do anything
about Rising water temperatures but we
can um mitigate the uh runoff and
erosion failing septic systems things
that maybe 20 or 30 years ago wouldn't
have triggered a bloom but because of
increased water temperatures now they're
they play much a much greater role so
how do we do that um you know several
lakes in New Hampshire that have
suffered chronic blooms um and I'm
thinking of Moma Lake which is the one
that triggered the research on Al also
Mary meeting Lake and then the lake
where I spend my summmer Lake kisaka
we've taken upon ourselves to fund and
manage watershed management plan
developments and that's been very
helpful to these communities um it's
been able for them to identify that
those high impact projects they can do
that would prevent phosphorus which
which is a leading contributor to
cyanobacteria growth being able to
prevent them that from going into the
water um and so and and the other thing
too is um is is public awareness um
there is no way that in New Hampshire we
really can proactively inform people
that there is a bloom going on and that
it could cause illness or death um DS
has done a wonderful job we had a
wonderful program director for harmful
alil program she recently left to join
the faculty at UNH um she was one person
I think she had a couple interns working
with her they would if they were aware
of a suspected Bloom they would they
would test sample and test and post it
to their website but it's information
that doesn't Reach people who might be
summering at the lake um there if it was
a public beach there could be some post
posting but I think one of the roles I'm
looking for this commission is to how do
we communicate risk to those people who
are at high risk because right now there
is no effective
way any other questions by members of
the
committee all
right I have a question I have you know
you know I have
questions and
as I as I read the
bill uh I think I obviously I say I know
bacteria blooms are a problem but much
of the as I read the bill much of the
things that you're asking the commission
to do are things
that a dozen people around the table
once a month can't get done uh you need
to have that should be things that
should be done in
the in the uh in the
department in other words find
out basically obtain information
necessary to Del to delineate the extent
of the cyano bacteria blooms commission
can't do that the department should be
doing that uh if
that's those are my concerns that we may
end up if we end up with a commission
all they will be doing is telling us
what we already know and not have
activities action action items that's my
biggest
concern I respect that thank you very
much representative vulo but this is an
issue Caceria is such a serious issue
and it's it takes a lot of all the
stakeholder groups to participate for
instance um yes de s could expand what
they're doing in harmful alil but
Veterinary Society needs to be part of
this and they're very eager to be a part
of this because they see a lot of
animals who are suffering from uh
cyanotoxin Health and Human Services I
mean education on
Physicians um uh I mean I didn't even
know until I got a call from the
director of the New Hampshire Rivers
Council that we were even seeing this in
in rivers and as we heard the testimony
of the previous speaker some Brooks or
small water bodies may be on private
land that would be beyond the regulatory
authority of Dees so I I understand your
concern but I think um this is so
critical that it's important to get as
many key stakeholders at the table as
possible um many of you know that I
chair the pasas commission which was an
a following HB 737 in
2019 we've done tremendous work and we
have broad representation from we have
UNH Dees
DHHS uh the
USGS um and it really adds to the work
we've been able to do and the progress
we've been able to make on that
commission and to be actually with this
bill I pretty much copy and pasted some
of the wording from HB 737 because that
commission has been working so
well thank you any other questions by
members represent representative post
thank you very much for taking my
question um in in this document um from
the doctor at Dartmouth um he says
compelling scientific evidence that many
of the toxins produced by S I can't say
it that's okay can lead to human disease
like cancer but are there any actual um
studies confirming this I mean I know
that's a statement but I would like to
see what's supporting that there's a lot
of peer-reviewed research that's been
published the link between cyanobacteria
toxins and ALS was first discovered I
think in the late 40s early 50s by the
New Hampshire Department of Defense they
had gone into Guam to settle Guam and
noticed an extremely high incidence of
ALS and and tracked back to um an amino
acid type molecule that was found
naturally in some of the vegetation
there
and that got the research going um but
saying it's been
proven to cause I think there's so many
other factors I think if we look just in
New Hampshire at what's going on in
Enfield New New Hampshire that was that
triggered a lot of research the high
incidents of ALS um near Moma Lake which
was suffering chronic cyano bacteria
blooms um there there is a linkage
there's a lot of research out there in
peerreview
journals um but um I think it's fair to
say that cyanobacteria poses a high risk
of someone Contracting ALS whether they
get it or not is is another
story well follow up would would you
have any of that information you could
send to us yes I would thank
you any other
questions
thank you very much thank you very
much chair calls David
Neils the depart Hampshire de for
now uh good afternoon members of the
committee
uh chair Ren Zulo thank you for allowing
me for the opportunity to testify this
afternoon my name is David Neils I'm the
uh Chief aquatic biologist at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services I also oversee the jod Connor
luminology Center and we are basically
charged with monitoring our surface
waters within the work that I do is the
uh sinob bacteria harmful alab boom
position that uh representative run
talked about um I I want to also uh
thank representative Brown for giving a
nice overview of Sino bacteria she could
probably do part of my job she did a
great job talking about CYO bacteria so
I'm going to skip over sort of some of
the background stuff that she spoke
about and give you guys um an overview
of what we deal with on a regular basis
at the Department of Environmental
Services reg uh relative to cob
bacteria over the past several years uh
we have monitored Soo bacteria and on
average we have reports of about 30
water bodies a year that experience CYO
bacteria blooms that continues to grow
every year it's hard to say whether
those upward Trends are because more
people are looking or it's getting worse
I think it's a combination of both we
also issue advisories based on the how
severe the CYO bacteria blooms are and
those advisories go out on a public
website that people can view on average
average we have about 6 to 800 days
collectively in a given year where
recreational opportunities are
prohibited or advised against on those
water bodies where CYO bacteria blooms
occur so is very prevalent and we have
um a lot of work that goes on throughout
the summer I will also say that through
that process we do microscopic
examinations that's how we determine how
bad a bloom is
and last year uh we did about a thousand
samples so that number that workload
continues to go up every year and again
we're not sure whether that's because
things are getting worse or more people
are looking but the need for that type
of work continues to increase
yearly the person that oversaw the
program our CYO bacteria program that
has uh since departed and goed and gone
to un age um she was excellent but she
used to carry a cell phone around with
her every day and on average that phone
would ring with about 20 calls a day
with people reporting sound of bacteria
wounds she was the only person that
managed that program with a couple of
interns of course she had assistance
from her other staff in the biology
group but she was really really overrun
with managing both the sample Lo the
microscopic examinations and answering
the phone calls and that's really the
critical part that we struggle with the
department so needless to say there's
there's a a lot of work to be done and a
lot a lot of work that we do do at the
department
now I won't go into the health risks
other than to say that besides ALS not
that that's not an important
consideration there are many
acute uh factors that can uh occur from
C bacteria and that can be simply
gastroenteritis and there are hundreds
and hundreds of reports out there that
report about the uh acute effects of
Sino bacteria they also can um manifest
themselves through inhalation and
respiratory illnesses so it might seem
like somebody has a cough or a cold um
that can be from inhalation the other
thing is there can be very acute inci is
where nerve damage is done from certain
toxins and this has been reported Across
the Nation and even New Hampshire where
pets die very quickly so it it can be
very severe beyond the long-term effects
not to minimize the long-term
effects the other thing I wanted to
bring up is the impact on public water
supplies and that's really important I
think to point out is cyanotoxins are
not just impactful for recreation but
they can have a severe impact if a
public water supply were to experience a
bloom we're very lucky in the state of
New Hampshire we haven't had a severe
impact on our public water supply but if
you've read some of the national news
over the last five or 10 years you could
probably see the impact that Lake G had
on a public water supply which blooms
every year and um and several large
communities were impacted by the uh
inability to use water from Lake yie
because it was toxic
our two State uh largest state water
suppliers the Manchester Waterworks and
Tenchu Waterworks they do actively
engage in cob bacteria monitoring and
they're fortunate in that their water
supplies have not been impacted but as
you probably know there's a lot of other
smaller Public Water Supplies around the
state that just don't have that
capacity So based on our
experience we know that there's several
Lakes every year that we can count on
blooming and these are are really
problematic because we have challenges
right now diagnosing and correcting
those problems and I think the cob
bacteria commission if it were to move
forward be helpful in that we also have
new Lakes every year that show up and
those are surprising to those folks that
like to recreate or have a home on that
Lake also they could occur on Public
Water Supplies as I mentioned so those
are some of the challenges that we know
about in both cases we know there's way
to to fix these problems but we really
have a hard time
finding uh resources to complete those
fixes and identifying what the best fix
is today as I mentioned we're lucky that
we haven't had a severe Bloom on P of
Water Supplies but they have been noted
in small scales and they do
occur we also like to point out that our
Bloom tracking system that we have and
notification system system that we have
at the state does get a lot of use in
fact it's one of the most popular I say
popular but most frequently visited
websites that we have it's a map that
people can click on like Google Maps and
it'll tell you which water bodies are
impacted by a cal bacteria wounds we
also have a just a general listing as
well we also realize that this is
probably not the best system it works
well but that can be improved upon and
it is timec consuming for our staff to
to update on a daily basis we really
think this commission this department
does will help us better understand the
causes of CYO bacteria Blooms of course
as scientists we kind of know some of
these things but they're different on
each individual water
body we also help we also know that um
the commission will be helpful in
getting input from others on the
preferred options for cyano uh bacteria
tracking notification and
Reporting we also think it would be
helpful to recommend the preferred
options for public education and
awareness and we'd also like to explore
the opportunity to enhance public water
system monitoring and tracking we think
that's really critical to protect the
public health and last lastly we'd like
to explore the best opportunities and
ways which we can tackle um options to
reduce the causes of cob bacteria blooms
and the risk of these occurring in our
water bodies if P the agency looks
forward to participating on the
commission and understanding what our
capacity is for mitigating the impacts
of CYO bacteria on our state surface
waters so with that I'm happy to take
any questions that you may
have thank you I have a I have a
question it sounds like you're you're
you're the fireman putting out the fires
constantly and
thank you for that but is there someone
who is out there trying to figure out
what the fire is and what how to how to
put that put all the uh how to stop the
arsonist from doing all of the
fires I mean who who in the
department does that job so like I said
I'm the chief aquatic biologist I have a
staff of about 10 people most of the
people are biologists and we're all
charged with monitoring our state's
surface waters we have several people
that work for me that do specialize in
Lake ecology and together we work on
figuring
out uh ways to deal with Lakes we don't
outside of the one position we have for
tracking CYO bacteria we don't have a
specific sort of position designated to
identify the causes of problems if
you're asking me who the arsonists are
collectively we all the arsonists and
historically all the people before us
that used our
Lakes
okay
questions representative post thank you
um so earlier um the speaker talked
about um in Guam it was naturally
occurring there could that be our issue
here or have you looked at it from a
Global
Perspective um could you give us some
information on that sure absolutely um
as representative rung noted CYO
bacteria are natural component of all of
our water bodies they're a part of the
natural pled Community the issue that
we've seen is that they become dominant
when excessive nutrients become
available for their production we also
know that increases in
temperature and uh nutrient inputs from
external sources and ex and internal
sources can greatly impact the
likelihood that cob bacteria can bloom
so it is an issue that's being dealt
with Worldwide it's not unique to New
Hampshire it's not unique to New
England but it is a prevalent
um and I I would say relatively new
occurrence although that they've been
part of our uh aquatic communities for a
long time and and looking back in in
some of the records we have we have
records of blooms on New Hampshire Lakes
going way back to the 50s it's the
prevalence of those blooms and the
understanding of what those CYO bacteria
how they can impact our human health is
what's really leading to the increase
awareness and need to do something about
that um also I I think in the past we've
talked about it being caused potentially
from putting
um growth products on our Lawns and to
keep them looking beautiful and things
like that are they still thinking that
is the cause that's going into our water
systems and then getting passed down
through the aquifer is that there are a
number of factors that can um promote
zobac Bloom certainly fertilizers can be
one of them I will not that I think it
was back in the 80s that uh phosphorus
was banned from most fertilizers they're
still allowed to be used in starter
fertilizers so um that is one of the
limiting nutrients in our Lakes the
unique thing about
cyanobacteria is they may be able to to
to take advantage of excess nitrogen
amounts and when you put fertilizer on
your lawn it is loaded with nitrogen so
and that and that's of course why we
have um the Shoreland protection act
which restricts the amount of fertilizer
you can put so that's one of the factors
among many
yes representative
Huff thank you Mr chair thank you for uh
coming and and testifying I just want
to what I'm hearing and what I'm I just
want to make sure is basically there's a
lot of possible causes um from runoff
from nutrients um from Lake Heating from
uh septic systems all of these things in
in in uh
conjunction and I'm what I'm think I'm
hearing is is we just don't know those
are posses but we don't actually know
and that's the purpose of this is that
am I correct in that
assumption I think the purpose as I
understand the purpose of the Comm is is
multifaceted that would be one of the of
the uh components to explore yes thank
you anyone else for
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you
chair calls Michelle
Davis from New Hampshire
Lakes uh thank you chair and Zulo
members of the committee my name is
Michelle Davis I'm the policy and
advocacy program manager at New
Hampshire lak
and thank you for giving me the
opportunity to testify in support of
House Bill 1066 which would give which
would create a cob bacteria study
commission um I've included and passed
out a letter of testimony in support of
the bill which has been signed by eight
other environmental organizations New
Hampshire Rivers Council The Nature
Conservancy marac River Watershed
Council the New Hampshire Association of
conservation commissions the wesam
Watershed Network Green Mountain
conservation group and kisaka water
Association and save Lake sopy Watershed
these organizations represent thousands
of Granite State residents and visitors
who are dedicated to keeping New
Hampshire's lakes and rivers clean and
healthy um I won't tell you what you
already know but our Lakes are sick in
2021 there's a record number of toxic
cyanobacteria blooms in lakes and rivers
Statewide and we know what the causes of
cyanobacteria blooms are as noted
increased nutrients including phosphorus
from sources such as fertilizer septic
system waste soil being washed into our
Lakes we know the effects of cyano
bacteria blooms and that they're not a
threat to the use and enjoyment of our
lakes and rivers but they have the
potential for far-reaching and long-term
consequences to human and animal health
uh notably New Hampshire's tourism
economy and lakefront property values
are also at risk as people are less and
less likely to visit and buy property on
toxic water
bodies what we don't know and what the
study Commission has the opportunity to
investigate is exactly how to address
the Gap in current state laws and
programs to come up with Cutting Edge
Solutions including legislation to begin
combating cyano bacteria's impact on New
Hampshire this issue can't be siloed
into one state agency or program alone
it's multifaceted
interdisciplinary problem that cuts
across many sectors of society and state
government so without bringing this
commission together it's unlikely that
this issue can be addressed by one
agency or governing body it's time to
bring a diverse group of stakeholders to
the table to address this issue
comprehensively and begin mitigating its
threat thank
you any questions by members of the
committee representative Smith thank you
Mr chair and thank you Miss Davis for uh
taking my question um since you are uh
with New Hampshire lakes and you you
know interact with a lot of people or
you hear from a lot of people when you
have the lake host program or uh
Adventures out on the lake with as a
community um are you hearing reports
from people about cyano bacteria people
who've been out boating or swimming or
recreating on the Lakes absolutely um we
hear uh consistently throughout the
summer people's concerns over
cyanobacteria blooms um we're hearing
stories about people who are uh
contemplating selling their lake houses
and moving to lakes that are uh less
affected by Cal bacteria blooms um we're
hearing about people who are choosing
not to recreate in their Lakes for most
of the you know the hot summer months of
July and August and September because
they just don't want to take the risk
we've heard of people whose you know
college age and adult children are not
choosing to come back to the lake that
they grew up on um for the same reasons
and and not bringing to the lake with
them for those reasons um or their or
their you know or grandchildren so it's
it's becoming um more and more obvious
that the problem is growing and that
people are aware of the issue and and
making their choices about how to recre
and how to use the lake
accordingly thank
you representative post for a question
thank you Mr chair do you have any
programs um for around the lakes and
things where you promote um healthy
behaviors for treating the lakes and are
there any um uh private homeowners
businesses cooperatives to get the news
out maybe um at marinas and things like
that where people would go to rent a
boat and say you know these are the
things that you need to um not put in
maybe use certain detergents things like
that for people who are renting homes on
the lake I mean has there been anything
like that to to get a public um you know
campaign going to try to prevent
that yeah New Hampshire Lakes uh runs a
program called Lakes smart um and there
are several other Lake Associations
around the state who run similar
programs um the Lakes smart program is a
voluntary non-regulatory program where
homeowners take self assessments of
their property and that is in everything
including you know what kind of
detergents and home cleaning products
they're using to their septic systems to
drip lines around their roofs uh
fertilizer use Woodland buffers natural
plantings in their in their yards the
reduction of salt use in their driveways
and and reduction of of open lawn
areas um and then
after the self assessment New Hampshire
Lake staff or other Lake Association
staff will go out and visit the
properties um confirm sort of some of
the that self assessment and then give
them the opportunity to improve um their
their choices on how they're using and
managing their properties um and then if
the property meets certain criteria they
will be uh awarded a lak smart award um
which we're really proud of of and um a
lot of homeowners are really proud to
display that um the program is growing
but it's still um you know boots on the
ground effort we also um partner with uh
local businesses so we have um a Lakes
smart service provider program and those
businesses are everything from Realtors
to landscapers to snow removal
professionals um that partner with us
and those are all uh businesses that are
committed to um to maintaining Lake
friendly practices in their in their
business
day-to-day have you seen um any
improvements since starting this program
and how long has the program um been
going the program's been going uh for a
few years and I I don't necessarily have
an answer as far as improvements go I
know a lot of people that have not
received a Lakes smart award have gone
back into their property and done some
of those those recommended changes in
order to receive that Lake smart award
and I think that that's a really
wonderful um thing that people are doing
I think in order to really see clear
improvements related from uh the Lakes
smart program to um to impacts on cyano
bacteria it has to be a whole Watershed
or whole lake um effort uh you know one
person updating their septic system are
not using fertilizer isn't going to
solve the problem of cob bacteria blooms
on an entire Lake um but these these
individuals taking these steps you know
incrementally will make a difference
over
time one more followup
please is there anyone um keeping
records of this program starting and the
followup what's happening in the the
lake areas that that people are
participating in and if not um I think
it would be a great idea that would help
every everyone understand if these
things are actually making a
difference are you are you asking if we
have records of the Lakes smart visits
that we've done are you are you keeping
track this year um so many people
participated and we didn't have as many
blooms this year or you know someone
keeping track over the years of of the
program increasing in participation if
that makes any kind of difference um I
know that we have lak stats that I can
certainly send to the committee based on
how many visits we've done and and where
they've they've been done and I can
certainly forward that along to you I
don't know that we have statistics on a
any correlation between blooms and and
lakes smart visits and I think it's hard
to make those those connections
necessarily because you know if you have
a particularly hot dry summer you might
see more blooms or if you have a hot dry
spell and then a major rain event that's
a trigger to a bloom and so com Cor
ating Lakes smart visits solely with
with CYO bacteria blooms I don't think
it's it's necessarily um an a parallel
um so I think there's a lot of factors
that go into um the occurrence of the
blooms can I ask one more
question thank you very much I
appreciate your indulging me
um have you thought about participation
with someone like UNH and things like
that to do long-term
studies um I I don't I don't have I
don't know the answer to that and I can
certainly follow up with you on that I
think that would be a good idea I mean
especially there's so many Lake
Associations in New Hampshire you got
these people together I think that um it
could make a huge difference and even if
you had homeowners you know keep track
of things by their section because
sometimes I know blooms happen in
representative you're test you're
testifying now I am I'm sorry thank you
very much thank
you anyone else for questions if not
thank you very much thank
you
and and final person is David uh Packard
from the New Hampshire Rivers Council
push the button
um thank you very much Mr chairman uh
this is the first time I've ever spoken
at a legislative committee so forgive me
if I don't quickly fall into your
protocol but I'll I'll do what I
can
oh thank you very much for allowing me
to speak uh my name is David Packard I
have lived in gwn near both at bcat
squag River and Glen Lake for over 40
years my wife and I also have a small
cottage on Lower Suncook Lake in
Barnstead I'm speaking today
representing the New Hampshire Rivers
Council board of directors and I thank
Michelle Davis for a very nice lead into
what I intended to say
today I ask this committee to fully
support House Bill 1066 including the
amendment by representative rung to add
New Hampshire Rivers Council as a member
of the study
committee although cyano bacteria are
naturally occurring in our States lakes
ponds rivers and streams when conditions
become favorable through high water
temperatures and particularly with
nutrients are present blooms can happen
anywhere because of our common concerns
New Hampshire Rivers Council has
co-signed the letter presented by New
Hampshire Lakes I have firsthand
experience with a significant bloom last
summer on June 8th a suspected
cyanobacteria Bloom adjacent to my beach
on Lower Suncook Lake was reported to
Suncook Lakes Association which reported
to New Hampshire Lakes which then
contacted Dees Dees investigated and
confirmed the
bloom we have never had a bloom on Lower
Sun L either before or
after as it turns out a neighbor on the
waterfront applied fertilizer to his
entire site including within the 25 foot
boundary right along the lake and along
the entire stream that runs through his
property this was done about a week
before the bloom occurred uh and it we
had significant rains after the
fertilizer was laid
down as I said this is very distressing
to the people on Lower sunkook Lake who
have never experienced a BL before now
other neighbors have concerns over
potential impacts to the lake water
quality resulting from such activities
that are already strictly forbidden
under the Shoreland water quality
protection act my wife and I so enjoyed
the lake we bought the cottage not for
ourselves but for the enjoyment of our
family and our
grandkids we love teaching our kids
about the environment our Our Lake and
the sun crook River Birds notably the
Eagles and the loons the various fish
species Turtles and especially the
Chipmunks that the kids feed by
hand over the years our dogs have been
in and out of the lake and we literally
can't keep our grandkids out of the
water safety is always our top concern
for
them this is just one instance of a
bloom that isn't supposed to happen the
bill clearly outlines the importance of
controlling the factors that lead to
blooms and management of blooms once
they do occur all of us here must be
concerned about water quality and safety
I again ask that you support the
formation of the study committee and the
issuance of a final report as quickly as
possible five years just seems to be way
too long for studying uh the situation
leading to
legislation and I'll be happy to answer
any
questions any questions by any member of
the
committee seeing
none thank you very much your
time
that's the all of the remaining cards I
did have one question of the uh uh of
the representative representative rung
say the presenter uh yes Mr uh I think
u in the bill there's it talks about
having the harmful algae cyanobacterial
bloom program coordin from the
Department of Environmental Research
Services or design is there that that
person exist now uh that position's open
the person who held it um was the one
that took a position with UNH okay on
their faculty I would anticipate DS
would either fill that position or
assign a designate okay and also an
invironmental engineer specializing in
watershed management planning is that
someone from the
outside just yeah yes mainly um Lake
Associations who've experienced blooms
particularly when they've been Chon
become chronic uh typically raise money
to fund watershed management plan
developments and uh there are many
contractors Consultants throughout New
England throughout the country that do
this kind of work to identify sources of
uh runoff or nut actually what I was
aiming at is does this require
additional Personnel no there's people
out there that was my aim maybe I wasn't
okay
okay representative Smith you had a
question well yes I do thank you very
much and thank you again representative
R um the as as represent as Mr chair
said an environmental engineer
um do you have any thoughts on who that
person would be appointed by um um
because that should probably be in the
bill no I really haven't um I think in
the bill is it stated that it would be
nominated by the Senators okay I'll I'll
um I'll revisit that and the other
question I have is do you really think
we'll get two senators who will attend
these
meetings yeah I I don't know I mean it's
always a problem with senators and
usually when the bill goes to the Senate
they take off one of the Senators too
yeah you know I'll defer to the uh but
but I do know you know going back to my
experience on the Pas commission uh
Senator Senators Daniels and Carson make
most of the meetings and um and they
definitely have a vested interest
because of that groundwater
contamination affects their
communities and I mean just anecdotally
from my involvement in this issue is
there are people that are really they're
frightened they're scared they want the
state to do something I think they would
ensure that their Senator would
participate but I would leave if if the
the committee doesn't believe that um
the Senate that position would be able
to be honored on that I would be open to
an amendment to reduce it to maybe one
Senate but I I do expect the reason that
the Senate representatives are on the
commission is that there's likely going
to be budgeting issues there's likely
going to be some policy recommendations
that may require a legis lative remedy
and so to have that buyin from both uh
you know the the house and the Senate I
think are going to be important for any
legislation that moves
forward quick
followup which brings me to five State
reps which you know it is so challenging
to find state reps who will attend
commission and committee hearings um of
statutory commissions so just consider
if we could do with less of those also I
mean we can do whatever we want now that
we have the bill but I just wanted to
approach that subject and and I will say
that um the bill as submitted as the LSR
when it went through the process there
was a an error on the part of os um
there were probably eight
Representatives that signed on as
co-sponsors of this bill but the only
one that made it I I noticed this eror
and it was too late to um remediate it
but uh that's why Senator PR and I are
the only ones on the bill but it had
very strong support from Senate from
representatives in The Lakes Region yes
as I was one of them yes okay thank you
okay representative maville thank you Mr
chair um representative R thank you for
taking the question I was wondering I I
was looking at the various um uh duties
of the commission and I was thinking
about stakeholders as just previously
mentioned and I I was just wondering if
because it seems that the source and
impact of the surface water includes
fertilization and includes some of the
land owners that perhaps maybe um a
thought might be to include the
Landscaping Association of New Hampshire
or the New Hampshire realtors
association as just a couple of other
stakeholders that would Encompass that
that bulk of people thank you for that
suggestion I think that's worthwhile
many of them are involved in uh Lake
Associations anyway so there we may get
that involved involvement but I do
appreciate that the challenge with
something like this is like for instance
when I got when I got the email today
from the new from The Nature Conservancy
to add it on we're already I think at 19
members so with the with the New
Hampshire Rivers associ Council so there
is a concern about having it too
unwieldy but um you know and but I do
think it's important to have the the
elected representation I guess it's
there's needs to be a balance to be find
out who can who can participate now I
know New Hampshire Lakes um part of
their programming is they do certify
land landscapers and people that service
waterfront property to make sure that
they have best practices environmental
practices so that may be a channel
through them to get that
representation anyone
else any more questions none okay thank
you very much Mr chairman thank you to
the committee for all your thoughtful
questions I appreciate
it Ru I'll call the uh hearing on
1066 as
adjourned and we will go now
to House
Bill
do you have one of
these
okay did I miss one oh here here it is
okay for pardon representative gutl the
floor is
yours can you hear
me okay all right uh thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record I am Sue goling
representing Su Sullivan County District
2 the towns of snipe and Cen I am here
to introduce a bill to make Perkins pond
in sopi the fourth houseb free body of
water in New
Hampshire one of my first constituent
service requests when I was a relatively
new representative was to help the
Perkins Pond
Association dislodge a long promised
report from the Department of
Environmental
Services the report was needed for the
association to determine the direction
of their long-term efforts to protect
the pond this report the Perkins Pond
diagnostic feasibility study
2009 describes what the future of this
small and extremely shallow Pond could
be as increased development of the
shoreline and the Watershed took place
the Perkins Pond Association decided to
continue their efforts by recommending
replacement of the existing sewage
systems chiefly septic systems but
including cess pools ouses and
latrines they would do this by
advocating for connection to the sunap
sewage treatment facility I am happy to
say that the association's efforts were
successful and all dwellings are now
connected as you hear from a number of
residents from around the pond about the
years of hard work to achieve their goal
of protecting the pond as well as the
cost to the pond home homeowners to
install
their their sewage lines and the sonop
taxpayers who agreed to pay for the
lengthy connection you might understand
the shock when a makeshift houseboat
appeared at a dock occupied by a person
enthusiastically encouraging others via
social media to do the same with all its
implicit threats of
contamination from sewage and Gra water
a floating septic system on Perkins Pond
is truly a bad idea I hope you will
support this
bill any questions from the from the
committee representative
kraton yes ma'am thank you sir I
appreciate your testimony so I'm looking
at the map of Perkins ponds looks like
there's
about 20 or 30 houses around there oh no
or it looks like docs or
something is
that is it 100 yeah um of those
residents how many would agree to this
is there a a poll of how many are are in
favor of this oh you you will hear from
the the folks that are to
T they they have more first hand
information than I
do any any any other
questions from the
representative seeing
n thank you very
[Music]
much uh Captain dun may I see you here
are you here for this bill are you
uh okay because yeah otherwise I said
Gee I didn't expect to have him come all
the way down here just for
this okay thank you very thank
you all right
uh
Robin Saunders wow okay Robin
Saunders thank you of course with a name
like Ren Zulo don't worry about
it I heard Sue refer to the uh the
diagnostic study that was done and I
just brought a copy in case anybody
wanted to look at it but I'm good
afternoon Mr chairman and committee
members and thank you for allowing me
the opportunity to speak today I'm Dr
Robin sers and have been an active
member and vice president of the Perkins
Pond protective Association for over 20
years
Perkins Pond is a 157 acre Shallow Lake
located in the town of snipe in Sullivan
County the pond is only 9 feet
deep rather you look at that than look
at me no that
works um this is an aerial photograph of
the pond showing the approximate
location of where the houseboat was
found and has been there for the last
two
years due to the small size and depth
we're a very fragile body of water but
we like to think of our community as
Tiny But Mighty the Perkins Pond
protective Association has been actively
monitoring Perkins Pond and its
Watershed since 1987 through the New
Hampshire volunteer Lake Assessment
program you probably know them as
VAP we were one of the first Lakes to
participate in the testing program to be
able to monitor small changes and
quickly mitigate when needed
as Perkins Pond resident Attorney
Richard jaffy was the founding Godfather
of the New Hampshire Lakes Association
Lake monitoring was very important to
this little fragile B of body of
water as a community we were concerned
about the health of our water body and
as most of you know there are three
classifications of water body based on
the amount of biological activity that
they sustain the first is oligotrophic
which means you have good water quality
the second is mesotropic which is fair
and the worst is UT you utopic which
means poor water quality in 1986 Perkins
Pond had good water quality and was
classified as oligotrophic but in 2003
it was downgraded to Fair also known as
mesotropic this is a
picture
coincidentally of a cyano factor
outbreak that we had in 2009 and we have
had a number of them
since our small P shallow Pond heats up
very very quickly in the summer and
these outbreaks can very very quickly
appear part of the New Hampshire
volunteer Lake Assessment program is
that we collect to data during the
summer and the summer months that is
reviewed by experts and a report card
table is created for the community now
this is the report card table
for the most recent report card table
for Perkins Pond and this is obviously
available online and you can see that
there are many areas where we keep
struggling if you can see these pictures
or I should pass them around I'm not
sure of the
protocols as an older community we were
concerned that the older cottages and
older septic systems might might be
contributing phosphorus causing exensive
excessive plant growth and algae growth
and the shift in Tropic status in the
1990s more than 20 years ago the Perkins
Pond Community initiated discussions
with the town of cipe to install a sewer
system to present another shift in
trophic status in other words we try to
B limit biological growth that would
result in another
downgrade after four failed votes to
have a sewer bill passed
one by missing one vote we decided to
contact the New Hampshire de in request
a very expensive and timec consuming
diagnostic study of the pond to gather
more information for the next vote and
that's the document that that that
representative goling was talking
about the conclusion of the study
indicated that a sewer system around the
pond would remove septic system
phosphorus and have a significant
benefit in maintaining Lake water
quality over the long
term the Perkins Pond Community spent
over 20 years lobbying for a sewer
system and in 2019 with the help of the
town of cipe and representative goling
we were able to install a a greater than
$3 million sewer system to help mitigate
septic
waste the residents of Perkins pond have
worked tirelessly to keep the pond clean
including investing hundreds of hours
and thousands of dollars to have a sewer
system installed to protect our asset so
you can imagine our horror and surprise
when a makeshift houseboat with five
gallon plastic buckets for waste
collection and Disposal was able to
attach to a dock owned by an outof State
person and stay for two
years ly Arnold one of my colleagues
will speak to you next but do you have
any
questions any questions
questions by members of the
committee seeing none if do we excuse
me Kelly oh I no I thought thought I saw
your hand up if possible I would like to
leave this document with with the chair
with with you Mr chairman in it you will
find um just about 50 letters of support
for the project from the residents of
Perkins Pond as well as um some of the
materials that we we've shown you here
okay we uh we could take them we can
leave them in the office and uh
representative goling will return them
to you okay also in the back of this was
a wonderful article that the eagle times
did on Perkin Pond and this house bill
that was just published
yesterday thank you thank you you
representative goling
you uh
when when she she going to leave those
with the committee uh for short period
of time and we put it in your your uh
your F in your office your little in
your office your drawer your drawer in
your office so and return
them well you're Mo every rep now has
has a it's like a filing
cab that has a fairly large fairly
shallow drawer and that and that's our
office but then again what do you expect
for $100 a year
so thank you thank you all very much
thank you all very much this is very
important to the the the residents of
Perkins Pond you know being only nine
feet deep were we always worry about
contributions of biological waste and
this was this was such a surprise to us
that there wasn't a law in the state of
New Hampshire that would protect
us let's follow with no being no no
additional questions uh we'll we'll move
on Lyn
Arnold the floor is yours thank you uh
good afternoon Mr chairperson and
committee members H thank you for
allowing me to speak today about House
Bill 1220 my name is Lynn Arnold and I
live on Perkins pond in sunap and I'm
here today to ask you to support this
house build we moved here three years
ago from another small Lake in another
small town in Massachusetts where I
chaired the select board I um chaired
the planning board and I actually
started and then shared a lake oversight
committee uh we chose this beautiful
pond in centipede to move to in large
part because of the Town sewers and the
work of the Perkins Pond protective
Association in keeping this Pond clean
having had experience in other ponds
that was something we were looking for
and found here um you can imagine my
surprise on May 19th two years ago when
uh two summers ago actually um when I
saw a large strip down pontoon boat
blocking our boat ramp and then later on
it had moved to a dock of my neighbor
right down the street this boat owner
asked others to use their docks and was
told no so finally the boat owner
convinced an outer State homeowner who
has rental property on our pond to rent
her dock space when the pond boat moved
to its new home the boat owner erected a
tent and that was where she lived that
summer and then again last summer so we
brought you a picture so that you could
see it really is a stripped down pontoon
boat with a tent on it and she lived
there for the summer and then again last
summer the boat is currently parked in
the driveway of the property where she
was docked so we expect this to continue
um new Hampshire Dees Marine Patrol was
called and our Board of Health was
called they visited her and she
explained that she was using two five
gallon pales for her waste in her gray
water and she told them that she would
be dumping these five gallon pales in um
the facilities that were at sunap
Harbor because of covid those facilities
were closed that entire
season yep and so where did all of her
Wastewater go and where did where did
she shower and um what else went in our
pond so um oh also Perkins Pond has no
restroom and it has no dumping
facilities to make matters worse this
Boat Boat owner has an active social
media presence and once she was docked
she advocated for others to bring their
boats to our beautiful pond so just a
few days after that I watched a large
boat with sleeping facilities trying to
launch thankfully they were unable to do
so because uh of the very low water
level at the time at our boat ramp so um
this is actually bigger than the
homeowners of Perkins Pond you're going
to hear from us today but um there is a
state boat launch on the pond which is
used year round by
non-residents these people come they
fish they put in their fishing boats
they kayak they canoe um they bring
their kids to swim there uh this is
their resource also biological waste
contributed by a house boat like this or
any other house boats can as you've
heard in Willl her can cause degradation
of our water quality and harm our pond
so I'm here today to ask you to support
all of us in protecting our vulnerable
resource by voting to pass House Bill
1220 and which would prohibit House Bill
L Perkins
Pond thank
you question by representative KRON uh
thank you Mr chairman ma'am the same
question is before what kind of support
from the community is it 100% is it 84
.3% what of the of the 100 houses around
Perkins Pond how how many have signed up
to this legislation so we have um we're
going to leave that book with you we
have letters from at least 40 of them um
we voted twice what you'll hear um as
the protective Association to um support
this unanimously so I don't have a
percentage for you but
um any other any other
questions
Huff
representative thank you Mr chairman um
I don't know much about this so bear
with me um it sounds to me that you're
not so much opposed to the house booat
as it is dumping waste into into the
pond
so there's nothing anywhere that says
you can't do that I mean I would
think just I'm just asking there there's
no statute there's no you just can't
dump I mean you have to have septic
systems if you live around the lake
because you can't dump it in the lake so
I would assume that that would hold true
in this
no like like I mentioned we have we have
a state boat launch but there are no
restrooms at that launch and there is no
dumping facility anywhere near our
pond thank
you representative
thank you Mr chairman uh so my question
is do we have any sense of why this
resident person on the MAA boat CHS
Perkins Bond um she's familiar with it
because she has relatives who have a
house a home or property I'm not sure
they don't you around property
on thank
you any question by anyone
else not thank you very much Mr chairman
and I have a letter
um uh Richard jaffy who's a member of
the Perkins Pond protective Association
as well as a homeowner uh wanted to be
here today but was unable to come and he
sent a letter um if it's okay with you
could I read it how long is
it I'll allow
it I'll read fast uh dear chair Rulo and
members of the committee let me express
my appreciation for the opportunity to
comment on house House Bill 1220 which
if passed will prohibit the docking of
house boats on Perkins Pond and cipe I
fully support this bill an article in
the Manchester Union leader way back
November 13th of 1979 began as follows a
gathering of persons concerned with the
survival of New Hampshire's Lakes
approved in concept Saturday the
creation of a Statewide organization to
provide cloud in solving Lake management
problems and a ninepoint program to
bring that clout to Bear meeting at the
SOP Junior Senior High School in what
may be the state's first Lakes conf
conference about 75 representatives of
Lake Associations and local planning
boards and conservation commissions
heard presentations from State and
private authorities on Lake management
at the end of that 1979 conference in
sunap the representatives in attendance
unanimously voted to take the first step
in creating what eventually became the
New Hampshire Lakes Association it was
my great honor at the time to have been
elected chair of the conference in its
subsequent steering committee however I
do not write you today on the collective
behalf of all the beautiful bodies of
water that bless our entire state in all
cander I confess I confess that my goal
today is somewhat selfishly to elicit
your support for the reasonable
protection of that one small pond that
my wife and I fell in love with almost
50 years ago I know you have received
materials from my neighbors and others
um other concerned 1220 supporters
regarding the long battle to bring Town
sewers to Perkin Pond the continuing
fragile nature of the pond the absence
of public restrooms and the present
threat posed by house boats on this
small body of water as such I'm going to
limit this letter to reminder in a brief
summary of some Salient facts oh I
didn't know you had two pages well I'm
sorry one and a
half yeah what else um house boats are
currently prohibited on swam Conway and
Silver Lakes um and all of I'll I'll
I'll paraphrase all of those Lakes are
larger and deeper than our pond um the
current trophic C uh classification of
Perkins Pond is mesotrophic and simply
put the pond is officially fragile so I
guess I'm just posing one question is it
not both reasonable and advisable to
extend the same protection to the small
shallow fragile Perkins Pond that is
already afforded the three larger and
deeper bodies of water named above on my
on behalf of my wife and myself and all
our caring neighbors I thank you in
advance for your continued support and
Devotion to all of our treasured lakes
ponds rivers and streams respectfully
jaff thank you
uh chair now calls
Sharon it Mar
Martinez pardon Shannon okay
okay yeah it's Shannon Martinez
representing the town of sonap yes um
good afternoon Mr chairman and committee
members my name is Shannon Martinez and
I am the brand new town manager of centi
New Hampshire it's a great honor to
serve CTI but it's also happen stand I
am a resident of Perkins Pond as you've
heard from my colleagues here the town
of CTI has experienced in increased
growth and construction of properties
during the past two years property
values have increased creating new tax
revenue for our town after having just
gone through the tax rate setting and
the budget I can tell you how important
that revenue is to us and to the
stewards of um the community members of
sen and the impact the negative impact
of these kinds of house boats on Perkins
ponds impacts the dollar value of the
homes um and that as you will know
dramatically impacts our
tax rate um the TA the The increased
values of the property construction and
added tax revenue support our town the
bodies of water within the town of ctie
are some of the most important and
valuable assets that we have the town is
committed to support any and all efforts
to keep these Waters of bodies clean and
safe at the June 14th 20121 Senate Board
of selectman meeting the select board
voted to fully support the Perkins ponds
associ motion to condemn the presence of
house vots and any other watercraft
serving as such from docking acing or
moing on or at said Perkins Pond this
motion was passed unanimously by the
Perkins Pond Association there were over
70 members at that meeting that voted
unanimously as a resident of Perkin Pond
community and a member of the Perkin
Pond protective Association I appreciate
the need to continue to support our pond
thank you for your time and I hope that
you vote to pass this
bill any
questions seeing none thank you very
much oh representative post it is not of
this witness I wondered if we could ask
Captain question you mean Captain D
Captain Eastman wrong wrong
department is there anyone
fromes uh no but Captain Captain done
live he probably can answer the question
what sorry about that he's at the Marine
Patrol thank you very much
representative uh oh do you have a
question for question for this all right
first uh
[Music]
representative I know I'm
new you got to get bigger letters on you
at least I got you know I got the new
guys the new guy card you know thank you
Mr chair for letting me speak to the
witness thank you man for taking my
question congratulations on your
position you're the perfect person I
want to ask this question to um what
type of zoning law
in town have existed or don't exist or
could be enacted to help preclude this
from occurring and therefore not having
to be a legislative issue but a Town
rules issue I feel like you just gave me
the winning lottery ticket to redeem
myself I stumbled a little bit on um the
text here so um we together as a town
have just put into our budget and if it
passes at the March 8th town meeting we
will be hiring a full-time um code
officer and an ordinance officer and
that would afford US the ability to be
able to better monitor not only Perkins
Pond but all of our bodies of water our
Watershed and Rit large um and this is
hugely important not just for Perkins
Pond um but there are a number of other
violations that are happening that are
jeopardizing Lake cenpy and again as I
was just trying to talk about the dollar
values of our homes it if we lose the
lake we lose lose almost everything and
that's the same for Perkins Pond if we
lose Perkins Pond we dramatically lose
um that whole Community um as a tax
contribut so what we are doing is we are
putting in place a structure that would
allow that um I would say that we are
going through a growth process with me
at the helm we do not have as many
strong ordinances as you might imagine a
town like us would have but given that
we have those large bodies of water
however we are seeing an increased
demand for us to have those in place and
there are about 12 different stakeholder
groups aside from the Perkins Pond
Association that are advocating for us
to do the same thing to have this code
officer in place so that we're better
putting in um we're better monitoring
but we also have stricter uh guidance on
the books that would allow us to fortify
how we are uh protecting our bodies of
water all right representative post you
had a question uh or query of Captain
done
one yes um my thought was that the
problem is not really the house boat the
problem is The Dumping of the
sewage is there anything on the books
about people dumping sewage in legs that
could help these
folks could I just say that the
ordinance we do have an ordinance that
would would not actually allow that
because the pond is not zoned for
that living quarters to be there and as
a result it is actually um not in
compliance with the Zord ordinances of
Perkins Pond or like the those specific
residential zones around Perkins pond so
the house boat itself is not in
compliance and our new code officer um a
building inspector would be able to
enforce that um I think this just gives
us more top cover as well as helps us to
put in place stronger um means as we
continue to grow not only send for
Perkins Pond but the the larger Lake
itself thank you for clarifying
that chairman rulu my name is Tim Dunley
I'm the captain of the New Hampshire
Marine Patrol unit for the division of
State Police and I want to thank you and
The Honorable members of the committee
the opportunity to answer some questions
for representative post I can tell you
that just in listening to this um there
are statutes uh in the dees section of
of our laws that prohibit the dumpage of
sewage into our public Waters uh the the
statutes Define clearly a house Boo and
what that is and it is a very general
term that applies to any type of craft
platform or anything that has sleeping
or toilet facilities whether those are
formal facilities or temporary in nature
and in the past quite frankly a 5 gallon
bucket has been ruled a toilet facility
on a boat uh from a perspective of
what's been discussed uh for for local
authorities to regulate this I will I
will just not being a legal mind but I
can tell you that we have circumstances
where there are commercial operations on
our Lakes uh that are taking place uh in
areas where zoning on Shore are
residential only and because this is
taking place on the public Waters being
held in in trust for all of us uh those
zoning regulations do not apply when
something is happening on the water just
food for thought um but we do have
bodies of water that do restrict
houseboats and houseboats if it's a
house boat it's clearly because it has
some sort of sleeping whether temporary
or not uh accommodations as well as uh
toilet facilities uh Dees has the
authority to to inspect those facilities
and the land owner by Statute right now
who is renting a dock or or host hting a
house boat for an overnight period must
maintain logs report to Dees when this
activity is going on and and the
oversight for this activity would be
through
DS happy to answer any more questions
than we have thank you very much for
that represent
Mayville sorry it does not prohibit a
house boat from being on that body of
water as long as you know the the box is
a check for the the person that V on
property thank you Mr
chair there we go okay so just a I
reviewed that statute as well it was
2782 and it re related to overnight Ming
of house boats correct um now I'm I'm
and I my understanding is that this is a
public body of water am I correct
because it is 100 acres that is
correct now I'm wondering if um we do
have the you know the bill coming
forward but I'm wondering if that area
can be better protected by designating
that an NDA a no discharge area if or or
do we already have those statutes in law
that prohibit the discharge of that
where the homeowner who's renting that
dock would be fined or somehow you know
disciplined I I can't speak to what the
dees all the dees statutes say about
discharge but it's the person who's on
board the boat that is caught
discharging that is held responsible for
that violation every body water in our
state is a no discharge Zone it is
illegal for the boat to be capable of or
for a person to discharge any gray or
black water into our public waters on
the
state
good afternoon Mr chairman and committee
members my name is Diane Sinatra and I
live at 11 Northshore Road on Perkins
Pond I'm also a member of the Perkins
Pond protective Association I am here to
read the motion that was passed
unanimously by the membership at the
June 27th 2020 Perkins Pond protective
association meeting moved that in
recognition of the small size shallow
depth and fragility of both the water
quality and overall Ecology of Perkins
Pond and sunabe the Perkins Pond
protective Association hereby condemns
the presence of house boats Andor any
watercraft serving as such from docking
anchoring Andor Mooring on or at said
Perkins pond in accordance theto the
Perkins Pond protective Association does
hereby petition the town of snipe County
of Sullivan and state of New Hampshire
to take any and all actions as soon as
possible to prohibit the presence of
such vessels on said Perkins Pond from
this day forward passed
unanimously my home is on the same
street as the do where the makeshift
house boat has been for the past two
summers and we've all noticed increased
vegetative growth in the area where the
boat is we don't know what it where it's
coming from but it's a concern to all of
us and if I might add you know we've
it's we all know that there are rules
against dumping in the pawn but how do
you ever catch someone that if she's
doing in in the middle of the
night you no one would ever know I mean
she said she was going to the dumping
facility and the dumping facility was
closed so she did something with that
waste whether she dug a hole in the
woods
we don't know and that's what it's that
unknown that is so concerning for all of
us my husband and I are from
Massachusetts we moved up here we own
the home for 20 years we moved up here
permanently maybe two years this past
May and my children have grown up here I
now have six grandchildren and my
concern OB as all of the homeowners is
that the water
degreg you know what do we do we have to
sell it can't use the kids can't go in
the water it's just it's such a concern
it's it's heartbreaking to
watch thank you for your time and
commitment to helping us keep our
little Paradise
clean any questions representative Smith
well I'm not sure if this is a question
or a clarification but since any water
body of over 10 acres is inheld in the
public trust for all the people of New
Hampshire can an ordinance passed by
sopy be actually legal that is telling a
certain kind of boat can't be on the
water I think that is I think that's a
big issue regarding the ordinance
anyway that's not really a
question
okay see no other
questions thank you very
much
and thank and thank thank you Captain
again
for for helping us out they coming
down uh I will will close the hearing on
House Bill
and on time again we've caught
up uh all right you wantan to do
everybody would like like a five minute
break all right go we get we got a five
minute break let's go with
it come back
for we'll start again in about uh 20
after
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record representative
Jeff goaly representing Hillsboro
District 8 which is Manchester's W one
and here today to introduce po Bill 15
19 28 establishing a public boat access
donation program for operators of
non-motorized boats and requiring the
fishing game department to prepare a
report relating to such
programs um I have put a amendment in
front of each of you uh Amendment
51h um what that Amendment does is it
removes section one of the bill the
reporting requirement uh in discussion
with fish and game that information is
uh already uh as public information
Avail will be available um they
currently do that with the hike safegard
and they would have no problem doing it
with this program as well so they don't
feel that the reporting requirement is
necessary and I agree with them and took
that
out and why am I here today this came
this bill came about uh it's been a
lengthy process
um I shared a a commission to uh study
the sustainability of fish and game
department and one of the things that
came out in the report
was
um that boat access sites here in New
Hampshire
um were not being funded by all the
users of of the access sites um fishing
game maintains all the sites um and out
of the number of sites they maintain
four 43% of those
sites are available and used for cart
top uh Vehicles only which would be
canoes and
kayaks um and the way they F boat access
fund is uh funded is $5 of every
registration uh of a motorboat goes to
the boat access fund and there was no
money going in from those folks in
canoes or kayaks uh to help maintain
those facilities
uh
so the report was written and uh I came
back and uh submitted a bill back in
2019 um that bill went to the fishing
game committee and
uh that bill that I put in mandated a
$10 fee for anyone who used a access
site um here in the state of New
Hampshire um as you can imagine there
was a number of folks that were opposed
to that fee
um and fishing game the committee
retained the bill in 2019 after I put it
in uh so that we could work on it and
talk about some of the issues that were
brought up in the public
hearing um during that public hearing
there were a number of individuals
there who had testified that they'd be
willing to voluntarily
help support the access sites um knowing
that it only creates a
better site for them and also it can
increase access to New Hampshire's water
bodies for these individuals to get
their canoes and kayaks out
so when fishing game retained that bill
we worked on it and we had discussions
about how we could at least have a
vehicle for those folks who testified
that they'd like to donate and like to
participate and maintaining these access
sites um that currently aren't uh and
one of the ideas that came out was well
we do the hike safe card here in New
Hampshire that goes to search and rescue
that is a
voluntary
card uh
so the thought came out could we mirror
that and have a voluntary way of
participating and helping with boat
access here in New Hampshire uh for
those who want to take advantage of it
that have Cano and kayaks um so we
mirrored that and said that all the
money generated would go directly to
boat access through fishing game uh that
bill in fishing game in 2000 in 2020
after the retained it was amended to
basically the same exact language that's
in the build before you today that
passed the fishing game committee 14 to
nothing went to the house floor we
passed it in the house on a Voice vote
and we all know in 2020 Co came and the
Senate put a number of bills into
Omnibus bills and then tabled the rest
of them this was one of the bills that
get tabled so I'm back here today
bringing this back out hoping that we
can have a vehicle for those folks who
have canoes and kayaks and want to help
participate in the funding and create
better access and maintain the access
they have and also increase access to
our public bodies of water here in in
Hampshire have that vehicle to do that
and that's why this bill is here today
so I ask that you support that that and
like I said the amendment before you was
at request of fishing game to delete the
reporting requirement and that's all
that does and with that I will take any
questions thank you very much uh any
questions for the presenter
representative Smith thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question um I note here that um with
the hike safe card there's a certain
amount that you donate to get the hike
safe card and I don't see any specific
number it's just like someone can make a
donation and then those who have
contributed could get a sticker a card
or a letter of thanks so it seems pretty
vague I was I was thinking it was going
to be more like the hike safe card where
you did have a you know like a $25 fee
for the year or something like that if
you decided to partake and and I I I
left that open for a reason because I
felt that fishing game could deal with
that in their rules when they put this
program together
um it's fairly new it's to help out with
the program uh I'm not sure what the
cost will be to them for initial startup
or what they may have for costs going
forward um I I think by dealing with
access they have a better understanding
what that fee would be and how they
could help generate revenue for at boat
access so I left that for that reason
thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you
committee
after with the Amendments that um
representative uh goalie
mentioned if I need to say that again
for the record for the recording I
will so representative goalie made a
good overview of what um this bill is
about and and why it's
important um I want to just provide some
context for it and to answer any
questions that may make it um more
relevant to uh your perceptions of how
this program
runs just want to clarify a few details
the program is has two funding
mechanisms one is a state fund and the
other is the sportfish restoration act
which is federal
dollars the every boat regist motorized
boat um that registers in the state of
New Hampshire pays a Sur charge above
their Reg registration fee of
$5 which comes to the department
directly to be included in the Statewide
Public boat access fund under RSA
233a um no there's no sech charge or no
registration requirement for
non-motorized watercraft in the state so
there's no opportunity for those people
to contribute even if they wanted to
where it would certainly be difficult
you'd have to make a special um uh
process for them to or or active
activity to come to the department to do
that the program does not receive any
state budget money um it's
self-funded we use the Statewide Public
boat access fund the state funds to uh
obtain Federal matching dollars at a
ratio of one state dollar for three
federal dollars so it's quite quite a
good deal for us to have a larger State
Fe um to maintain this this
fund we have 135 boat access sites in
the state that the fish and game
department
maintains on um only and there are
97 great ponds in the state so there's a
lot of lakes that we don't have access
to at the moment um which would benefit
the state by um you know trying to
increase that number of those 135 sites
as representative goalie mentioned uh 77
are for trailered you uh Vehicles
trailer boats and at those sites they
are also totally available to
um non-motorized watercraft so canoes
kayaks P paddle boards and and the
like uh the remaining 58 sites are only
uh capable of handling C top
non-motorized um watercraft there's no
ramp there's no way for well there are
ramps but they're not they're not
functional for for um trailered boats
it's just not going to be uh able to
launch one of those boats on a
trailer um when I have spoken with
kayakers and canoeists and so forth
they've called in many of them think
that their tax dollars to the general
fund are supporting this progr
program and so they are unaware that
their contribut that they're not
contributing to you know the benefit
that they're receiving uh through this
program and many of them once that that
gets explained to them are are quite
willing to consider making you know
trying to contribute and and supporting
the the um the program but there's no
mechanism for that at the moment so this
bill would be very um beneficial for
easing and and making it easy easier for
people to contribute when they feel that
they want to again it would be voluntary
but I think that there's probably a lot
of people out here once this would be
advertised and and promoted around the
state that would one uh educate them to
the fact that their tax dollars don't
pay for the program and and that would
make many of them I think um feel um
potentially compelled but certainly at
least give some thought to making a
donation um representative Smith asked
you know that we didn't clarify how much
money we would ask for as a donation or
at least specify it and um I can say
that we would try and match it to the
$25 fee for the hike safe card so that
they're they're compatible to each other
so that's probably where we would go
with
that
um there are many lakes that don't have
boat access of any kind at this at this
moment I don't have the exact number I
think it may be on the order of 200
perhaps as high as 300 lakes that don't
have access not all of them would be
appropriate to have access some of them
may be too small or too too remote to
actually get there to make it cost
effective there are many lakes of course
out of we have 135 sites on 135 Lakes
but there are many lakes also that are
that are um accessible perhaps on Town
ramps but those ramps are restricted in
many cases to residential to the
residents of the town that they're in so
for the most part they're foreclose for
most of the general
public so this bill would add fairness
to the program by allowing more people
to be part of the program and and to
contribute to it and in a larger
framework it also I think would be an
investment in the economics and and
benefit uh the business businesses of
the state in that boat access and
boating is a major component of the
tourism industry that we have in the
state so it would have a a wider um
benefit to all of the citizens in the
state by increasing um the um enjoyment
of people coming to visit and therefore
May attract more people over the last
two years I've received many calls from
people who are just very surprised and
and annoyed that's one word um at the
overcrowding that we're seeing at the
boat ramps that exist now um just
because everyone was told hey it's get
outside you know recreate and that'll be
a safe way to try and make your way
through this covid pandemic that we're
suffering through at the moment but what
that what that demonstrated was the fact
that we were very close if not Beyond
The Tipping Point for having enough
access points to accommodate the tourist
industry that we want to promote for the
state so therefore if we can find a way
to help fund having more access to our
Lakes we're going to make the enjoint
the the experience that people have both
tourists and our own citizens more
enjoyable and I think that's going to
benefit um the businesses of the state
and certainly the whole population in
general so uh I think we need to think
about this opportunity also in a broader
in that broader
context I just say one more thing our
revenues and I gave a chart out there
have been very stagnant very uh stable
for the last 10 years that I've been
here and I want to point out that again
building on that tourism idea the last
time fishing game was able to buy a
property was in
2012 almost 10 years ago now when we
bought the downings landing property in
in Alton at the southern part of the bay
which um by next spring will be our
first Public Access on lein aosaki and
that's kind of surprising since this
program's been here for 19 since 1993
that it's taken that long to get onto
Leu pasak but that's an example of how
hard it is to find properties that when
we can afford or or become
available so I just want to point out
that with without more funds it's going
to be difficult to uh increase the
number of boat access sites that we can
um build or buy and then
build and I will leave it at that for
the moment and thank the chair and the
committee for allowing me to make this
presentation and I hope that you will
support this
Bill thank you thank you I have a
question or two um I G to get it
straight you have the Statewide Public
boat access fund and that is funded by
federal funds and matching State funds
from the
motorboat uh Monies to be clear I'm
using the term Statewide Public boat
access fund as it is written in the RSA
2338 colon 13 which is a $5 fee from
boat registrations in the state okay the
federal dollars are in addition to that
um they come from an excise tax and from
What's called the um the uh the
sportfish restoration act which goes
back to the
1950s and we get an apportionment from
the federal government based on uh our
state size uh that we can use when we
match it with our state funds so um it's
two different pots of money they come
together we use both to put the program
forward and you're you're looking to put
money that you would get from the
non-motorized
folks into this fund with uh correct yep
and would that increase your federal
funding uh or is that not or is it or it
doesn't go that
way we we can access the federal funds
if we have money to match right at this
particular moment we actually have more
State funds than we can get from the
federal government oh okay but we still
need more funds in order to operate I
was just trying to find out you know if
you put 10 bucks in you get 20 20 bucks
from the feds well if you put 15 bucks
in you get 30 bucks from the feds at
this particular time we we're already
have enough money to get what we need
from
them thank you is any any members of the
committee have a
have any
questions representative ghou for
question yes I have a question oh thank
you for are taking my question
um is this uh donation going to be quote
unquote asked for every
year or will people just do it when they
want to do it does anybody know it's
going to be totally voluntary um we're I
mean we haven't figured out the the
process for it I mean we might send in
an email saying hey you donated last
year would you like to um we're trying
to we'll have to find a balance for how
much we want to spend in time and and
money to gain uh or to to have people
reapply or re re
donate
um I'm not sure that that will be cost
effective I think we'll
probably let it go and put this money
towards the purpose that people are
donating for and that's to improve the
boat access opportunities in the state
um we'll have to find that balance I'm
not sure how it's working with the hike
safe card exactly but I think we're not
doing much um to promote that Beyond
just having a note up on our website and
so forth and that has shown that it's
growing organically without a lot of um
extra
effort
did answer your
question okay thank you representative
Ean thank you Mr chair thank you sir for
taking my
question would there be similar
potential Partnerships for this program
similar to how the AMC supports the hike
Safe program and therefore there would
be other supportive organizations that
could promote this program knowing that
a donation program would help the state
not try to put tax dollars taxpayer
dollars towards this but that
constituents who are interested in
improving the uh boot locations would be
able to support it like voters
associations you know Lakes associations
would there be would that opportunity be
available there's no reason why it
wouldn't be uh again I think we'd look
into that those
opportunities
um that that would again would would be
a volunteer type effort that would help
us um to to make this a more successful
opportunity and and promotion overall
and again if we could encourage outside
groups to promote it for us uh you know
there's more there's more power when
more people are doing the same thing
pulling in the same direction so I would
have to say yes we would do that you
know certainly where it's uh there's an
interest thank you
excuse me any other questions
representative
Huff thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for
testifying I'm I'm just curious is there
any idea or mechanism to actually uh
collect the funds yeah I mean is it
going to be cash are you going to be
able to take credit cards you gonna is
there something already in place for
that at these locations or is that
something that would have to be
developed well we don't take money at
any of the of the boat access locations
um they're they're free to access um
they're open
247 uh throughout the year um
so the way the fees would probably or
the the the donation would be um
accepted would be along the same lines
as we do with the house hike safe card
we'd have an online process probably and
certainly we'd have agents around the
state where people are already allowed
to buy or provided the opportunity to
buy a fishing license and so forth or
the hike safegard so those those same
locations and mechanisms would be um
used for this location I have to say
that it wouldn't be a free uh
opportunity you know there's always
going to be extra men admin cost to keep
those to a minimum but the basic yep
just okay thank
you any other
questions see none thank you very much
thank
you Colonel Jordan did you uh want this
says you want I presume you want to
speak to this bill okay
yes good afternoon my name is Colonel
actually my name is Kevin Jordan and I'm
the chief of law enforcement New
Hampshire fishing gam so Mr chairman
thanks for the opportunity there were a
couple of really good questions
that um were asked and I felt like I
might be able to Enlighten it a little
bit more I was part of the uh I was
totally against uh and I think I can say
that in a room I was totally against hik
safe when they made it a voluntary
program I felt it would never work uh I
was seeking more permanent type funding
to fund that program because we it was a
really a a program that was spinning out
of control expense wise and the
sportsmen were paying for the footing
the bill hike safe proved me very very
wrong it's been very successful in fact
last year it brought in an excess of
$300,000 now I equate some of that to co
the governor uh came out and told
everybody to get outside because it was
safe and we were
inundated uh so we slowed him down a
little bit and we said listen we got to
push hike safe and we got to tell people
this isn't the time to do these 4,000
Footers and so in the end it worked out
really well and that generated a lot of
money so I've had a lot of internal
discussions and representative goalie
has been extremely helpful in writing
this bill uh in the way he's crafted
this it has given us the flexibility I
think to do some of the things that
you're asking so my point of coming up
here was to tell you kind of what I'm
pushing for in the agency and and it's
to mirror a hike save I think it's been
very successful I would look to make
this the same or similar the other the
other reason I would like to do that
it's easier for people if we keep it
simple uh so the goal would be uh in the
third paragraph of the bill it gives the
director the ability to go to rule of uh
and J car of course would be required so
we're not going to be able to sneak in a
high fee we'll have to put in a fee that
everyone is comfortable with but we were
thinking of keeping it close to what
hike safe is we're thinking of offering
the same protection to people who buy
this as we would for hike safe so there
wouldn't be a need for folks to buy both
because they've now contributed to the
to the agency which contributes to the
search and rescue fund so if they had a
kayak pass and we had to rescue them uh
I can see us doing the same we do with
any other license that they have we
don't charge them uh for the
rescue uh so that would be an advertised
benefit we we were thinking of the fee
being very similar the $25 fee the there
is a we allow them now to we we Advocate
people to buy it online or they can come
to a license uh station and buy
it uh we have a credit card um fee that
is charged to us in in in in hike safe I
was told yesterday it's uh
$22.75 every time they use a credit card
so that reduced the money to about $22
that we receive and the the goal would
be to keep the administrative cost at a
bare minimum as Garrett explained so
that most of this money would go to
benefit the program I'm a firm believer
if I'm donating to an agency or donating
to a particular program I want my money
to go there and I would assume everybody
would want that so we try to keep the
administrative cost down now having said
that one hurdle on going to have I can
tell you from talking to folks is they
some people will be very proud of this
that they donated and they want to be
able to demonstrate the others that they
donated and the way they would ask for
that I can I can guess would be a
sticker for their boat the problem with
that is when you start doing those
things you yeah you add cost and and so
I'm not sure how we're going to get over
that hurdle yet that's one of the
reasons I don't actually give them a
hike safe card I get that call a lot
they can print off the what's on the
screen but but I don't give them an
actual car because I'm trying to keep
the cost I'm trying to make that money
go into the fund and not be diverted a
100 different ways and I would the goal
for this would be the same um I'm always
in favor of voluntary payments uh as a
citizen I like that idea I I have
changed my mind I think most people will
take advantage of it and I'm I and I
like Garrett have received a number of
calls from people who have ctop boats
that do want to contribute and there
isn't a way to do that currently this
bill would give us the ability to say
you can do it here uh in hopes of
opening up more access later so access
is something that we as a state are
concerned about we're losing it and so
anytime that we can gain funding um you
know to purchase that precious access I
think is key so um so hopefully that
answers the
questions thank you Mr Mr
chairman any uh any additional questions
for the
colonel seeing n thank you very
much and last speaker is Joseph Mullen
from the Congressional Sportsman's
Foundation perfect good after afternoon
Mr chairman honorable members of the
House resources Recreation and
development committee my name is Joe
Mullen I'm from Grafton Massachusetts
and I'm the north eastern states
assistant manager for the Congressional
Sportsman's Foundation I appear before
you this afternoon to testify in support
of House Bill
1528 um I will be supplementing my
testimony with a letter of support so
I'll be extremely quick um first and
foremost something I think worth
mentioning and I'm sure everyone here in
the room saw um this build is introduced
by someone who has a tenure history of
working exceptionally well with the New
Hampshire fishing game department
representative goalie is the co-chair of
the New Hampshire legislative
Sportsman's caucus and the vice
president of the National Assembly of
Sportsman's caucuses executive Council
he has led the charge in securing
additional funding mechanisms for the
Department such as the hike safe card
and House Bill 1528 is his most recent
effort towards ensuring that those who
enjoy the state's natural resources May
contribute towards the care and up of
the facilities that get us there in 2020
alone New Hampshire's Sportsmen and
women generated around $18 million for
conservation through the unique user pay
public benefits structure known as the
American system of conservation funding
um identifying additional opportunities
to increase the funding for the
Department that will allow it to
continue continue providing exceptional
services for all recreators uh once
again I would just like to reiterate my
support for House Bill 1528 and I'd like
to thank representative goalie for
bringing it Forward I thank you for your
time thank you very much any
questions any questions for the person
testifying just a
moment seeing none thank you very much
than
you
okay okay the looks like we we have
finished the
uh 1528 so with that I will
declare the meeting adjourned for 1528
the
hearing and I will open the hearing now
on House Bill
the
uh
okay chair recognizes representative
Smith who will introduce the bill good
afternoon Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record I'm Suzanne
Smith I represent the towns of Plymouth
Hein and holderness in Grafton County
District 8 and I am here to introduce
House Bill 1227 relative to the
definition of prime
Wetland
and that's all I have to
say good well I've far as the chair is
concerned you're just introducing the
bill you don't have to put in a pink
card or anything like that no I wasn't
going to oh okay that's oh you I'm
leaving that for the sponsor when he
returns oh you just oh you just I
thought you just collect
them right thank you very much uh uh no
not not for he can uh he can fill it out
when he comes uh for the for the
edification of the folks in the audience
uh the uh the prime sponsor of the bill
is representative grassy he
has he's come down with the the co like
so many others and he cannot be in today
uh so uh what I will do I will accept
testimony on the bill as if we're go you
know we were having a normal hearing and
uh I will but instead of adjourning I
will just continue the hearing put a
continuance to a Time certain and uh
we'll we'll it'll it there'll be a
publication on uh of when that
we will continue the hearing that will
be then allow representative grassy a
chance to speak to his bill so with
that we
gota look and
see people we have uh
from see some I think I'll go with
someone who supports the bill Uh Kevin
Nyan
supporting the uh supporting the
bill good afternoon thank you Mr
chairman for the record Kevin Nyan I
manage the environmental office at do uh
and I am here to speak in support of the
bill and uh specifically uh the bill as
introduced on lines 21 through 23 um it
was a number of years ago now I think I
worked with uh representative grassy uh
to identify some uh concerns that the
Department of Transportation had with
respect ECT to Prime Wetlands uh and so
I'm speaking specifically to that part
of the bill which um would acknowledge
that the department experiences
challenges with prime Wetlands when and
their buffers when they're located
within the RightWay and it affects our
ability to maintain the uh
infrastructure in a in an efficient way
um by example uh we have a a current
project in Sandwich where we are doing a
small covert upgrade which if not for
the presence of a prime Wetland or a
prime Wetland buffer in and at the right
of way would not have needed a permit
from the department but would have been
able to be done under a notification and
simply because there's a prime wetland
in the vicinity it triggered us to have
a uh the need for a permit which delays
the maintenance that we have to that we
have to do so I'm happy to answer any
questions that you might have I'm I'm
I'm grateful for the opportunity to work
with the committee and um on on the bill
so thank
you any questions from Mr
Nan seeing none U Mr chair I believe
there was a
question okay uh if I recall when they
were doing 93 down in Wind Exit 3 I
think it is wasn't there an issue like
this there how does that compare to this
what you're talking about so the two uh
thank you for the question um the two
issues I would they're they're similar
in that they're both Transportation
related in the work that the department
does on the highway I would say that
they're different in that the expansion
of the highway um outside of the
existing right of way uh down in i93 is
different than the maintenance type work
that this bill um would kind of
alleviate those those concerns for the
Department recognizes that when we are
we do have those larger projects and
they're outside the right of way uh
impacting locally designated Prime
Wetlands it does introduce maybe an
untenable impact at times and so those
are treated very differently but similar
in that they're both Transportation
related okay thank you you're
welcome anyone
else thank you very much thank you I
should announce that uh we since we will
be having
another continuation of the hearing on
this uh I will I will allow and would
allow uh anyone who who's does testify
today can also Testify the next
hearing I think especially if it a long
uh long time difference
Hiatus when uh when we get back together
again uh recognize Gary
Abbott represent presenting the
associated general
contractors thank you very much uh
chairman rulu uh committee members for
the record my name is Gary Abbott I'm
the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire um I've done a paper I've
discussed this issue I think four
previous times that this legislation has
not passed the legislature and I think
today I just want to kind of give you
may something I haven't done before
first this bill is about prime wetlands
and I want to make sure the committee
understands Prime Wetlands Prime
Wetlands is a designation by a
municipality for a given area that they
want to preserve and they have to meet
criteria that's in the state statute
there's 12 different
criteria but the biggest criteria is it
has to be two acres or more where it
can't get that designation now this was
put in place way before many many years
have gone by and rules and regulations
have changed for wetlands and so what I
want to discuss is that this is about we
had many many years ago uh some very
vague language of what a town could do
and and designate we had lots of issues
I was part of a statutory change to the
prime Wetlands that we put in this 50
foot across because we started to have
culverts Brooks included in this
designation which when you have this
designation Dees when you go for a
permit treats it differently than a
regular Wetlands they consider it higher
because the municipality said it was
important but it doesn't necessarily
have to be any more important than two
acres up the road that wasn't
designated so this today this bill that
keeps coming back keeps talking about
this 50F foot cut off so you have a
two-acre wetland and you have a culvert
or a brook or something going up that
can be disputed by the consultant of
whether this is part of a wetlands and
the legislature agreed to do this 50
foot cut off we really haven't had any
issues with permits I haven't heard any
great issues from the perspective of
construction that I'm talking about
today this comes up and a lot of the
testimony you will hear in favor of the
bill because I've heard it before
is that you know you want to protect the
wildlife or the the impact is too great
we need to designate it now you have to
understand Prime Wetlands it's not a
requirement to even delineate the area
you can use a photograph the town can
use a photograph and say this area we
want to designate as Prime they didn't
look at it they didn't get in there with
Consultants it's not a requirement we
have many prime Wetlands that are done
by aerial photographs and it's on
private property so I feel bad for the
private property owner because a town
can do this without their permission
that's the current law I'm really not
debating that but that's what can happen
today or any Prime
Wetland our biggest sticking point has
been if you start to expand this
definition without the property owner's
permission you know now you're starting
to get into a future taking if
development happens but let's skip all
that let's go to I'm the contractor
developer home builder Timber Harvester
whoever goes onto a property to do
something I have to comply with the
wetlands bureau's
regulations they're not easy they have
thought of everything they've made
modifications over the years that's when
we have to as a developer comes in he
has to delineate he has to look at it we
get to do
mitigation we get to do a lot of
different things we have to avoid and
minimize we have to take a lot of things
into consider a but if it has this
designation the dees calls it a special
resource area and almost Cuts us off
from those negotiations of happening
that's why we fight so hard on this bill
year after year because it sets a new
standard that's very hard to overcome
even
though environmentally technically we
could mitigate or make compensation for
it and that's why we fight hard on this
designation that's more it's just a
designation a prime wet lunch does not
necessarily mean it's the best of the
best it just means the town designated
it I'd love to be in the town's position
towns get to designate it there's some
towns that suddenly needed a road they
get to D desate it but a developer does
not get to do that a home owner does not
get to do that so some will say years
ago I tried to work on this bill and
come to a negotiation but I wanted
landowner approval I clearly wanted land
if the property owner agrees that they
would Encompass these smaller areas it's
their property I say it's okay that's
they're making that choice but to leave
it that a group of citizens can get
together go to a city and designate it
without the approval it bothers me and
then it bothers me what we have to do if
we go in to try to do something with
property so that's why this bill I've
handed out um a paper and I I just want
to highlight
this I have Consultants I have Wetland
scientists that are members of our
organization I have contractors I have
sand and gravel sites that get involved
in all of this but I wanted to give you
this sample and we've used this
before the top picture on the back of
the position paper is a prime Wetlands
now without the 50 without you know you
can't go beyond the 50 Foot the bottom
one is the same development but if you
Encompass and you allow these
tributaries or areas where less than 50
feet you could Encompass all of this
property and this is just to show you
this is a real property in New Hampshire
and it's to show the difference we feel
like we solved this issue when we put in
the 50 Foot and I would hope this
committee would really look at it with
new eyes and say
maybe we should leave it because the
current regulations I'm not even sure in
the long haul this designation still
needs to be in place what really needs
to happen is Dees somebody needs to fund
a study to save the most valuable
Wetlands I was hoping I would say three
years ago I thought there was a study
going to be done by Dees to come up with
those water bodies that were very
valuable because I don't think this
designation makes that
designation but another process in which
we can say to the these are the ones to
save we're for we're for supporting
environmental measures that protect the
environment but the prime Wetlands
procedure doesn't necessarily do that it
just is a
designation I know I went on and on
probably longer than my five minutes
chairman but I would be happy to answer
any questions I would hope that the
committee uh does not support this uh
changing the def and the boundary it's
really about this 50 foot it's not about
the wetlands regulations it's not about
all these other things it's about
expanding the area with that I would end
my
testimony thank you any questions by
anyone from the
committee seeing none thank you very
thank
you uh Ron Lamar
karski
Marik conter cook opposing the
bill good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is Ron
clarik I'm a consultant Forester have
been consultant Forester since 1980 uh
my clients include private land owners
quasi public such as a Boy Scout and
quite a few towns and
cities um as a Forester conservationist
I I respect Wetlands appreciate the
value of wetlands and in my Timber sales
I religiously leave buffer zones along
Wetlands streams and rivers lakes you
know and water bodies drenal pools that
type of thing but uh due to things like
terrain or boundary lines or access
points um sometimes I have to cross
intermittent streams or streams and um
and if they are attached to a prime
Wetland it does become quite a uh quite
a bureaucratic cast to to deal with
these things as previous speaker
mentioned uh extra costs for the
permitting process there already is a
permitting process that that we have to
go through if we are going to be
Crossing wetlands and when you add uh
additional paperwork expense to the
landowner uh my time uh that's something
that I would normally try to protect try
to minimize the impact now there is a
big difference between a Timber Harvest
that I do where I enter the property
maybe once every 15 or 20 years versus a
developer going in and putting in houses
and you end up with backyards and tennis
courts and streets and that have storm
water issues and things like that so um
I would kind of oppose the bill as
presented but if it was to exempt
forestry and passive Recreation for
Trails uh you know for hiking cross
country skiing that type of thing I
wouldn't have a problem with it but but
uh it does put quite a hassle on on on a
land owner and uh and I I would having
dealt with these and it was several
towns even my own clients towns it it it
dealing with people who aren't in the
town that don't have the environmental
background it can get very confusing to
them so for that reason I I oppose this
bill as
presented thank you very much any
questions
uh from the uh testifier
being done thank you very much thank
you chair calls
Kimberly is it
Pace
peace representing
nanners yes hi good afternoon everyone
uh my name is Kimberly peace I am the
senior en enal coordinator for H Tanner
Associates and today I'm here to speak
on behalf of the na New Hampshire
Association of natural resource
scientists uh which goes by the acronym
of nners and for those of you that
aren't aware we are the organization in
the state that is the collective of
wetlands and soil scientists and we have
looked at this bill as it has come
forward over the past several years and
we are in I'm speaking today as the an
opposition on behalf of nanners for this
bill Mr Abbot introduced several
important points about what prime
wetlands are and how they are protected
um it is up to a municipality to have
those Wetlands identified I I would say
that um as Mr Abbott pointed out um in
most situations a professional Wetland
scientist is brought in to do that but
in some situations for smaller towns
they do determine what the prime
wetlands are and um that's been a
process that has occurred over time
since the origin the origin of that
Prime Wetland um part of the RSA and the
intent as as he said was to protect
those valuable important resources to
our state if you think about a wetland
that's larger than two acres that's an
important resource it's large enough
that it's going to have a lot of
important Wildlife functions functions
for water quality protection and so we
do support a protection of those Prime
Wetlands but the reason why we
opposition to this bill is that it it
picks up those small narrow connections
and if you notice in the second part of
the bill there there is that addition
that revision that really um oversteps
the the 50 Foot width and goes into some
of these narrower Wetland channels and
when you think about the Wetland
functions as a professional Wetland
scientist and how we approach what's
valuable and what functions and
resources do those Wetland fingers bring
to the the table they're not as
essential as that Prime Wetland body
that is is worth the protection and and
as Mr Abbott I think Pro provided for
you some mapping there is a substantial
increase in the prime Wetland area that
would be covered by this change and what
happens is once you have a prime Wetland
if you need a wetland permit that Prime
Wetland is considered a priority
resource area that's under the new rules
that were changed several years ago so
the New Hampshire DS Wetland rules has
several characters of a wetland that
gives it the highest level of protection
and if you a priority resource area
which is the prime Wetland you have the
highest protection and so your number
one way to to if you want to affect that
Wetland you have to provide full a very
solid uh avoidance minimization and and
you have to really look at that Wetland
it's very well scrutinized and and so we
want this protection for our best
Wetlands for our finest w wetlands in
the state but what we don't want it for
as as uh as Kevin Nyan was spoke so well
of is these smaller Wetland channels
where we have stream crossings that have
pipes for example so in order for you to
permit a project that has a pipe if that
were Prime Wetland you would first of
all have to prove Ironclad that you have
no way to not cross that Wetland and
then number two you would have to
provide mitigation for that and that's a
sizable challenge for some of our
municipali who have small projects think
about how many times your roads cross
pipes and those pipes have to be
upgraded over time and when we end up
with these small Wetland fingers it just
provides additional layer of protection
to the wetlands that we don't think were
are valuable and worthy of that extra
layer of
protection and the second reason I would
say that we are opposing to this bill
it's not so much that it's complicated
to to um come into effect as it's it's
based on less of firm Wetland science
than we would like to see in in such a
proposal so if the state wants to say we
think we need an increase in our Prime
Wetlands what we'd really like to see is
organization to come to nanners and ask
us as Wetland scientists and the people
who are out in the field and looking at
these what's our important resources
what are we missing the language in here
is just a little bit too vague and it's
it's it's reaching for a lot of
different Wetlands that maybe don't have
that value that really need that
additional
and I would also say as a final point we
are in support of Mr nyan's proposal
that New Hampshire do um be exempt from
Wetland Prime Wetlands especially within
the dot rways because they are so
challenging and because they do present
such a problem um and I think that
that's a separate situation and so we're
proposing opposition to this bill as it
it stands but we're not in opposition to
his point I think his point is very
valid but unfortunately I think I think
that this bill just doesn't come forward
with enough science behind it to provide
additional Prime Wetland protection that
is necessary at this point and uh if the
legislator was willing to work together
with nanners to come up with ways in
which we really think this needs to be
changed and in a valid manner then we
would support that and be willing to
work with
them any questions from uh the
testifier seeing none thank thank you
very
much Jason stock
from New Hampshire Timber Owners
Association it's been a long
day patience
out I failed to mention in my testimony
earlier we do
represent so my you're doing your
part
oh wonderful
actually there you go thank
you
thank you um uh again for the second
time today for the for the record I'm
Jason stock I'm the executive director
of the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association I think this morning I
failed to mention our our membership and
kind of who we are and why we would have
an interest in a Wetlands Bill we
represent Timberland owners and these
are
these range from companies like
warehouser that own hundreds of
thousands of acres to small tree farms
folks that own 10 12 15 20 acres cut
their own firewood burn it in their wood
stove we Al also represent businesses
that derive their income or their
livelihood from Forest Products and it's
the entire food chain it's Consulting
Foresters loggers
Sawmills log truck drivers yes paper
mills and biomass power biomass energy
plants um and pellet mills and you can
firewood processors you can go on and on
we have about 1300 members our
membership owns or manages about a
million acres of land in in the state of
New Hampshire so we cover a lot of
territory we have we we manage a lot of
land and as you heard from from Mr
claric who spoke earlier who's who's a
member of ours we our members have an
interest we love trees um we love
Wildlife we manage for all these things
when we do we do management it's you
know it's multiple Resource
Management um and so that's why I spoke
earlier on a recreation issue we manage
Trails things of that nature so our
interest in in this bill is on that land
are wetlands and in 33 towns in the
state of New Hampshire they have opted
to designate Wetlands a number of
wetlands within their jurisdiction or
their political jurisdiction as
Prime my introduction to Prime Wetlands
really came about it was right around
the time that the
Shoreland um the Shoreland Protection
Law was was was coming into coming into
being I got a call from a Forester that
said hey I'm being told I can't use this
road that I've used for years and years
and years and years with this client and
this was down in the kind of the um
Madbury area of the state barington
Madbury I thought well gez you know it's
near a Wetlands could this possibly have
something to do with the new Shoreland
Protection Law no what it did was it had
to do with this what at the time was a
change to the prime Wetlands law that
required a 100 foot buffer up until that
point and as you heard from Gary Abbott
a lot of the v a lot of the definitions
and terms in the law were kind of vague
and up into that point the way the law
read was if you're going to do timber
harvesting in or adjacent well what's
adjacent and and so these Foresters
again as you heard from Ron they use
their professional judgment they go out
there and say yep you know it's getting
soft over there I'm going to stay out of
that area I'm not going to harvest there
Etc well you put into statue
a definite distance 100 feet now that
truck road which had been used for years
and
years it was 100 feet from the side of
that Wetland can't do it it's within the
buffer and so we looked at it and we
said geez this is you know this is not
we didn't believe this was in the spirit
of the law everyone agrees Forest I
think most people would agree forestry
Forest management and all the things
associated with are a good thing but yet
we we have a law here that's designed to
protect Wetlands but at the same time
can be can become a hurdle to that and
so that was my introduction to Prime
wetlands and as we got into it and I
started getting calls from other
Foresters saying hey I can no longer
access the back 40 because I have to
cross a prime Wetland and in order for
me to do that I have to obtain a
standard dredge and fill major project
permit this project there's just not
enough wood or not enough money in wood
chips and cordwood to sustain that and
so you know we started I started getting
calls I don't get a lot of calls I
probably get a couple a year and you'd
say well that's not a big deal well if
you're that landowner or the family that
owns that property it is a big deal and
so this bill which expands what can be
eligible for a prime Wetland
designation really starts to become a
problem for us because it affects it
really does have an impact on forestry
and Forest management and the ability
and and again how it affects
us most people if there's cat and
Ninetails growing out there there's no
trees you're not going to harvest it
most people say Jason what's the big
deal there's no trees out there to worry
about anyway well if you picture a
wetland and kind of picture we used to
always call this the finger and toe Bell
and those who' have been on the
committee for a while know that that Ty
for this I see representative Smith the
finger Infamous finger and toe Bell if
you think of a wetland as a as a hand
and you have the palm of your hand as
the the body of the Wetland and then you
have inlets and Outlets that occur to it
well if you have a if you have a piece
of if you have to go obviously that that
Palm is your cat and Ninetails kind of
where the water is and you say all right
I'm going to go around that to access
the back 40 well now I've got a finger
sticking out and maybe there's a
property line there across the first
knuckle and I get well how do I get to
the back 40 without cross without
Crossing that do I go and try to
negotiate with the neighbor is that even
an option and so does the topography
even allow it and so what this does is
it not only has the potential to take
land out of forest management directly
but it also cuts off access to other
parts of the property where you may say
well that Back 40 that's high and dry
you can cut that to until you're till
you're happy well I can't get to it or
in order for me to get to it I have to
obtain a standard dredge and fill major
project permit for a Timber Harvest I
have to hire a wetland scientist to come
in and do the assessment and design or
engineer a Crossing to cross this finger
and so um that's why this bill is is is
problematic that's why we have opposed
it for the last I think three to four
times it's it's been through the mill
here and and that's why we're we're here
again
today opposing
it I think I think given the given the
hour I and and the fact that you're
going to be hearing more about this
later I'd be happy to try to answer any
questions the one thing I do want to do
before I lose the the microphone here I
I gave you copies of wet the wetlands
permit application for forestry and the
state best management practices for
forestry a common misperception is that
it's the wild west out there in the
woods we're out there cutting wood and
you know fire up the skitters let's go
let's go cut some wood today boys we
have
regulations we have and there are
multiple agencies that watch us we have
Dees we have forest rangers through the
division of forest and lands we have a
Timber we even have the the tax folks
the New Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration and the timber tax we
have a the state has a Timber tax
assessor who visits I would dare say
almost every single Timber Harvest
across the state um so we have a lot of
people watching what happens in the
woods they all know what the regulations
are um although Dr Dr does not regulate
or have jurisdiction over uh Wetlands
rules they certainly interact and cross
communicate with these others and if
they see something going wrong they call
up their friend at their their local
forest ranger or Dees person and say hey
I think you guys need to get out here
there's a problem on the the stock Tree
Farm we've got a real a real mess you
need to come out so there are rules
there are regulations in place and this
this is absent Prime Wetlands we have a
permit process we just went through the
whole exercise with the es for the last
several years updating that so there's a
process in place and there is there's at
least three agencies watching the shop
adding another layer with prime wetlands
and elevating that permit to a standard
dredge and fill major project permit it
just doesn't work for forestry you heard
it from Ron I could parade in here
another half dozen Foresters and they
could all have their story about you
know the Dame Tree Farm up in up in
lonia Guilford near the airport where he
had a Micro Burst blow down a bunch of
pine couldn't get to it because there
was a prime Wetland between his log
landing and where the the the the blow
down Micro Burst hit and it was an old
tote road but because it was a prime
Wetland you know he couldn't get there I
mean I could parade in folks to give you
those stories I I'll spare you that I've
gotten the calls I know them so again I
I do appreciate your time um and I you
know we'll continue I'm sure to continue
to have this
conversation but again I just would urge
on this particular Bill to just vote itl
and I think as was suggested earlier I
think that you know it may be time to
take a closer look at just Prime
wetlands in general what is it you know
with Dees and the level of scrutiny that
they're out there doing now the wetlands
laws have
evolved well past what they were when
this when this law came onto the books I
think it may be time to ask the question
what is the necessity of this um or is
it really accomplishing is it truly the
best of the best that's being protected
so with that I'll I'll uh conclude my
testimony I'd be happy to try to answer
any
questions any questions by members of
the
committee seeing
none just just checking are you all
awake I've done that before I
know thank you very much thank you for
your
time uh Mr Patrick
Hackley representing division of force
LS and do not say whether you support or
oppose the bill that's correct chairman
Rulo uh thank you uh and the members of
the committee for the opportunity to
speak um we do not have a formal
position but I did want to offer some
comments um so again my name is Patrick
Hackley I'm the relatively new director
for the division of forest and
lands um and I did check with our forest
management staff and we have had some
challenges with uh Prime Wetlands laws
that currently exists are the the
ability of municipalities to Define
their own Prime Wetlands so I'll just
read some comments very broadly I won't
get into um fingers toes heads and
shoulders like my predecessor Jason St
but we have encountered those those
fingers and toes and the issues they
cause in terms of forest management so
as most of you know the division of
forest and lands uh we're the state
agency charged with the execution of all
matters uh forestry uh in the
jurisdiction of the state
um as such we we support responsible
Forest management obviously we are we
need to be the standard bearers of good
forestry on on public lands and we go
through I think it's a 14-step process
to plan our our tumber harvest in a very
careful way with a
um a team of of Forestry professionals
Wildlife professionals and it's actually
a two-year planning process before a
machine even gets on the ground we've
we've spent um time creating a report
with with detailed maps of all the
sensitive areas on that Forest before we
even cut a stick of wood so it's a very
um careful we we try to practice
textbook forestry on state lands as we
should um our concern with this bill is
the unintended impacts it has to Forest
management as has already been well
articulated allowing these narrow strips
to be designated as Prime Wetlands as
the potential to impact the state's
ability as well as private land owners
ability to access portions of their
property as as Jason Illustrated so well
earlier um so in its current form
enhancing
this expanding the the definition of a
prime Wetland through these narrow
strips has has really created
administrative burden for us we've had a
couple of encounters with towns and
we've had to um we worked things out uh
but in one case where we did a a Timber
Harvest about 15 years ago uh apparently
at some point during that 15year period
the town hired a a consultant who
expanded the boundary of that that
Wetland the prime Wetland um and we
never got a notification until we we
issued our um our intent to cut and uh
our our notice of intent and they said
well you can't have that Crossing there
now because it's a prime Wetland I said
well we you know so we worked it out DS
came out we worked it out with our state
Foresters but it it did stop you know
stop the train and we had to have an
education experience there so our
forestry staff has encountered recent
difficulties in the planning and
execution of our harvesting operations
on state reservations due to Prime
Wetland designations Brading this
definition has the St has the strong
potential to increase those challenges
for us so we are concerned that if this
um expanded definition passes in uh in
the in the new definition of a prime
Wetland that not only the state but also
private Forest land owners um are going
to face another regulatory hurdle that
um you know if if they it's kind of the
death by a Thousand Cuts if they have
another you know another thing they have
to do to be able to cut wood on their
land they may consider alternative uses
that may be less desirable than growing
trees and providing wildlife habitat
which is what our division is all about
and what we want to see uh be promoted
going forward so with that I'll just
conclude my comments and Happ to take
any
questions okay any uh comments or
questions from or any any questions no
comments just questions from the uh
members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you and finally last but not least Ari
poock representing the home
builders good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh my name is
arri poock I'm with the fir Gallagher
firm in conquer and registered lobbyist
for the New Hampshire Home Builders um
like the others uh we also have added
our voice to the corus year after year
of opposing the bill I think it's three
or four I know this H is going to uh you
you'll have an oncore performance of
this hearing later in the month or next
month and I won't take any more time
than necessary simply to State our
position that uh wetlands are adequately
protected in the state of New Hampshire
uh there is already an onerous
uh permitting process to affect and fill
uh Wetlands for development uh there are
already mitigation avoidance and
minimization standards uh that put uh
those permits uh on the top shelf and
difficult to reach uh and Prime Wetland
designations uh would simply put
additional land off the table or farther
from the table for development and so
the home builders oppose uh those
standards and believe that the state and
its resources are adequately protected
by the current state of the law
I'll be back for the Encore performance
but until then thank you for
listening thank you very much any
questions from the
committee I seeing none and looking at
the time we uh I will
adjourn 1227 excuse me I will not
adjourn I will
continue
1227 uh at a it will it will be it will
be posted in the
calendar we caught up we caught
up
up no n unless it becomes
obvious
huh Jon is yeah let's let's talk
on well it's it's so it's so
complicated
don't
[Music]
why don't you why
don't yeah
uh you know I could ask I could ask
Heather she could now that we got the
the now that we have the draw why don't
we just throw them in the
drawers oh is
it GE I thought it was oh oh was what we
had was all the
bills oh we had all the 28 bills
think no no those are all say no those
are all 28 bills I
think yeah they right they had today's
they oh yeah oh yeah
they yeah that was every
bill yeah talk to you later I got to go
to work yeah oh me go to work you work
for yourself I do that's what happen I
got an aw you know my brother my brother
has my brother has a practice does he in
in Connecticut and every every time he's
mowing his grass he is thinking about
the money he's
losing
weers yes now you you I don't know if
you wouldn't have it yet you probably
have it in the fishing game I have fish
game yeah yeah it turns out Huff got
two he got two well because he he's in h
uh he's in uh in um go in labor and he
got so so he got one put it in labor but
now he's come here and so she put it
there so you just got here
late but uh I don't know maybe she'll
put one in for you because you're
replacing uh you're replacing what was
her name she she
never yeah see what she's got but yeah
you probably have you probably have
two and thank you for uh thank
you I didn't realize being on the end
table that you're going to get hit with
all
that that you know you know you know
that's probably you're right it's
probably a
God I'm
[Music]
glad